merci monsieur le Président alors
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le texte déposé au Sénat présente pour
cette mission des crédits en hausse ce
qui n'était pas le cas dans la maquette
budgétaire déposée le 26 septembre alors
cette hausse elle est uniquement liée au
contexte inflationnisme et au dispositif
de soutien en consommateurs elle n'est
pas vraiment liée à une augmentation de
la politique de soutien aux différents
sujets que nous allons aborder cet
après-midi et notamment des sujets qui
nous sont chers comme la biodiversité la
transition écologique par exemple mais
surtout en fait ce budget il reste
encore à définir si j'en crois l'annonce
du 20 octobre avec une concertation
nationale sur le mix énergétique et un
nouveau débat sur la relance du
nucléaire organisée par la CNDP juste
pour mémoire 11 débats ont eu lieu sur
ce sujet depuis 2004 mais c'est la même
chose pour la transition écologique
puisque le 21 octobre nous avons eu le
droit à la présentation du volet climat
et biodiversité du Conseil national de
la refondation et qu'on nous a annoncé
en même temps l'ouverture d'une
concertation pour parler de France
nation verte alors monsieur le ministre
je vais avoir un développement plus
spécifique sur le programme 380 puisque
c'est la nouveauté de l'année et que
vous êtes ici dans la maison des
collectivités donc ce sujet leur est
cher alors déjà je suis vraiment au
regret de dire que nous transmettre le
30 octobre une note datée du 30 novembre
pardon une note datée du 25 octobre
alors que nous avons demandé à vos
services des précisions sur ce programme
continuellement au cours du mois de
novembre c'est un peu dommage alors
cette note elle ventile les deux
milliards de crédits alors heureusement
pour nous il existe la radio et les
journaux donc on avait à peu près réussi
à reconstituer les données que nous
avons eu dans cette note il y a deux
jours mais en fait ce que j'ai envie de
dire c'est qu'en plus vous savez
anticiper parce que au salon des mers
vous avez été en capacité de présenter
un beau document aux élus locaux alors
bon déjà pour tout le monde cette
répartition prévisionnelle elle n'est
que prévisionnelle puisqu'il est bien
dit que tous les crédits sont
entièrement fongibles d'une ligne à
l'autre alors comment est-ce que vous
allez faire si les crises sont
effectivement décentralisés parce que
quand vous allez pouvoir les reprendre
sur une enveloppe qui aura été donnée un
préfet pour venir abonder une autre qui
aurait besoin de plus de crédit mais
alors surtout la note cette fameuse note
elle dit qu'il n'y a ce programme n'a
pas vocation à double nonner des
dispositifs existants mais alors comment
pouvez-vous expliquer un programme de
lutte contre l'érosion côtière alors
qu'il existe déjà des crédits dans le
programme 180 comment pouvez-vous
prévoir un programme de prévention des
inondations alors qu'il existe déjà un
fond de prévention des risques naturels
majeurs comment pouvez-vous parler de la
protection des encycloniques alors qu'il
existe déjà décrit dans le 180 comment
pouvez-vous financer la stratégie
nationale de la biodiversité alors que
c'est le cœur du programme 113
alors si par ailleurs le programme 362
en fait il consacrait déjà tout un tas
de crédit à la rénovation des bâtiments
publics au développement du tri à la
valorisation des déchets à la
densification et le renouvellement
urbain c'est le fond friche à la
restructuration des locaux d'activités à
la biodiversité à la prévention des
risques à la résilience en fait ce
programme 380 c'est un recyclage du
programme 362 de la mission plan de
relance ce qui est très bien si vous
faites de l'économie circulaire ça tombe
bien c'est le sujet de cet après-midi
alors mais monsieur le ministre vous
nous avez justifié le besoin de ce
programme 380 pour avoir des crédits
décentralisés mais j'ai envie de vous
dire j'étais en ministère on sait très
bien gérer des crédits décentralisés
avec les bobs régionaux alors pourquoi
vous n'avez pas affecté ces lignes de
crédit sur le 113 et sur le 181 avec
après des enveloppes régionales qui
auraient permis d'avoir une véritable
lisibilité sur les moyens engagés par ce
gouvernement pour la prévention des
risques pour la biodiversité pour les et
pour tout un tas de sujets que j'ai déjà
évoqué précédemment alors surtout moi
cette enveloppe budgétaire elle me fait
craindre un saupoudrage 2 milliards 2
milliards sur quatre ans parce que ce
sont deux milliards d'autorisation
d'engagement j'ai juste vous prendre un
seul exemple vous avez une ligne pour
l'éclairage public 150 millions d'Ao je
vais vous donner un exemple 150000
habitants qui bénéficient déjà d'un parc
complètement rénové vous savez le coup
de changer tous les lampadaires pour
passer au LED 108 millions d'euros deux
communes 108 millions d'euros vous pour
toute la France entière 150 millions
d'euros sur quatre ans le compte n'y
sera pas l'écologie ça coûte cher il
faut s'en donner les moyens alors en
pied en réalité le crédit décentralisé
ça sera quand même des crédits
recentralisés quasiment 30% du programme
et soit la main des préfets de région
notamment le Franprix notamment le
fondaturation et le reste est à la main
d'organismes nationaux pour 270 millions
je pense ici au fond pour les déchets ou
encore financement de la stratégie
nationale de la biodiversité qui sera
assurée par l'ADEME donc après avoir
parlé du fond vert sans transition je
vais passer sur le deuxième gros morceau
des crédits qui nous sont affectés à
savoir les énergies alors heureusement
pour le gouvernement en 2023 vous allez
avoir une recette exceptionnelle due aux
énergies renouvelables de près de 39
milliards d'euros alors sur ces 39
milliards disons-le bien ici 19
milliards sont des reliquats des
exercices 2021 et 2022 alors bien sûr
tout ceci ne transparaît absolument pas
dans la maquette budgétaire donc le
citoyen qui veut s'y retrouver il est
perdu pourquoi je vous dis ça c'est
parce qu'en fait après nous avoir fait
supprimer dans la loi de finances pour
2021 le casse transition énergétique
vous le reconstruisez cette année en
fait en affectant directement des
recettes à l'intérieur du programme pour
venir financer des dépenses tentez si
bien que l'ensemble des coûts des
boucliers des amortisseurs dont on
discutera à l'article 42 terres
certainement l'article le plus cher de
ce PLF
on a plus de
45 50 milliards de coups qui
transparaissent uniquement dans l'action
17 nouvellement créée je la cite
protection des consommateurs 9 milliards
mais pourquoi ne voulez-vous pas faire
une vérité du coup auprès des
consommateurs c'est important de le dire
combien coûte le soutien aujourd'hui au
pouvoir d'achat des ménages j'ai fait un
petit calcul l'ensemble des dispositifs
que porte ce ministère en 2022 on était
à 50,9 milliards d'euros en 2023 on sera
à 64,3 milliards d'euros et par ailleurs
j'ai juste un petit problème je n'ai pas
trouvé où sont inscrits le 1 milliard 5
annoncé le 16 novembre pour le
dispositif gros rouleur juste pour
mémoire en 2022 ce dispositif était
financé par le programme 174 donc
peut-être que l'enveloppe sera encore
amené à grossir alors en parlant de vous
monsieur Béchu l'ancien ministre Borlo a
dit c'est le ministre qui fera le plus
pour le pouvoir d'achat des Français
c'est très certainement vrai au regard
de tout ce que je viens de citer comme
coup mais attention le pouvoir d'achat
ne doit pas se faire au détriment d'une
un vrai transition écologique nous
aurons l'occasion d'en parler cet
après-midi aujourd'hui ma prime rénove
on ne peut pas compter les dossiers
comme le présent de la République ce
n'est pas une politique efficace que de
dire qu'on a fait tant aujourd'hui ma
prime rénove à 86% ce sont des
monogestes ce sont des mesures de
pouvoir d'achat ce ne sont pas des
mesures pour la transition du parc et un
dernier sujet le soutien au véhicule
aujourd'hui 80% des véhicules sont
produits à l'étranger ce n'est pas une
mesure en faveur de notre souveraineté
donc monsieur le ministre nous émettrons
un avis favorable sur ces crédits car on
ne peut pas laisser de côté les Français
face à l'inflation mais en tout cas ce
n'est pas un budget de l'écologie
merci nous passons maintenant la parole
à Hervé Moret rapporteur spécial de la
commission des finances
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre le président de la commission
des finances Madame et Monsieur les
rapporteurs
les programmes budgétaires relatifs au
transport affiche une forme de
continuité pour cette année 2023 cela
pourrait sembler rassurant dans la
mesure où les investissements dans les
infrastructures de transport sont par
nature des opérations plus réannuelles
qui exigent constance et permanence
pourtant cette situation nous inquiète
elle nous inquiète car nous ne savons
pas car nous savons parlons à quel point
les besoins d'investissement dans les
infrastructures de transport sont
criants à quel point ces infrastructures
sont dégradées et à quel point il
faudrait plus de moyens nous sommes
d'autant plus préoccupés que cette
situation tout temps à s'aggraver le
réseau ferroviaire en est le meilleur ou
plutôt le pire des exemples le
gouvernement avait annoncé un signe sur
les infrastructures ferroviaires mais
nous avons eu beau chercher nous nous
n'avons rien trouvé
pire le ministre délégué au transport a
annoncé comme objectif un maintien du
niveau actuel du réseau ferroviaire ce
qui nous paraît particulièrement peu
ambitieux quand on connaît l'état de
dégradation du réseau et je rappellerai
que l'âge moyen du réseau en France est
de 30 ans lorsqu'il est de 17 ans en
Allemagne cet objectif se révèle de
surcroît improbable en raison de
l'impact de l'inflation dont nous
reparlerons
le gouvernement nous renvoie à l'année
prochaine dans l'attente des travaux du
Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures qui devront conduire à
une nouvelle programmation de
financement présentée au Parlement d'ici
la mi-2023 comme l'impose la loi
d'orientation des mobilités
sont présumés de la conclusion de ces
travaux on sait déjà qu'ils impliqueront
un véritable exercice de confrontation à
la réalité celle d'un mur
d'investissement colossal à cet égard il
est déjà clair que l'enveloppe qui avait
été prévu par la l'homme pour la période
2023 2027 sera nettement insuffisante à
fortiori si on ajoute les projets de RER
annoncés par le Président de la
République dont nous reparlerons plus
tard enfin cette continuité apparente
nous préoccupe d'autant plus dans la
période actuelle d'inflation ou le coût
des chantiers explose le maintien des
trajectoires de financement en
neuroconstant serait une catastrophe
pour la régénération du réseau
ferroviaire
alors que les investissements sont déjà
notoirement insuffisants comme je l'ai
indiqué les conséquences de l'inflation
pourraient se chiffrer à 500 millions
d'euros en année pleine dans le rapport
d'information que nous avons présenté
Stéphane sotarel en février dernier nous
avions dit tout le mal que l'on pense du
contrat de contreperformance de SNCF
réseau s'il n'est pas révisé notre
réseau ferroviaire pourrait se déliter
et les ralentissements récurrents que
l'on observe jusqu'à présent sur les
petites lignes pourrait se diffuser sur
les lignes les plus circuler face à ce
constat nous avons acquis la conviction
qu'il n'est pas raisonnable d'attendre
l'année prochaine et c'est pour cette
raison que nous défendrons au nom de la
commission des finances un amendement
visant à augmenter dès cette année les
investissements des SNCF réseau doivent
infrastructures ferroviaires
en ce qui concerne la fille de France
que vous connaissez bien monsieur le
ministre elle continue de bâtir du
décalage manifeste entre le caractère
certain de ses dépenses et la grande
volatilité de certaines de ses recettes
nous sommes d'ailleurs scandalisés à
propos de recettes par l'attitude des
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroute
qui parce qu'elles sont en conflit avec
l'État sur la taxe d'aménagement du
territoire refuse toujours de verser
pour la deuxième année consécutive une
contribution de 60 millions d'euros dû à
la fit ses proprement scandale par
ailleurs au cours de nos auditions nous
avons été très surpris d'apprendre que
cette année la fille de France n'a pas
été limitée par ses recettes mais par sa
capacité à dépenser les crédits qui lui
sont alloués cette situation est tout à
fait
ubuesque au regard des besoins
d'investissement dans les
infrastructures de transport elle
s'expliquerait selon nos interlocuteurs
notamment par le fait que dans le cadre
du plan de relance de nombreux maîtres
d'ouvrages ont présenté des calendriers
peu réalistes et que par ailleurs il y
aurait dans certains cas des appels de
fonds très tardif il faut évidemment
travailler pour remédier à cette
situation
il faut également noter que depuis 2020
sans les crédits du plan de relance la
trajectoire prévue par la l'homme
n'aurait sans doute pas été tenu en 2023
grâce au crédit du plan de relance le
montant prévisionnel des dépenses de
lafit de France et certes inédites
puisqu'il atteindra 3,8 milliards
d'euros mais compte tenu des révisions à
la baisse qui interviennent de façon
récurrente au fil des budgets
rectificatifs nous préférons à ce stade
rester prudent voire dubitatif je laisse
la parole à Stéphane sotorel pour la
suite de notre rapport et je vous
remercie de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues dans le
prolongement de l'intervention de mon
collègue je vais commencer la mienne en
vous disant qu'en dehors de quelques
effets de périmètre les crédits du
programme 203 devraient rester très
stable en 2023 les financements dédiés à
l'entretien du réseau routier national
pour suivre quant à eux leur progression
et respecteront l'objectif de la l'homme
en revanche s'agissant des trains de
nuit les financements notamment pour le
renouvellement du matériel roulant ne
sont pas à la hauteur et les moyens
humains de VNF interrogent eux aussi le
projet de loi de finance pour 2023
maintient les nouvelles aides
d'exploitation en faveur du frais de
ferroviaire c'est heureux car sans ces
aides nous n'atteindrons jamais
l'objectif que l'on s'est fixé de
doubler la part modale du fret
ferroviaire d'ici 2030 cependant les
opérateurs de fret sont aujourd'hui
menacés par le péril de la crise des
prix de l'énergie comme bien d'autres
opérateurs l'an dernier une aide
exceptionnelle le 26 millions d'euros
avait permis de courir une part de leur
surcoût
mais en 2023 c'est sur coût devrait
quadrupler pour atteindre 400 millions
d'euros cette situation pourrait donc
réellement mettre en péril le secteur
aucune aide n'est prévu dans le PLF mais
nous avons appris que le ministère des
Transports et le secteur échangent pour
concevoir un dispositif pour lequel nous
aimerions obtenir des précisions
au-delà des aides à l'exploitation
l'enjeu majeur est celui de
l'investissement dans les
infrastructures
Hervé Moret la largement rappelé 10
milliards d'euros sont nécessaires d'ici
2030 spécifiquement pour le fret
malheureusement le contrat de
performance de SNCF réseau est très
minimaliste sur ce sujet ce qui semble
admis par tous même si cela ne génère
aucune réaction à ce jour
nous avons déjà fait part de notre
profonde inquiétude s'agissant de la
régénération du réseau ferroviaire mais
au-delà de cette régénération nous ne
comprenons pas qu'aucun financement ne
soit prévu pour moderniser notre réseau
nous voulons bien sûr parler des
programmes de commandes centralisées du
réseau et de RTS deux innovations qui
sont source de gain de performance
considérable de retour sur
investissement et que la plupart de nos
voisins européens ont déjà déployé
en plus de l'amendement présenté avec
mon collègue et visant à abonder en
urgence l'enveloppe de régénération du
réseau ferroviaire la commission des
finances défend une majoration bien plus
modeste de 4,6 millions d'euros de la
subvention versée à l'Autorité de
régulation des transports celle-ci s'est
vu confier de nouvelles missions et de
nouveaux effectifs ces dernières années
sans que l'État ne lui donne des moyens
financiers pour les mener
alors que ces réserves s'amenuisent
cette situation est d'autant moins
soutenable que l'autorité est exposée à
de nombreux contentieux et quel est son
propre assureur la perte d'un litige
pourrait la mettre en grave difficulté
les programmes 355 en rythme de
croisière et 205 marqués par une
évolution du périmètre n'appelle pas de
commentaires particuliers enfin nous ne
pouvons conclure notre présentation des
crédits relatifs au transport de la
mission écologique sans manifester notre
incompréhension pour ne pas dire plus
après les dernières déclarations du
président de la République concernant
les projets de RER métropolitain
loin de nous la volonté de remettre en
cause l'utilité de ces projets mais sur
la forme quelle désinvolture quel mépris
de la représentation nationale comment
au détourne une séquence YouTube faire
une telle annonce pour des milliards
d'euros que nous n'avons pas sauf à ce
que le gouvernement nous présente un
nouvel amendement en urgence sans
esquisser des pistes de financement
sérieuses alors que le gouvernement ne
cesse de nous répéter de patienter
d'attendre la conclusion des travaux du
coi et la nouvelle programmation des
investissements retenus et tandis qu'un
mur d'investissement va se dresser
devant nous avec un enjeu de
priorisation déterminant comment
interpréter cette annonce si ce n'est
comme un nouveau contournement de la
démocratie représentative
les contradictions manifestent entre les
déclarations du gouvernement et cette
annonce ne témoignent pas seulement d'un
manque de considération pour le
Parlement mais plus grave encore elles
affectent la crédibilité du message
public dans une confusion généralisée et
entretenue
cet effet d'annonce non financé et
probablement plus facile de renforcement
des moyens alloués à un réseau
ferroviaire en voie de dégradation
avancée y compris bientôt sur ces lignes
les plus structurantes et que l'on
voudrait masquer derrière ce type de
paravent au moment même ou par ailleurs
le RER parisien et lui sans réponse de
notre côté nous assumons de répondre à
l'urgence d'un indispensable effort
souvent annoncé par le gouvernement mais
jamais concrétisé en faveur des
infrastructures ferroviaires gravement
menacées par le choc inflationniste qui
plus est comme nous l'avons affirmé dans
notre rapport avec mon collègue Hervé
Moret nous sommes prêts à nous engager
sur des voies d'innovation financières
pour décarboner nos mobilités maillez le
territoire et ne pas ignorer nos
territoires ruraux au-delà des RER
métropolitains soutenir le pouvoir
d'achat accroître la transparence des
coûts notamment en abordant enfin la
question du poids des péages dans notre
pays et des tarifs pour développer une
politique de l'offre
en dépit des réserves importantes vous
l'avez compris que nous avons présenté
de l'absence totale de mesures
introduites suite à notre rapport de
contrôle et après avoir proposé
l'adoption des deux amendements comme
mon collègue et moi-même venant
d'adapter la Commission à toutefois ami
pardon un avis favorable sur la
d'adoption des crédits dans sa globalité
et donc nous suivrons cette
recommandation générale sur la mission
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur la parole
est maintenant à Vincent capocanella
notre vice-président rapporteur spécial
de la commission des finances
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances mes chers
collègues le programme 159 que je vais
vous présenter regroupe les subventions
pour charges de service public du céréma
de l'Institut géographique national et
de Météo France depuis plus de 10 ans
ces opérateurs ont connu des baisses
ininterrompues d'effectifs et le moyen
financiers il y avait sans doute je veux
bien le croire des gains déficience à
réaliser et les opérateurs du programme
ont bien sûr effectué leur part toutes
leurs parts et très largement leur part
des efforts de maîtrise des dépenses
publiques la rigueur trouve parfois ses
limites et j'ai pu constater à
l'occasion des deux derniers contrôles
budgétaires que j'ai effectué au nom de
la commission des finances que ces
limites je crois pouvaient être atteinte
s'agissant Météo France et qu'il était
également nécessaire de donner un peu
d'air frais à l'IGN
peut-être monsieur le ministre avec vous
d'ailleurs entendu la commission parce
que je veux saluer quand même des
chiffres qui évoluent et s'agissant
l'hygiène je vais y revenir car j'ai
commis un autre rapport et il est en
train d'accomplir une mutation qu'il
faut je crois soutenir
pour le céréma un rapport du CGEDD en
2021 avait livré une analyse pour le
moins l'armiste sur les tendances à
l'oeuvre au sein de cette opérateur
ainsi pour le programme 159 l'année 2023
sera celle de l'inflexion de ces
trajectoires budgétaires baissières qui
étaient je crois devenu intenable pour
Météo France c'était d'autant plus
nécessaire que cette opérateur est sans
doute le plus affecté par la hausse du
coude de l'énergie c'est super
calculateurs sont très gourmands en
électricité dans un deuxième rapport
d'information que j'évoquais donc à
l'instant il y a quelques semaines au
mois d'octobre j'ai pu présenter la
muque accomplie et que engage en tout
cas l'Institut Géographique nationale
celui-ci porte des enjeux majeurs en
matière de souveraineté des données
géolocalisées et cet établissement
devait se transformer pour ne pas être
marginalisé voir disparaître c'était un
risque c'est une trajectoire difficile
que celle qu'il engage et que celle qui
commence
dessiner mais c'est je crois une option
réaliste et sans doute la seule c'est un
sujet de souveraineté que de garder un
acteur de référence dans le domaine des
données géolocalisées et c'est pour cela
qu'il fallait sans doute desserrer la
contrainte budgétaire elle est
partiellement et en tout cas s'agissant
des effectifs cette en partie le cas et
je me félicite de cette évolution dans
ce PLF le modèle économique de l'IGN
repose sur l'obtention de grands
contrats d'accompagnement des politiques
publiques ce modèle n'est pas sans
risque il nous faudra en évaluer la
viabilité notamment à l'horizon 2025 je
veux saluer l'évolution du serema ces
dernières années le cerema a beaucoup
été malmené il a retrouvé une dynamique
positive il se projette à nouveau à
notamment dans son modèle de quasi régie
il a fait un certain nombre de choix
dans ces missions c'était douloureux
mais il faut saluer cette mutation
et se dire que le nouveau modèle de
quasi régie conjointe entre l'État et
les collectivités locales qui a été
introduit d'ailleurs ici au Sénat dans
la loi 3DS par Madame Gouraud ce nouveau
modèle devrait porter ses fruits
l'opérateur bénéficie lui aussi d'une
infection budgétaire que l'on constate
en 2023 sur ce même programme 159 il y
en avait grand besoin le partenariat
nouveau avec des collectivités locales
en tout cas à partir renouveler devrait
être confirmé car c'est un axe majeur
pour cette opérateur dans sa stratégie
j'en viens au budget annexe à côté du
programme 159 le budget annexe contrôle
et exploitation aérien ce budget annexe
regroupe les crédits de la direction
générale de la vaisselle
les ressources venant non pas du budget
pour la DGAC mais du transport aérien
qui paye des redevances pour
l'utilisation de ces services chacun
imagine que l'équilibre budgétaire a été
quelque peu malmené ces dernières années
vu la baisse du trafic si la tendance à
la reprise du trafic c'est clairement
manifesté cette année celui-ci pourrait
rester en 2023 inférieur de 20% au
niveau d'avoir la crise et c'est donc
un élément qui affecte évidemment les
équilibres financiers le secteur est
convalescent il est également exposé à
la crise du prix de l'énergie la
compétitivité des compagnies reste
fragile et c'est un paramètre je crois
trop souvent éluder qui doit être pris
en compte dans l'équation globale alors
plutôt que de financer sur le budget de
l'État à la baisse des redevances qui a
eu lieu en 2020 et 2021
et qui était lié à la baisse du trafic
il a été décidé de lisser cette perte-là
sur 7 ans et donc on a c'est devant les
conséquences financières de la crise et
maintenant à partir 2023 on commence à
retrouver une hausse importante des
redevances ça va déjà commencer l'année
dernière mais là ça commence à franchir
un nouveau palier et tout cela est
destiné à payer le déficit des années de
covid alors qui a été financé et comme
ça par
en le poussant les redevances vers
l'avant mais également par une hausse de
la dette du budget annexe ceci pour un
secteur qui convalescent et qui est
confronté aux besoins financiers à la
transition énergétique comme face
également comme il est face également à
la consolidation du ciel européen il a
des domaines du coup de la sûreté qui
d'ailleurs augmentent
au-delà notre question principale et la
capacité à faire passer le trafic avec
le contrôler aérien là-dessus il y a une
modernisation des programmes qui est en
cours on peut se féliciter que for
flight avant bien monsieur le ministre
maintenant pourquoi il est en phase de
déploiement il va être dans un deuxième
centre à Aix petite inquiétude quand
même pour le deuxième programme voisin
qui est coflight pour la DSNA il faut
également continuer cet effort de
rationalisation qui est fort bien engagé
en ce moment mais rappelez que la
modernisation passe aussi par la
flexibilité des présences des
contrôleurs une inquiétude monsieur le
ministre celle des protocoles que
conclut la DGAC j'ai dit dans mon
rapport qu'ils étaient parfois gagnant
pour les contrôleurs et peut-être
perdants pour l'État c'est une
préoccupation que je veux partager avec
vous tout comme je veux dire dans le
domaine qui n'est pas chez vous mais qui
rejaillent chez vous que la baisse du
nombre de fonctionnaires dans les grands
aéroports pour faire de la PAF c'est une
vraie préoccupation avant les Jeux
Olympiques notamment il y avait la
remontée du trafic on a un sujet
d'engorgement tout comme il faudra
garder d'ici l'échéance 2025 l'évolution
des crédits du Cora qui finance la
recherche pour la mutation écologique du
transport aérien et à partir de 2025 il
y a un risque de baisse voilà les
quelques éléments que je voulais
souligner en indiquant que je suis
favorable à l'adoption des crédits du
budget annexe
merci Monsieur le Kester je passe
maintenant la parole à Daniel Gremillet
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des affaires économiques
[Applaudissements]
sur le président monsieur le ministre
mesdames messieurs et rapporteurs chers
collègues
le PDF pour 2023 intervient dans un
contexte de crise énergétique inédit
notre commission approuve sur le
principe les annonces sur la
prolongation du bouclier tarifaire la
baisse de la fiscalité énergétique et la
revalorisation des crédits à louer à la
rénovation énergétique à la mobilité
propre ou à certains opérateurs de
l'État dont l'ADEME est l'endroit
satisfait de la reprise de nos
recommandations passées nous appelons à
concrétiser ces annonces pour autant
notre commission relève que la hausse du
programme 174 énergie climat et après
mines est dû à un effet de périmètre et
à la baisse du programme 345 services
publics de NRJ à la flambée des prix de
plus nous nous inquiétons de
l'application des volets énergie des
plans France relance et France 2030 pour
2023 les engagements de crédit
n'atteignent que 15% de ce prévu pour le
premier et 25% pour le second
pire notre commission juge très
incertaine l'évolution des crédits car
l'actualisation des charges de service
public de l'énergie réalisée par la
creux entre juillet et novembre dernier
n'a pas été pris en compte d'une part le
gain pour l'État lié au projet
renouvelable ne sera pas de 16 milliards
mais de 35 milliards d'autre part le
coup pour l'État induit par le bouclier
tarifaire ne sera pas d'un milliard mais
de 3 milliards or aucun débat de fond
n'a été posé sur la location optimale de
ses gains qui ne seraient être capés par
l'État notre commission déplore
plusieurs angles morts des crédits ainsi
la revalorisation des territoires
touchés par les arrêts des centrales
n'est plus soutenu de plus les
dispositions budgétaires et fiscales ne
sont pas assez favorables au nucléaires
à l'hydro-électricité à l'hydrogène au
biogaz et au biocarburant dans ce
contexte Senna a adopté il y a quelques
jours plusieurs amendements fiscaux que
j'ai présenté à titre personnel ils ont
permis d'abaisser la fiscalité sur le
biogaz et l'électrom ils ont permis de
revenir sur un article du gouvernement
qui aurait complexifié les augmentations
de puissance assouplies par notre
commission sur la loi climat résilience
de nuiles 21 alors que nous apprêtons à
vivre en hiver tendu avec des risques de
lestage sur leur a été complètement
malvenue contenu de la gravité de la
crise énergétique notre commission
adoptée amendements budgétaire visant à
garantir les éligibilité des
collectivités territoires territoriales
des TPME et PME à larmentières sœur
d'électricité a augmenté du cent mille
euros les moyens de la creux pour
contrer les bouclier tarifaire à
prolonger l'éligibilité des ménages
intermédiaires pour la prime ma prime
rénov à relever de 120 millions les
crédits du chèque énergie de 80 millions
ceux du fond chaleur renouvelable de 30
millions ceux du fonds de robertisation
des territoires je forme le vœu que le
PDF pour 2023 contribue à réduire la
précarité en Égypte et la énergétique
qui est un lourd sujet de préoccupation
cet hiver mais aussi chez les suivants
tout en consolidant notre transition
notre surveillante énergétique au nom de
notre commission je vous invite donc à
adopter des crédits sous réserve de
l'adoption de ces amendements je vous
remercie
merci la parole est maintenant à
Philippe tabarrau rapporteur pour avis
de la commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la
Commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable a
émis un avis de sagesse sur les crédits
transports ferroviaire fluvio et
maritimes pour l'année 2023 si les forts
budgétaires peut être signalé dans un
contexte difficile il reste toujours à
la remorque du sursaut des mobilités que
nos voisins européens craintent
désormais dans leur politique à l'heure
des crises énergétiques et climatiques
nos ambitions sur le chant des mobilités
doivent être grandes pour réduire les
fractures nos ambitions doivent être
également adossés de moyens financiers
relevés pour ne pas rester cantonné au
rang d'incantation aussi prometteuse
soit elle quand elles sont diffusées un
dimanche soir sur Youtube par le
Président de la République
face à votre réalité politique qui
canalise la contre-performance
ferroviaire nous souhaitons faire du
train le pilier de la mobilité pour
enfin vitaminer le report modal faute de
moyens supplémentaires la réalité
hypothétique des RER Macron est une
remont pas de façade rangée pour
l'instant à quai de gare mais elle a le
mérite de soulever encore plus
d'injustice d'un pays qui avance à deux
vitesses un pays où pendant qu'on a fait
des TGV pour les métropoles et c'est
bien le reste du réseau s'est dégradé
faute d'entretien un pays où on doit
améliorer les déplacements
métropolitains mais également où l'on
doit répondre aux besoins de la France
périphériques dans ce cas nous avons
défendu ici la baisse de la TVA 5,5 en
forme d'amortisseur autant pour les
autorités organisatrices de mobilité que
pour les usagers il s'agit enfin
d'appliquer ce que le Sénat inscrit dans
la loi le doublement de la part du frais
de ferroviaire et fluvial et de rendre
plus compétitif et vertueuse nos
infrastructures portuaires ce projet de
budget répondit à ses écueils nous
sommes encore loin du compte les
collectivités prennent largement leur
part à l'état dans sa stratégie de
souveraineté de tracer le chemin
dans notre commission notre conviction
est de répondre aux besoins
d'attractivité de bien-être de nos
habitants aussi j'ai mes d'importantes
réserve notamment sur le contrat de
performance signé par l'État et ça a été
dit par mes collègues il sanctuarises le
péril à venir de nos infrastructures et
le poison du coup de nos pH ferroviaires
aussi je défendrai une enveloppe de 150
millions supplémentaires dédiés à
l'investissement ferroviaire même si je
suis bien conscient qu'il en faudrait
bien plus nous souhaitons également
doper les capacités sous-exploitées du
transport fluvial qui a démontré sa
résilience quant au secteur portuaire et
maritimes dont nous une chance pour
qu'il soit considéré enfin une chance
locale car ancrée dans leur territoire
une chance internationale dans la
mondialisation des échanges agir sur les
mobilités c'est conjuguer aménagement du
territoire et réponse au défi sociétaux
plus on offre une diversité de solutions
mieux on répond à nos exigences de
service public telle ambition portée par
notre commission
merci la parole est maintenant à Madame
Évelyne Perrault rapporteur pour avis de
la commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président
monsieur monsieur le ministre rapporteur
pour avis de l'aviation civile je vais
faire deux observations la clé de
l'équilibre de ce budget annexe ce sont
des recettes gouvernées par le niveau du
trafic aérien et ce niveau est lui-même
influencé par le prix des billets
d'avion ainsi que la que par la
psychologie des voyageurs l'année
dernière on a été un peu trop prudent
dans les prévisions d'où des surplus de
recettes et moins d'emprunts que prévu
grâce au rebond de 2022 en revanche il
nous semble opportun de tempérer
l'optimisme qui s'exprime pour le trafic
2023 en effet nous constatons plusieurs
freins cumulatif baisse du pouvoir
d'achat et de l'épargne des
consommateurs sensibilité au prix et
inquiétude climatiques particulièrement
chez les jeunes
on l'a vu ces derniers mois les prix de
l'énergie demeurent des paramètres très
puissants or les carburants c'est-à-dire
25 à 35% des charges des compagnies
aériennes ont plus que doublé et il
n'est pas question de bouclier tarifaire
dans l'aérien malgré ses réserves nous
approuvons la volonté de désendettement
de ce budget à partir de 2023 une
interrogation tout de même monsieur le
ministre la facture énergétique des
installations de contrôle aérien ne
risque-t-elle pas de remettre en cause
le rééquilibrage prévu comme c'est le
cas pour de nombreuses entreprises et
collectivités deuxième idée la France
est l'un des deux leaders mondiaux de la
construction aéronautique et peut
décarboner 50% de la flotte mondiale
nous sommes également pionniers dans la
réglementation environnementale par
exemple avec la loi climat et les
nouveaux mandats d'incorporation des
kérosènes durables au niveau national ou
européen
notre talon d'Achille c'est notre retard
pour produire et distribuer ses
biocarburants alors que les moteurs
d'avion sont prêts à les utiliser et les
compagnies à les acheter sous peine de
taxation supplémentaires nous soulignons
également la nécessité d'accompagner
notre maillage aéroportuaire territorial
qui s'adapte aux verdissement 0 émission
pour les opérations au sol et production
d'hydrogène vert gazeux pour les engins
au sol et liquide pour les futurs avions
qui seront opérationnels en 2035 enfin
les 8 à 9 millions de riverains des
aéroports eux aussi travaillent plus
qu'avant à domicile et donc les
nuisances perçues peuvent parfois
augmenter même quand le trafic diminue
nous approuvons également les nouvelles
trajectoires plus économes en carburant
mais les descentes continuent impliquent
de voler plus longtemps à basse altitude
le financement des travaux d'isolation
assis sur une taxe indexée sur le trafic
n'avait pas prévu ces évolutions et les
pertes de recettes se sont accumulées
une nouvelle rallonge budgétaire et donc
souhaitable d'autant que le bon sens
plaide pour le couplage de l'isolation
acoustique et thermique à double
efficace environnementale
merci et maintenant la parole à Hervé
gilet rapporteur pour avis de la
commission de l'aménagement du
territoire du développement durable
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la
Commission de l'aménagement du
territoire du développement durable à
émi un avis favorable à l'adoption des
crédits relatifs au transport routiers
de la mission écologie développement et
mobilité durable mais sous réserve de
l'adoption de 13 amendements je me
réjouis d'ailleurs qu'un certain nombre
d'entre eux comme la diminution du taux
à 5,5 sur les transports du quotidien ou
encore l'élargissement du prêt à taux
zéro pour l'acquisition d'un véhicule
popolo ait été adopté dans cette
hémicycle en première partie nous
verrons bien qu'elle suite leur sera
accordée je défendrai au nom de la
commission d'autres amendements sur la
mission sur laquelle nous nous penchons
ce jour je souhaiterais évoquer devant
vous trois principaux points de mon
rapport pour avis d'abord la question
majeure de la décarbonation du parc de
véhicules le déploiement à court terme
des zones à faible émission de mobilité
conjugués à la définition d'objectif
ambitieux de fin de vente des véhicules
thermiques à l'échelle nationale et
européenne impose de mieux soutenir les
ménages mais aussi les professionnels
dans le renouvellement de leur véhicule
et on connaît bien les problèmes
d'acceptabilité sur ce sujet sur ce
point là je dois vous dire que nous
avons été particulièrement déçus par le
dispositif monsieur le ministre dit du
leasing social pensez pour permettre
ménage modeste de louer des véhicules
électriques qui à ce stade par des
moments d'expression ressemblent plus à
une coquille vide qu'à une véritable
solution d'accompagnement par nos
concitoyens ce ministre vous demandait
aujourd'hui au Parlement de se prononcer
sur un dispositif et démontant
substantiels alors que même aucun acteur
ou administration que j'ai pu interroger
n'a donné le moindre de taille sur ces
modalités de mise en oeuvre ce qui pose
quand même largement question c'est
pourquoi nous avons déposé des
amendements qui pour certains ont été
adoptés visant accroître très
concrètement le soutien ménage mais
aussi aux professionnels dans
l'acquisition de véhicules moins
polluants et cela sont nul besoin
d'inventer de nouveaux dispositifs de
toutes pièces
mon deuxième point d'alerte concerne
l'état de nos infrastructures routières
je fais référence non seulement aux voix
mais également aux ouvrages d'art la
veille des transferts de voirie aux
collectivités intéressés rendus
possibles par la loi 3DS l'état des
routes nationales continue de se
dégrader l'État ne doit pas baisser la
garde sur ce point vous savez que c'est
un sujet il y a eu très peu de
transferts à l'heure actuelle qui ont
été mis en œuvre au niveau des
collectivités territoriales sur les
ouvrages d'art ne nous arrêtons pas au
constat du programme national pont qui a
certes terminerait à l'avancée mais doit
se poursuivre par des travaux de
réparation des ouvrages les plus
dégradés et mon collègue Bruno Belin a
présenté ce matin deux amendements
commission que j'ai déposé avec Louis
Jean de Nicolas notamment sur ce sujet
donc pour les pans d'État il est plus
que temps de rattraper le retard
considérable en matière de travaux
d'entretien et de réparation enfin je
voudrais souligner qu'il manque
globalement des schémas de mobilité qui
permettent vraiment de développer les
inter modalités sur les différents
niveaux de activités et c'est un point
qui devrait retenir toutes nos
attentions je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur et la
parole est maintenant à Pascal Martin
rapporteur pour avis de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances Madame et
Monsieur les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues la Commission de l'aménagement
du territoire et du développement
durable a émis un avis favorable à
l'adoption des crédits du programme 181
relatif à la prévention des risques pour
2023 compte tenu de la trajectoire
d'augmentation qui est consacrée dans le
budget soumis à l'examen du Sénat
l'augmentation des crédits de l'ordre de
7% en autorisation d'engagement et 6% en
crédit de paiement visent surtout
absorber la hausse tendance contraintes
du programme 1181 pardon au sein duquel
je relève que les subventions pour
charges de service public distribuer à
différents opérateurs l'ADEME lancès le
BRGM représente les deux tiers des
crédits avec une augmentation de 5
points par rapport à 2022 je note aussi
avec satisfaction que les baisses
d'effectif au sein du pôle ministériel
de la transition écologique marque une
pause après une décennie de baisse
continue
sur ce sujet je ne peux que regretter à
nouveau le manque de précision
concernant les effectifs des inspecteurs
des installations classées pour la
protection de l'environnement à chaque
fois que je pose la question j'ai une
réponse différente ce qui n'est pas très
rassurant vous en conviendrez il semble
également y avoir un problème structurel
de vacances de poste et je souhaite
monsieur le ministre que le gouvernement
travaille sur ce sujet car il s'agit de
services essentiels pour assurer la
conciliation des objectifs de
développement industriel et de
protection de l'environnement et de la
santé des populations
en outre sans un travail sur
l'attractivité des postes le
gouvernement ne pourra pas honorer sa
promesse faite à la suite de l'incendie
majeur des usines Lubrizol et Normandie
logistique en 2019 de renforcer
l'inspection des installations classées
pour la protection de l'environnement
alors que les enjeux sont très très
nombreux je pense notamment les
questions du droit d'antériorité je
referme la parenthèse je conclurai en
vous indiquant que la Commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable a souhaité marquer
3 priorités pour 2023 s'agissant de la
prévention des risques premièrement le
renforcement des moyens de
fonctionnement et des effectifs de
l'Autorité de sûreté nucléaire dans un
contexte d'accroissement très important
de sa charge de travail
deuxièmement le renforcement des
effectifs de la Commission nationale du
débat public
indispensable pour améliorer
l'acceptabilité autour de nos grands
projets enfin marquer l'importance de la
prévention du risque d'inondation auquel
7 millions de nos concitoyens et 40% de
nos emplois sont exposés en sécurisant
l'attribution de 15 millions d'euros en
2023 cette politique en provenance du
fond vert dont on ne connaît pas la
ventilation des crédits le risque
inondation c'est faut-il le rappeler le
premier risque naturel auquel la France
est exposée il ne faut pas surtout
tergiverser je défendrai cet après-midi
au nom de la commission 4 amendements
traduisant ses priorités je vous
remercie de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
excusez-moi merci et la parole est
maintenant à monsieur Guillaume
Chevrollier rapporteur pour avis de la
commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues pour rendre
compte en trois minutes de mon avis
budgétaire j'accerai mon intervention
sur la question fondamentale de l'eau la
sévérité les épisodes de caniculaire a
démontré s'il en était encore besoin la
centralité de la question de la
ressource en eau dans notre pays le
programme 113 est le support de
financement budgétaire de la politique
de l'eau 21 millions d'euros de crédit
de paiement lui sont consacrés pour
devenir 23 avec notamment 900 000 euros
pour la mise en oeuvre des
préconisations du Varone agricole de
l'eau la modicité de ce montant
m'interpelle au regard des défis posés
par l'adaptation de notre modèle
agricole à la nouvelle donne climatique
un autre point de vigilance déjà mis en
avant sur de nombreux bancs de notre
assemblée portent sur la question des
ressources affectées aux agences de
l'eau avec le fameux plafond mordant
c'est à dire les crètement des
ressources affectées aux agences au-delà
de presque 2,2 milliards d'euros et le
versement de l'excédent au budget
général ce mécanisme est à l'origine de
plusieurs effets pervers le taux des
taxes est moduler pour s'ajuster à ce
plafond faussant ainsi le signal prix du
coût de l'eau facturé aux usagers
générant une tarification qui n'incite
pas forcément la sobriété des usages
plus grave les capacités d'intervention
des agences de l'eau sont contraintes
alors que leur mission ne cesse de
s'élargir au et biodiversité de nombreux
élus pointent le désengagement des
agences de l'eau dans l'accompagnement à
la rénovation des réseaux de
distribution d'eau
la vétusté croissante des réseaux est à
l'origine d'un taux de fuite estimé à
20% soit 1 milliard de mètres cubes par
an ce qui est considérable cela
s'explique par un sous-investissement
chronique récemment évalué à 4,6
milliards d'euros par an je note que 50
millions d'euros de crédit
supplémentaires ont été consacrés à la
rénovation des réseaux d'adduction dans
le second projet de loi de finance
rectificatif pour 2022 c'est un signal
positif mais les montants ne sont
toujours pas à la hauteur des défis il
est présent nécessaire d'accroître la
résilience hydrique de notre pays dans
un contexte climatique incertain je
regrette donc que cette priorité ne
ressorte pas plus clairement de
l'analyse des crédits de la mission qui
nous occupe tant pour la gestion
quantitative que la gestion qualitative
de l'eau qui est pourtant un sujet
majeur de préoccupation de nos élus des
collectivités locales et je sais
Monsieur le Ministre que vous partagez
cette préoccupation
enfin j'ai tiré votre attention sur les
crédits consacrés aux aires protégés
nettement insuffisants pour atteindre
l'objectif de 10% du territoire sous
protection forte d'ici 2030 un rapport
de l'Inspection générale des finances et
du CGEDD portant sur le financement des
airs protégés a notamment montré qu'il
faudrait consacrer trois fois plus de
moyens qu'actuellement pour y parvenir à
la veille de la COP15 consacrée à la
biodiversité cet écart entre les
ambitions affichées et les moyens
budgétaires à louer mettre mérite d'être
pointé les aires protégées sont un bel
outil de protection de la biodiversité
et un levier pour l'attractivité de nos
territoires qui méritent d'être financée
à la hauteur des bénéfices qu'elle
génère comme les services rendus par la
nature donc il est important que la
France soit en cohérence avec ses
discours internationaux et ses actions
sur le terrain national la France nation
verte se doit d'être exemplaire nous
serons vigilants nous comptons sur vous
monsieur le ministre
merci
et enfin pour les rapporteurs je passe
la parole à Monsieur François calvaire
rapporteur pour avis de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable
monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je vous présenterai succinctement la vie
exprimée par la Commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable sur les crédits de
la mission écologique développement et
mobilité durable relatives au
développement des énergies renouvelables
et à la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments je commencerai par les
énergies renouvelables la France et le
seul pays européen à ne pas avoir
atteint l'objectif fixé à l'horizon 2020
le déploiement des énergies
renouvelables et pourtant doublement
nécessaire à notre pays d'une part à la
teinte de nos objectifs de réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
d'autre part à la préservation de notre
sécurité d'approvisionnement
ce retard est également dommageable d'un
point de vue financier c'est
exceptionnel dans un contexte budgétaire
tendu le développement des énergies
renouvelables
constituent en 2002 en 2022 et en 2023
une politique publique à un coût négatif
pour les finances de l'État raison de la
forte hausse du prix de l'électricité du
gaz ce sont ainsi 39 milliards 400
millions qui entreront dans les caisses
de l'État pour l'exercice budgétaire à
venir la situation est bien différente
pour le la chaleur renouvelable qui
nécessite aujourd'hui un soutien public
accru je vous proposerai donc au nom de
notre commission un amendement apporter
les montants du fond chaleur de 520
millions à 700 millions d'euros une
augmentation nécessaire à la teinte des
objectifs de la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie janvier au
deuxième thème de cet avis la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments si le pelf
2023 consacre une pérennisation
bienvenue de ma prime rénove notre
commission déplore toutefois le bilan
énergétique insuffisant du dispositif
nous avons en effet plus calculé que les
économies d'énergie permet par ma prime
rénov ne représenterait en 2021 que 0 45
% de la Coupe consommation totale du par
résidentiel et à ce rythme là nous avons
pour des décennies la Commission estime
donc nécessaire d'orienter plus
massivement les aides vers les
rénovations globales ou multigestes à
moyen constant le développement le
déploiement du service France rénov et à
partir de 2023 d'un réseau
d'accompagnateurs agréé doit également
soutenir l'ambition des travaux la
massification de la rénovation
énergétique passera parallèlement par la
structuration des filières de rénovation
et la montée en compétence des
professionnels vous l'aurez compris les
réserves de la commission portent plus
sur l'exécution que sur le montant
retenu par le PLF elle a donc émis un
avis favorable à l'adoption des crédits
relatifs à la transition énergétique et
climatique inscrit au projet dont la de
finance pour 2023 sous réserve de
l'adoption de la main de ma relative au
chaleur
[Applaudissements]
bien merci monsieur le rapporteur dans
la suite de notre discussion je vous
rappelle que le temps de parole attribué
à chaque groupe pour chaque unité de
discussion
comprend le temps d'intervention
générale et celui de l'explication de
vote par ailleurs le gouvernement
dispose au total de 15 minutes pour
intervenir la parole est à Monsieur
Bruno Belin pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci
c'est le président monsieur le ministre
messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues
des sujets de mobilité ne manquent pas
ce sont les moyens qui manquent monsieur
le ministre alors on va prendre
l'actualité de ces derniers jours pour
balayer un syndrome de dossiers et se
rendre compte qu'effectivement
l'ambition française ne répond pas à ce
besoin à cette nécessité de mobilité
l'annonce la semaine passée des TER
métropolitains je vais employer cette
expression et certes une bonne chose
mais elle concerne 10 grandes villes de
France que faisons-nous du reste du
territoire que faisons-nous de la
ruralité que faisons-nous de ces 22
millions de Français qui n'ont d'autre
solution que d'avoir une voire deux
voitures par ménage et donc subissent
bien évidemment l'inflation d'un gazole
à plus de 2 euros de litre et non pas
d'autres solutions pour se déplacer que
le recours à un véhicule et puis avec un
manque d'ambition complète parce qu'on
leur parle de
solution électrique tous les soirs alors
que la France ne produit pas à l'heure
actuelle suffisamment de véhicules pour
répondre aux besoins d'un pays de 70
millions d'habitants
que pour nous leur proposer le
ferroviaire
non
inexistant ou alors dans un état de
délabrement à chaque audition à la
caisse dans la Commission de
l'aménagement du territoire que
président de Jean-François Longeot à
chaque fois qu'on a le patron de la SNCF
ou qu'on parle du ferroviaire Philippe
Tabarro nous l'illustre autant que faire
ce peu on voit bien tout l'ensemble des
cols lag évoque dans leur territoire
dans leur département hôtel Linkin ne
fonctionne pas là où il faut au bout de
la première garde descendre prendre un
bus pour rejoindre peut-être la deuxième
guerre on voit bien qu'on a une
véritable carence en France sur le sujet
du ferroviaire le petit-fils de cheminot
que je suis on est malheureux et
aujourd'hui ou alors qu'on est en pleine
grève évidemment on peut comprendre les
inquiétudes des personnels de la SNCF
alors que c'est une entreprise
indispensable pour un pays comme le
nôtre et puis un mot pour l'aviation
civile le questeur capot Canada m'en
voudrait de ne pas soutenir ce secteur
d'excellence merci à Évelyne perron de
m'avoir associé à l'ensemble des
auditions parce qu'on voit bien que tous
les efforts qui sont faits
ma génération monsieur le ministre c'est
de la fierté de la Caravelle et du
Concorde on a été un pays extraordinaire
qui a fait rêver et donc arrêtons la
maltraitance sur ce secteur si fort
qu'elle l'aviation civile un c'est un
outil d'abord d'aménagement du
territoire il relie
les provinces entre elles et il ouvre
les provinces sur l'ensemble des
secteurs extérieurs y compris l'étranger
ce qui fait de ce territoire un vrai
outil de d'attractivité c'est un outil
d'aménagement du territoire et c'est un
outil vital parce que à côté de chaque
aéroport comme ça de province qu'on
essaye de désinder actuellement on a
bien souvent un CHU qui est utilisé l'un
et l'autre pour pouvoir faire des
graisses
et là c'est évidemment la vie qui est en
jeu l'aviation fait aujourd'hui des
efforts considérables pour être faire
face à ses responsabilités aviations
rime avec des carbonations monsieur le
ministre on voit bien sur les carburants
durables les résultats alors qu'il faut
peut-être beaucoup de prudence sur
l'hydrogène on voit bien que sur les
carburants durables il y a effectivement
une marge de progression énorme pour
l'aviation civile sauf qu'on n'a pas la
filière en France et donc on est en
train de d'acheter des carburants
durable à l'extérieur et rendent les
déplacements plus onéreux comme la
montrer la rapporteur aviation civile
c'est un outil indispensable c'est un
outil qui progresse et qu'il faut
soutenir nous sommes évidemment face à
des outils qui sont utiles pour le
tourisme qui vont l'être encore plus à
l'accueil des événements comme les Jeux
Olympiques et donc c'est pour ça qu'il
faut absolument soutenir l'Aviation
Civile Monsieur le mise juste un chiffre
pour qu'on l'ait en tête le chiffre
d'affaires ce que génère en PIB Air
France c'est presque de 2% du PIB
national et donc c'est pour ça que sur
ce secteur d'activité la version civile
je pense monsieur le ministre qu'il faut
faire plus parce que nous avons besoin
comme un pays comme la nôtre merci de
votre attention
merci chers collègues et la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue Emmanuel
Capu pour le groupe Les Indépendants
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
madame et Messieurs les rapporteurs
spéciaux et pour avis mes chers
collègues
écologies développement et mobilité
durable trois notions qui cumulent tant
d'enjeux essentielles et autant de
rapporteurs spéciaux et pour avis 11
monsieur le ministre je crois que c'est
un record
fort heureusement concernant le défi
écologique nous ne sommes plus à l'étape
de la prise de conscience
malheureusement cela signifie aussi que
le dérèglement climatique est visible
cette année nous l'avons subi le plein
fouet et sur l'ensemble du territoire le
gel a d'abord attaqué le vignoble la
canicule ensuite à endommagé nos
cultures et fait souffrir nos élevages
depuis la sécheresse sévit c'est
d'ailleurs toujours le cas dans quelques
territoires certaines conséquences sont
désastreuses
alors que nous nous pensions épargner
nous avons dû faire face à de violences
incendies de forêts au nord même de la
Loire le Maine-et-Loire qui nous tient à
cœur particulièrement Monsieur le
Ministre a été cet été l'un des
départements les plus touchés
au total plus de 2500 hectares sont
partis en fumée en l'espace de quelques
semaines à Baugé en Anjou 1500 hectares
ont brûlé en seulement trois jours je
salue et remercie tous nos pompiers qui
ont affronté ces feux partout en France
ainsi que nos concitoyens et
particulièrement nos agriculteurs qui
ont également apporté une aide précieuse
notre groupe prend sa part en
travaillant sur des mécanismes concrets
à l'image de l'agrivoltaïsme ou de nos
propositions sur la forêt en tant qu’élu
nationaux ou locaux nous avons chacun
notre rôle à jouer
continuez à nous alerter et à nous
former sur les enjeux de la transition
écologique est nécessaire
mettre à disposition des élus un outil
de ce genre afin qu'il s'en empare va
impérativement dans le bon sens
d'ailleurs le fond vert qui leur donne
des moyens d'action adaptés à leur
territoire partage le même état d'esprit
nous ne pouvons que saluer cette
initiative dans la chambre des
territoires
au bouleversement climatique ce sont
rajoutés la guerre en Ukraine et les
conséquences énergétiques que nous
endurons mon groupe salut les réponses
conjoncturelles qui ont été apportées et
soulignées par les très nombreux
rapporteurs spéciaux et pour avis je
crois aussi que nous devons apporter une
réflexion structurelle l'échelon
européen est nécessaire surtout
lorsqu'il s'agit de la fixation des prix
de l'énergie à ce titre nous espérons
des avancées concrètes lors du prochain
Conseil européen
l'énergie est cruciale pour notre
compétitivité notre tissu industriel
notre agriculture plus largement nos
modes de vie en sont dépendants nous le
voyons bien à l'approche de l'hiver
l'énergie et la clé d'une transition
efficace à la fois un outil mais aussi
le plus gros défi des carbone en énergie
et nous décarbonnerons des pans entiers
de nos industries et de nos activités
fortement thémétriques je pense au
secteur du bâtiment à la métallurgie
mais aussi bien sûr à celle des
transports cette mission indique tout le
chemin qu'il reste à parcourir dans ce
domaine et je crois qu'il faut
travailler massivement sur nos
infrastructures
nomades de mobilité sont tellement
variées en fonction de nos territoires
notre réseau ferré doit rester
performant et vecteur de transition nos
voitures cela a été soulignées si
nécessaire à des millions de Français
dans nos territoires doivent devenir
plus propres
le travail est immense dans ce domaine
il faut agir bien et pour longtemps tous
les programmes de cette mission nous
amène à la même conclusion
nous allons devoir nous adapter et il
faut s'en donner les moyens pour
décarboner il va falloir innover et
trouver des solutions disruptives il va
falloir être acteur de prévention tout
en réduisant les problèmes auxquels nous
faisons déjà face pour cela il faut
investir aussi je salue à la fois la
hausse significative des crédits de la
mission et la stabilité dans les
effectifs et même l'augmentation sur
cette sur certains secteurs
la transition est en quelque sorte une
révolution
elle est nécessaire
nous devons donc impérativement la
rendre possible et acceptable pour tous
il faut voir loin pour faire bien aux
jeunes dire
monsieur le ministre la feuille de route
est belle mais pas sans obstacle il faut
inventer à nouveau nos modes de vie vous
l'aurez compris le groupe Les
Indépendants va donc voter en faveur des
crédits de cette mission
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue renondons
Tech pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire
[Applaudissements]
le président
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues après un nouvel
échec à la COP 27 pour crédibiliser un
scénario de stabilisation du climat avec
donc une prévisible augmentation des
températures en France de l'ordre de 3,5
à 4 degrés avant 2100 il nous faut
aujourd'hui envisager la pertinence du
budget de la mission écologique
développement et mobilité durable qui
nous est présenté à l'aune de son
adéquation assez défi parmi les
nouveautés de l'année on en a déjà parlé
le fameux fond vert pour les
collectivités territoriales portées à 2
milliards d'euros par l'Assemblée
nationale à dépenser dans l'année sera
déconcentré et d'organisation souple et
s'adaptera au projet qui seront remontés
au préfet c'est bien cela monsieur le
ministre
très bien mais vous connaissez aussi
monsieur le ministre des inquiétudes des
élus locaux sur les difficultés de
fonctionnement de leur collectivité
notamment mais pas seulement du fait de
la flambée des coudes d'énergie qui
remettent donc en cause leur capacité
d'investissement essentiellement
d'évoluer un investissement se font
risque en effet de rester inaccessibles
à beaucoup de collectivités notamment
les petits dont l'épargne brute est en
train de s'écouler à moi que le fond où
nous le préciserait peut-être ne couvre
à 100% certains projets surtout le
montage des dossiers buttera comme
d'habitude sur les difficultés
d'ingénierie et d'animation territoriale
qui sont pourtant le cœur d'une
transition territoriale réussie pour
répondre à cet enjeu nous avons de
nouveau adopté à la quasi unanimité ici
au Sénat une dotation de fonctionnement
climat en première partie du présent
projet de loi de finance toujours donc
mu par un esprit de synthèse et de
concorde nous allons vous proposer de
rajouter 450 millions pour le fond vert
pour prendre en charge les 650 millions
d'animations territoriales que nous
avons donc précédemment voter sur la
forme d'une dotation de fonctionnement
climat vous noterez monsieur le ministre
que nous avons donc gardé vos 200
millions annoncés d'ingénierie pour le
fond vert même s'ils vont passer par
tellement de tuyaux différents qu'on
peut prendre on peut craindre quelques
pertes et fuite peut-être les 20% dont
parlait Guillaume chevrolier pour l'eau
Christina barbe a déjà un peu habillé
pour l'hiver ce nouveau fond vert à la
discrétion de l'État et des préfets ce
n'est pas monsieur le ministre la bonne
méthode le risque de saupoudrage est
évident les sommes au final faibles par
rapport aux enjeux je le redis la
planification passe par une démarche
inverse faire confiance au territoire
notamment dans le cadre de leur spéci en
soutenant leurs besoins d'animation leur
permettre ensuite des accès à des
financements massifs mais récupérables
sur le long terme notamment par les
économies réalisées sur sur l'efficacité
énergétique il faudrait même
certainement prévoir une comptabilité
spécifique pour éviter de stigmatiser
cette entraînement nécessaire l'ombre de
Bercy planant et menaçant toujours
l'effort de transition nécessaire des
territoires
sur la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments les dispositifs d'aide ne sont
pas opérationnelles aujourd'hui tout le
monde le dit tout est donc à revoir si
nous voulons mobiliser les classes
moyennes pour qu'elles engagent des
rénovations globales nous espérons que
la commission d'enquête dont nous avons
fait la demande cette semaine au niveau
du groupe écologiste créera des
consensus pour cette réforme globale qui
permettent une vraie massification de
cette rénovation pour le ferroviaire et
mon collègue Ferney qui reviendra malgré
la reprise de 35 milliards d'euros de
dettes de SNCF réseau et l'effondre
relance vers le fret et les trains nuits
il manque encore au moins un milliard
d'euros par an le contrat de performance
2021 2030 établi entre l'État et SNCF
réseau a fait beaucoup de déçus
concernant enfin le ministère lui-même
on peut se féliciter évidemment de
l'augmentation des crédits des
opérateurs et de la stabilisation de
leurs effectifs sauf ceux de l'ADEME et
de l'ofb qui sont en hausse mais cela ne
compense pas des années de réduction
importante et de baisse de budget
cumulés le dernier rapport die forsy
l'Institut de l'économie pour le climat
et on ne peut plus explicite sur le
sujet entre 2014 et 2021 le céréma a
perdu 630 emplois mais au France 602 et
l'hygiène 250 ces réductions ont été
tellement importantes qu'il sera
impossible de reconstituer ses emplois à
court terme or le manque
d'accompagnement au sein de l'État en
matière environnementale et de
transition écologique se fait déjà
largement ressentir le temps me manque
évidemment mais j'aurais aussi un mot
pour les agences de l'eau il faut aller
à la sanctuarisation de leur budget le
rehaussement du plafond mordant est une
piste importante mais encore
insuffisante nous devons augmenter et
pérenniser les moyens dont elles dispose
pour la pour leurs actions en faveur du
grand cycle de l'eau et de la
biodiversité il nous faut certainement
une fiscalité dédiée renforcée en
matière de protection de la biodiversité
la stratégie nationale pour les aires
protégées n'a pas encore trouvé de
financement à la hauteur des objectifs
on est loin du compte pour les zones de
protection forte vous l'aurez donc
compris nous aurions préféré Alté un
tournant budgétaire décisif dans la
politique gouvernementale en faveur de
l'écologie aussi les amendements
proposés par le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire n'ont-ils
finalement qu'un but met de la loi et
les financements des politiques
publiques en cohérence avec les
engagements pris par la force merci
merci chers collègues et la parole est
maintenant à Frédéric marchand pour le
groupe RDPI
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cette année
comme la précédente a mis en lumière que
le dérèglement climatique est pour
celles et ceux qui en douteraient encore
plus qu'une réalité tangible illustrée
par une série de canicule des feux de
forêt gigantesques des sécheresses
Records et des épisodes plus vieux
orageux violents à répétition par
ailleurs la guerre en Ukraine et
l'aggravation de la crise énergétique
qui en résulte ont généré des
difficultés sociales et économiques pour
une écrasante majorité de nos
compatriotes confrontaient à une nette
augmentation des prix de l'énergie du
carburant ces enjeux ils nous obligent à
ce que loin de sombrer dans le fatalisme
et la résignation notre pays conduise
une politique écologique et
environnementale volontariste aux
échelles nationales européennes et
mondiales ces enjeux ces difficultés
nouvelles nous rappellent combien il est
essentiel de placer notre pays sur la
trajectoire de la neutralité carbone à
horizon 2050 et le sortir de sa
dépendance aux énergies fossiles ces
enjeux se sont ceux de la mission
examinés aujourd'hui présentée au
travers des différents programme portant
les moyens financiers historiquement
élevés que l'État a souhaité consacrer
dans ce PLF 2023 et dans la trajectoire
plurianuelle ici présentée jusqu'en 2025
pour parvenir à ses objectifs ambitieux
mais impératif la transition écologique
et énergétique doit être accélérée avec
une évolution des politiques portées par
l'État tant au travers des missions
directement impulsées par le ministère
et par le ministère de la transition
énergétique que par celle des autres
administrations publiques cette démarche
stratégique nationale et
interministérielle doit permettre
d'améliorer la résilience de nos
écosystèmes de renforcer la sobriété de
nos modes de vie de préserver la
biodiversité et les ressources primaires
de conduire à une transition socialement
juste et de développer les territoires
les filières vertes pardon sur les
territoires car oui la
retéritorialisation de la transition
écologique n'est pas un luxe mais une
nécessité je veux à ce stade mettre
l'accent sur le fond pour l'accélération
de la transition écologique dans les
territoires qui répond à la succession
des crises climatiques sur l'ensemble du
territoire ce fond il est doté de 2
milliards d'euros
mais lutter contre notre dépendance aux
énergies fossiles passe par une nouvelle
façon de se déplacer nous le savons
c'est l'objet du programme 203 dont 90%
des crédits soutiennent le développement
de mobilité décarbonée le ferroviaire
mais aussi le fluvial le portuaire le
transport combiné et les mobilités
douces au passage la trajectoire
d'investissement prévu par la loi
d'orientation des mobilités pour la
période 2019-2023 a été respectée et
même dépassé et se fait mérite d'être
souligné l'addition du programme 203 et
du budget de la fit pour 2023 porte le
budget global dédié aux transports
terrestre et fluviaux à plus 9 milliards
d'euros en augmentation de 6%. les
engagements pour le secteur ferroviaire
sont notables même si l'effort de
rattrapage reste pour partie devant nous
après des décennies de
sous-investissement le transport
ferroviaire et le fret sont deux
thématiques sur lesquelles le
gouvernement s'est fortement engagé
durant la Légion législature précédente
et je ne doute pas qu'il continuera à le
faire si j'en juge par les annonces
récentes
s'agissant du transport fluvial le PLF
traduit un effort soutenu grâce au plan
de relance à hauteur de 175 millions
d'euros le contrat d'objectif est de
performance signé au printemps 2021
entre VNF et l'État a fixé une
trajectoire ambitieuse d'investissement
en régénération et modernisation du
réseau fluvial ces actions auxquelles
n'étaient consacrées en moyenne que 150
millions d'euros par an avant 2021 on
bénéficié de 230 millions d'euros en
2021 et 2022 ce niveau sera maintenu en
2023 et la trajectoire ambitieuse
s'accélèrera à partir de 2026 et 2027
quant au transport aérien il sort d'une
crise sans précédent liée à l'épidémie
de la covid-19 le trafic aérien français
a chuté de 70% 2020 de 61% 2021 par
rapport à 2019 en août dernier il a
retrouvé 90% de son niveau enregistré en
août 2019 les mesures de soutien public
mise en place par le gouvernement dès le
début de la crise sanitaire ont été
indispensable à la survie du secteur
pourtant la régulation du transport
aérien joue un rôle majeur dans la
décarbonation beaucoup le travail reste
à faire il nous faut continuer à
progresser dans l'offre de solutions
alternatives à l'avion dans les efforts
de décarbonation du secteur dans la
sensibilisation des consommateurs et le
développement encore et toujours du
ferroviaire même si vous m'avez que ce
weekend c'est intentiné compliqué le
défi de la transition écologique nous
avons à le relever ensemble nous ne le
relèverons pas les uns contre les autres
ni les uns au détriment des autres
chacun est dans ses responsabilités
chacun est dans son rôle même si en
quelque sorte nous sommes toutes et tous
dans le même bateau c'est donc un budget
à l'offensive avec une hausse inédite de
près de 29% que nous présente le
ministère de la transition écologique et
solidaire et c'est pourquoi bien
évidemment le groupe RDPI votera les
crédits de la mission je vous remercie
merci chers collègues et je passe
maintenant la parole à madame Martin
filleul pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues l'examen de
la mission écologique développement et
mobilité durable du projet de loi de
finances intervient dans un contexte
tout à fait particulier celui d'une
France en feu et d'une Europe en guerre
incendie température record alerte
sécheresse même dans mon département du
Nord c'est pour dire nappe phréatique
asséchée et manque d'eau mais c'est
aussi la guerre en Ukraine qui met en
lumière notre dépendance à l'égard de
puissance étrangères et des énergies
fossiles
ce moment si particulier devrait nous
amener à répondre aux enjeux de ce que
l'on peut appeler le défi notre défi
pour le 21e siècle et devrait également
nous amener au respect des engagements
environnementaux pris par la France or
il n'en est rien au pied du mur face au
risque de pénurie le gouvernement n'a
trouvé comme réponse que des retours en
arrière avec la loi accélération des
énergies renouvelables et le terminal
métallier du Havre c'est le gaz de
schiste et les centrales à charbon qui
ont fait leur triste retour
nous déplorons grandement le manque
d'anticipation et de vision d'ensemble
du gouvernement pour que la France se
dotte d'une réelle politique
environnementale
l'examen de cette mission dite écologie
le confirme le virage tant attendu et
tant annoncé n'aura pas lieu si le
budget est en hausse c'est bien parce
qu'il y a financement de mesure
d'urgence liées à la crise énergétique
bouclier tarifaire soutient aux
effacements de consommation énergétique
mais le budget ne comporte aucune
réforme structurelle permettant de
financer l'accélération de la transition
écologique
ainsi on constate également que les
crédits alloués au transport routier
notamment à l'entretien des routes sont
en forte hausse alors que les crédits
dédiés au transport collectifs et
combinés sont en baisse d'autres actions
bénéficient bien de hausses mais tout à
fait modeste comme le ferroviaire et les
voies navigables la situation est
notamment inquiétante et plusieurs de
mes collègues l'ont déjà souligné pour
la filiale réseau SNCF les perturbations
enchaînent se multiplient de nombreux
usagers partout dans les territoires et
notamment dans les hautes-frances
souffrent quotidiennement de
désagréments la rénovation des voies
ferrées
âgées de 30 ans en moyenne en France
devient de plus en plus urgentes le
gouvernement n'aimait aucun signal pour
trouver une voie de résolution à ce
problème majeur contrairement à ce qui
avait été promis
pour poursuivre les crédits accordés au
programme paysage aux diversité vont
dans la bonne direction mais reste en
deçà de ce qui est nécessaire au regard
des enjeux qui seront largement évoqués
lors de la COP 15 biodiversité à
Montréal et surtout lorsque la France
entend incarné un lead archives fort
dans ce combat mais quelle crédibilité
accordée à notre parole quand c'est
financement reste notoirement
insuffisant enfin j'aurai un mot
particulier pour le nouveau programme
dédié au fond d'accélération de la
transition écologique dans les
territoires ou fond vert il va dans le
bon sens le rôle des collectivités est
effectivement fondamental dans cette
transition écologique mais nous restons
encore dans l'attente de précision quant
la qualité de son utilisation alors en
conclusion je dirais un que nous
attendons nous attendons que les mesures
prises par ce gouvernement soit à la
hauteur des engagements du Président de
la République qui nous a dit en son
temps que ce quinquennat serait
écologique ou ne serait pas ensuite nous
nous voulons plus voir l'état condamné
pour inaction climatique et enfin nous
voulons que la France soit exemplaire
dans le combat pour l'écologie le
développement les modalités durables et
rattrapent le retard pris à atteindre
ses objectifs je vous remercie
merci chers collègues et je vais
maintenant passer la parole à
Marie-Claude variace pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues pour
reconster recontextualiser ce budget
2023 frapper du saut de l'article 49-3
il est utile de rappeler l'urgence
maintes fois réitérée par les
scientifiques de prendre en compte
l'accélération à la remonte du
réchauffement climatique mais une fois
encore il est difficile de considérer
que la cop27 fut un succès comme le dit
très justement Jean-Marc chancovici une
cops
qui est souvent malheureusement une
déclaration d'intention le nombre de
lobbyistes d'ailleurs des énergies
fossiles à la cop27 dépasse le total des
représentants des 10 pays les plus
touchés par le changement climatique
avec presque 32 milliards d'euros
d'autorisation d'engagement et 30 et
demi milliards de crédit de paiement le
budget en faveur de l'écologie affiche
certes une hausse notoire mais intègre
près de 9 milliards destinés à financer
des aides aux consommateurs notamment le
bouclier tarifaire dans le même temps
faut bien le dire ou totale enregistre
des bénéfices records sans parler des
plus de 2 milliards de dividendes
exceptionnels annoncés certes la France
a le mérite de se fixer des objectifs
ambitieux dans sa stratégie nationale
bacarbonne pour contenir les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre et la hausse des
températures à 2 degrés d'ici 2050
cependant les objectifs doivent être
suivis de moyens associés jusqu'ici très
insuffisants et qui nous ont valu d'être
condamnés quand même à quatre reprises
pour une action climatique depuis 2017
la dernière d'ailleurs de ces
condamnations coûtera 500 millions
d'euros qui auraient pu valablement
abandonner ce budget quant au fond vert
évoqué par mes collègues portées à 2
milliards d'euros à destination des
collectivités pour accélérer la
transition énergétique il semble être
assorti si je lis bien d'un objectif
multiplicateur de 4 ce qui se traduirait
par une subvention égale à 25%. dans ces
conditions il est donc à craindre que ce
fond bénéficie aux collectivités les
mieux dotés à la fois un moyen humain
pour répondre à des appels à projets
toujours plus complexes et en capacité
d'investir sur leur fonds propres pour
répondre aux critères qui pour le moment
il faut bien le dire reste flou le
gouvernement a raison de dire qu'il n'y
a pas d'argent magique cependant
l'urgence climatique est là et bien là
l'été 2022 restera dans les mémoires
comme l'été de la fin de l'insouciance
dans mon département la Dordogne comme
dans d'autres d'ailleurs au-delà des
incendies à répétition la tempête de
grêle incroyablement dévastatrice à
générer des pertes considérables pour
nos agriculteurs et nos concitoyens dont
les maisons sont encore à ce jour
habillés de bâches dans le Ribera quoi
l'indispensable transition écologique
nous oblige à des investissements
importants il y a une plus juste
répartition des richesses produites avec
seulement deux réformes la suppression
de l'ISF et le prélèvement sur les APL
le gouvernement a pris 1,3 milliards au
bénéfice de l'aide au logement et à
redistribuer presque trois fois plus au
plus riche des français contrairement
d'autres pays voisins la France a refusé
de taxer des profits exceptionnels
générés grâce et à cause de la crise on
ne peut pas parler de transition
écologique monsieur le ministre si on ne
parle pas de justice sociale nous avons
besoin de réformes structurelles
adaptation de nos forêts de nos
bâtiments et de nos infrastructures
rénovation efficaces de nos logements
investissements dans le transport
responsable de 30% de nos gaz à effet de
serre et tout cela nécessite des
investissements importants or dans ce
budget pas de hausse significative des
crédits en faveur du ferroviaire lorsque
nous savons que pour atteindre
l'objectif fixé par la stratégie
nationale bas carbone c'est près de 3
milliards d'euros d'investissements
supplémentaires par an jusqu'en 2030 qui
sont nécessaires le frais de ferroviaire
je le rappelle ne représente que 9% du
transport des marchandises contre 89%
pour la route la moyenne européenne est
de 18%. une politique de rénovation
thermique pas suffisamment ambitieuse à
mon avis bien qu'abonder dans ce budget
le dispositif prime rénov reste
insuffisant dans la mesure où aucun gain
de consommation énergétique minimale né
requis l'an dernier seul 2500 logements
sont sortis du statut de passoire
thermique sur plus de 700 000 primes
accordées en 2021 pour un montant de 2,8
milliards d'euros seul 60000 logements
ont fait l'objet d'une rénovation
globale le reste à charge conduit bien
évidemment les ménages à y renoncer
enfin cette mission nous est présentée
après des échanges riches sur le projet
de loi d'accélération de la production
des énergies renouvelables adoptées en
première lecture au Sénat or ce projet
de loi de finances ne prévoit aucune
ligne budgétaire de soutien ces énergies
qui restent dans le secteur
concurrentiel l'investissement dans les
énergies renouvelables reste tributaire
du prix de l'énergie ouvert à la
concurrence la bifurcation écologique
implique réindustrialisation
relocalisation et création d'emplois
elle nécessite la reconstruction de
filières industrielle française dans le
renouvellement dans le renouvelable et
la création d'un pôle public de
l'énergie car l'État doit garder la main
sur ce que sont nos biens communs au
regard des enjeux sociaux humains
écologiques de souveraineté
d'indépendance du pays pour toutes les
raisons que je viens d'évoquer notre
groupe CRCE ne votera pas le budget de
cette mission
merci chers collègues et je passe
maintenant la parole à Jean-François
Longeot pour le groupe Union centriste
monsieur le monsieur le ministre
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues nous voici parvenus
à l'examen d'une mission fondamentale
pour l'atteinte de nos ambitions
climatiques et environnementales les
moyens les crédits portés par les
programmes de la mission écologie
développement immobilisé durable ont en
effet vocation à préparer notre pays au
défi immense de l'adaptation changement
climatique et atteindre un meilleur
niveau de résilience de nos territoires
par rapport à la loi de finance initiale
pour 2022 les autorisations d'engagement
pour 2023 de la mission augmente de plus
de 10 milliards d'euros dans le texte se
transmis au Sénat après l'engagement du
49-3 contre 6,8 dans le texte initial je
ne veux que ça lui s'est amélioration
parmi les points de satisfaction à noter
ce budget renforce fortement les aides à
l'achat de véhicule électrique ce qui
permettra davantage à nos concitoyens de
s'équiper véhicules de véhicules propres
proposition qui avait été faite par
notre collègue Philippe Tabarro en cas
de la loi climat et résilience j'appelle
néanmoins le gouvernement agit au niveau
européen afin de restreindre au maximum
ces aides à des véhicules produit en
Europe il en va de notre souveraineté
industrielle un point de satisfaction
important concerne la stabilité des
schémas d'emploi de la mission du pôle
ministériel et des opérateurs rattachés
après une décennie de baisse d'un cycle
il était temps de mettre fin à
l'hémorragie
nous savons que la transition écologique
sera intensive en moyen humain et
nécessitera un pilotage appuyé sur une
expertise publique qu'il faut dès à
présent conforter grâce notamment à
l'ADEME au céréma à Météo France ou
algérienne nous serons donc vigilants au
respect par le gouvernement de Sa
promesse de préserver les effectifs au
cours du quinquennat malgré ce budget
globalement satisfaisant il subsiste
néanmoins des points d'inquiétude
important le gigantisme du bouclier
tarifaire sur les carburants entraînent
un brunissement marqué de la trajectoire
environnementale du budget de l'État les
dépenses défavorables augmenteront de
90% par rapport à 2022 je partage bien
entendu le soutien au ménage modeste
face à l'inflation des coûts de
l'énergie mais je déplore l'absence de
compensation et les conséquences à moyen
terme de nos efforts sur le verdissement
par ailleurs la cohérence de nos
politiques publiques gagneraient à ce
qu'on mette fin à cette effets en
défaisant la nuit les efforts patiemment
accomplis le jour j'ai un autre sujet de
préoccupation important concernant le
fond d'accélération de la transition
écologique dans le territoire doté de 2
milliards d'euros se font vers et ça a
été dit ce vœu une solution de soutien à
portée aux collectivités alors même que
les capacités financières de ces
dernières ont été successivement
malmenées par la tension inflationniste
sous indexation de la DGF ainsi que la
suppression annoncée de la CVAE aussi se
fond vert qui constituent en réalité
davantage une périnisation de crédit
initialement déployés dans le cadre du
plan de relance comme le fond friche
revêt plus un effet d'annonces que du
nouveauté par ailleurs la mise en oeuvre
pratique de ce fond nourrit des
inquiétudes concernant et ça a été
répété à plusieurs reprises le mécanisme
d'attribution de ces aides
à la main des préfets pour garantir la
souplesse et l'attribution des dettes
des aides j'aimerais que l'on puisse
m'assurer que les communes au moyen
humain limités seront bien en mesure d'y
accéder car ce sont précisément
celles-ci pour lesquelles les aident
présentent l'effet de levier le plus
important sous le bénéfice de ces
observations je salue la stabilité de ce
budget l'arrêt de l'hémorragie des
emplois au sein des opérateurs rattachés
ainsi que la priorité croissante donnée
à l'environnement je ne saurais trop
invité le gouvernement à poursuivre dans
cette voie notre groupe votre en faveur
de l'adoption des crédits de cette
mission je vous remercie
merci et je passe maintenant la parole à
notre collègue Stéphane Artano pour le
groupe RDSE
monsieur le Président Mesdames Messieurs
les rapporteurs monsieur le ministre
Michel collègue après la COP 27 examen
de ce budget nous permet de faire le
point sur les principales politiques qui
concourent à la réalisation d'un
objectif de neutralité carbone en 2050
Oran peut légitimement se demander
comment les états de plus en plus
endettés pourront faire face aux murs
d'investissement nécessaire à la
transition énergétique et écologique
c'est unique constitue donc un Tournon
sur le plan énergétique la guerre en
Ukraine nous a rappelé notre fragilité
notre dépendance aux énergies fossiles
c'est un nez les énergies renouvelables
rapportent des recettes à l'état du fait
de l'explosion des prix de l'électricité
sur les marchés ce qui nous permet de
financer des aides mises en place en
France pour répondre à une situation
probablement durable blocage des tarifs
réglementés bouclier tarifaires
amortissement d'électricité filet de
sécurité pour les collectivités
territoriales chez Énergie etc le coût
du maintien de l'économie de la
protection contre la précarité de la
paix sociale pour ces quelques mois
représente tout de même 45 milliards
d'euros rien que pour le bouclier
tarifaire mais on conçoit parfaitement
on ne pouvait ne rien faire pour
préserver les ménages des entreprises
après une crise sanitaire ayant paralysé
l'économie celle-ci se trouve néanmoins
en perpétuel en perfusion publique
les collectivités territoriales
bénéficieront finalement d'un soutien
conséquent à travers les différents
dispositifs prévus par les lois de
finances initiale et la loi de finances
rectificative nous y reviendrons plus
longuement et plus sereinement lors de
l'examen de la proposition de loi qui
sera examinée la semaine prochaine
cependant l'avenir de ces aides reste
flou alors que les prix de l'énergie ne
peuvent que connaître une hausse
structurelle jusqu'à qu'on pourra-t-on
maintenir ce rythme les mesures adoptées
ces derniers mois ne pourront être
indéfiniment prolongés le gouvernement a
déposé un nouvel amendement proposant de
rehausser de 6 milliards d'euros les
crédits du programme service public de
l'énergie dont environ 2 milliards
d'euros pour étendre le bouquet
tarifaire y compris rétroactivement aux
structures collectives d'habitat qui
avait été oubliés en 2022 je me réjouis
évidemment de cette intégration
alors la responsabilité nous incombe de
progresser pour relever le défi
historique qui nous impose le changement
climatique
l'épuisement des ressources naturelles
et la préservation de la biodiversité la
sobriété donc ce mot que certains
nausées prononcés qui depuis ne cesse
d'être répétés pour cela le chantier de
la rénovation énergétique des logements
et des bâtiments publics et tertiaire
devrait constituer une priorité le plan
de sobriété constitue une première
réponse mais l'ampleur des besoins et la
nécessité de développer des compétences
et des filières très rapidement ne peut
que donner une vertige il aurait fallu
dans l'idéal favoriser les travaux lors
des mutations de biens ou de changement
de locataires nous aurions pu voter
cette mesure en 2019 lors de l'examen de
la loi énergie climat ou encore en 2021
lors de l'examen de la loi climat et
résilience
pendant ce temps-là nous continuons à
augmenter les montants consacrés à ma
prime rénove une tiers de cela et
bienvenue évidemment mais ces dépenses
publiques sont surtout orientées vers
des monogestes sans grands effets sans
compter pardon sur la consommation
énergétique des ménages et sur le climat
en matière de transport si la
trajectoire d'investissement de la loi
d'orientation de mobilité et on passe
d'être respecté celle qui doit nous
conduire vers neutralité carbone ne
l'est pas la décarbonation de ce secteur
ne repose pour beaucoup sur le
développement du transport ferroviaire
qui doit être à la fois une alternative
au transport routier et au transport
aérien
la compétitivité du secteur ferroviaire
ne repose avant tout sur les
investissements qui doivent être
consacrés à la régénération et la
modernisation du réseau beaucoup restent
à faire pour permettre d'engager le
report modal vers le rail
nous voterons en faveur de l'amendement
proposé par la Commission misant à
allouer 150 millions d'euros
supplémentaires à la régénération du
réseau on fait un mot rapide sur le fond
vert ça a déjà été dit par les orateurs
précédents au-delà de l'effet d'annonce
nous espérons qu'il ne s'agira pas d'un
simple recyclage de crédit précédemment
troyé nous aurions souhaité disposer des
modalités précises de fonctionnement est
affectation des crédits avant l'examen
du projet de loi de finance pour
conclure nous voyons d'un mauvais œil
bien évidemment les économies proposées
par la Commission des finances sur cette
mission fois plus de 700 millions on
pouvait estimer en effet que les actions
concernées étaient peut-être surdotées
mais c'est dernier crédit pouvait être
réaffecté à d'autres programmes et
visant à financer les transports les
aides à la rénovation énergétique la
préservation de la biodiversité le
renforcement de la prévention des
risques ou encore le fond vert
le groupe erdse malgré tout votera en
faveur de secret de ce de ces crédits il
restera attentive au sort réservé aux
amendements
merci
chers collègues et je vais maintenant
passer la parole à François bonhomme
pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre sur un portage général madame
la rapporteur spécial mes chers
collègues cette mission écologie
illustre une certaine légèreté peut-être
avec laquelle le gouvernement
aborde la transition énergétique dans
les territoires nous sommes témoins des
maladresses pour rester dans la litote
et la pondération sénatoriale qui nous
caractérise elle en connait territoire
notamment ruraux nous avons le zéro
artificialisation nette qui va sans
doute paralyser en tout cas scléroser
les collectivités locales quand bien
même elle soit en capacité de déployer
les trésors d'un jeune unités ou
d'ingéniosité plutôt pour résister à
cette folie technocratique
nous avons les zones affaires de mission
de le gouvernement ne mesure pas
toujours le caractère discriminant et
excluant pour les personnes habitant
dans le monde rural nous avons depuis
peu les projets de loi sur la politique
énergétique saucisse au nez comme pour
mieux culter les erreurs majeures il y a
10 ans concernant les orientations
stratégiques de notre pays en matière
énergétique stratégique Gribouille qui
peut nous conduire à de poils coupures
électriques cet hiver dans le domaine
budgétaire on trouve ici ou là les
marques de cette légèreté c'est le cas
avec le programme 380 et son fond
d'accélération de la transition
écologique dans les territoires
sous la forme nous assistons à un
habituel recyclage des crédits d'un
programme à l'autre d'action à une autre
les plus bienveillants ils verront sans
doute une contribution involontaire ou
ironique à l'économie circulaire cher à
brune Poirson qui depuis s'est perdu
dans les limbes notre rapporteur l'a dit
fort opportunément
de nombreuses politiques menées dans le
cadre du programme 380 sont des
continuations des dispositifs des
programmes 362 écologie de la mission
plan de relance concrètement les fonds
friches le font friche est directement
tiré du plan de relance tout comme les
crédits consacrés à la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments les politiques
de soutien autrui à la source et à la
valorisation des biodéchets la
prévention des risques et la pluie
politique de la biodiversité
Christine Avart de la prophète de la
parfaitement dit tout à l'heure la
répartition des crédits au sein des
trois actions de programmes n'est pas
détaillé dans les documents budgétaires
et le financement de nombreuses
politiques de fonds a été détaillée
après coup soit dans la presse soit en
audition devant le département c'est
quand même incroyable que le principe de
sincérité budgétaire qui me semble-t-il
implique d'exhaustivité la cohérence ou
l'exactitude des informations
financières fournies par l'État soit une
fois de plus ignoré j'en viens à la
rénovation énergique des bâtiments un
mot plus particulièrement sur le
fonctionnement ou plutôt le
dysfonctionnement chronique de ce
dispositif d'aide de public aux travaux
de l'économie d'énergie appelé ma prive
rénove ce dispositif très sollicité est
même attendu
a donc fait l'objet de financement par
Lana pour un montant cumulé de 5
milliards d'euros un peu plus
naturellement la hausse des factures
énergétiques particulièrement depuis un
an et qui pèse fortement dans le budget
des ménages vient alimenter un flot
grandissant de demande sur la plateforme
ma préférez 9 néanmoins ce dispositif
date de publique est grippé et
s'apparente parfois une boîte noire ou
une machine à produire des sacs de nœuds
qui finissent par décourager les
volontés les plus chevronnées et les
plus déterminés des précarisés
énergétiques cela fait des mois que les
amis très sagasses devant les
difficultés à trouver ou des
interlocuteurs ou devant les bugs
techniques répétés depuis sa mise en
place en 2020 nous avions déjà relevé ce
mécontentement auprès des modèles wargon
cela peut paraître étonnant d'évoquer
devant vous monsieur Miss des problèmes
de bug et c'est pourtant bien un facteur
de blocage impossibilité de créer un
compte ou un dossier de déposer en ligne
les justificative de modifier les
éléments du dossier voilà bien des
freins très concrets qui conduisent
parfois les usagers les plus précaires à
renoncer à ce dispositif d'aide près de
3 ans après sa création m'a pris
vraiment de bâtir des conditions dans
lesquelles elle a été conçue il
s'agissait alors je leur répète et
souvenons-nous que il s'agissait de
réaliser donc d'un des délais
extrêmement courts la promesse politique
de simplifier les aides aux travaux de
rénovation avec l'ambition d'accélérer
bien évidemment la transition
énergétique j'aimerais monsieur le
ministre que vous évitiez
je compte sur vous pour reprendre le
refaire habituel de certains de vos
collègues qui sont comme une dérobade à
choc à force d'être raciné à chaque fois
que l'on demande des choses ils nous
disent nous y travaillons ou une
variante on a besoin de travailler sur
le sujet j'espère que vous n'en serez
pas là je le crois et on a quand même
effectivement toujours la volonté et
l'attente forte d'améliorer la
plateforme de traitement des demandes
d'élargir LED initialement réservée aux
propriétaires occupants revenus modestes
à l'ensemble des propriétés occupants ou
des copropriétaires puis aux
propriétaires bailleurs mais de grâce il
ne sert à rien d'afficher des crédits
budgétaires si l'on n'est pas capable
d'améliorer fortement et surtout
rapidement la capacité opérationnelle en
fluidifiant le traitement des demandes
ce serait alors totalement
contre-productif et viendrait peut-être
un peu plus affaiblir si c'était
nécessaire la parole publique il est
temps monsieur le ministre donc de
mettre un peu d'ordre dans les
politiques publiques malheureusement il
est à craindre que nous reportions nos
espoirs sur le prochain PLF
bien merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue Franck
Montauger pour le groupe socialiste
écologie
écologiste et républicain pardon
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre cher collègue c'est à l'aune
des retards et des manquements graves
condamnés pour certaines d'entre eux que
les moyens budgétaires qui nous sont
proposés doivent être appréciées
marquent-ils avec le passé une rupture
de l'action gouvernementale à la hauteur
de la profondeur des transitions à
opérer visiblement non quand on constate
au terme d'une année 2022 sans précédent
du point de vue des dérèglements
climatiques que ce budget est en réalité
la reconduction du précédent correction
faite de l'inflation 2023 estimée à 5%
hypothèse basse les prêts de 60
milliards d'euros de la mission
correspondent à une augmentation de 2% à
Euro constant et si l'on sentit au
programme 113 159 et 181 l'augmentation
faciale de 3,2% est en réalité corrigé
de l'inflation toujours une baisse
réelle de capacité d'intervention
publique de près de 2%
donc tout ça n'est pas est de loin à la
hauteur des enjeux et de l'urgence
climato environnementale dans le cadre
du programme 113 paysages hauts et
biodiversité je redis ici que le varen
de l'eau est inabouti et qu'il faut
mettre en œuvre les préconisations en
matière de ptgen de plantes territoriaux
de gestion de l'eau au périmètre des
bassins ou des captages l'association de
tous les usagers à la gestion
contractuelle de la ressource et des
usages est indispensables agriculture
biodiversité sécurité doivent être
conciliés de façon plus générale nous
devons revenir au principe de l'eau qui
va à l'eau il est temps de supprimer le
plafond mordant et d'affecter les 2,8
milliards d'euros de redevance prélevé
aux agences de l'eau pour aider les
collectivités et leur syndicats à
améliorer rapidement le rendement des
réseaux les milieux aquatiques et les
dispositifs de protection contre les
inondations qui sont amenées à se
produire à fréquence élevée hélas les
mères sont aussi très inquiets de la
mise en œuvre du zan dont je note que
vous avez monsieur le ministre pris la
mesure des faiblesses ou des difficultés
je regrette qu'en première partie du
budget vous ayez refusé de donner les
moyens aux communes de travailler sur
les dents creuses ou la continuité de
l'habitat des rues de leur village il y
a là vous le savez un potentiel
d'accueil d'accueil de nouveaux
habitants que nous devons permettre le
fond vert de 2 milliards d'euros que
vous prévoyez de créer dans le budget et
dans cet esprit va dans ce sens mais il
se limite aux espaces publics pour
terminer je voudrais aborder la réponse
problématique que le gouvernement donne
à la flambée des prix de l'énergie vous
mettez en oeuvre un bouclier de 45
milliards d'euros qui coûtera net des
reversements provenant des énergies
renouvelables 20 milliards d'euros les
dispositifs sont complexes insuffisants
pour les Français en difficulté et les
règles d'éligibilité ont des effets de
bord qui mettent en situation intenable
des mères et des présidents
d'intercommunalité par ailleurs
rigoureux dans leur gestion vous devez
amplifier le chèque énergie et faciliter
le retour des des activités au tarif
réglementé notamment en augmentant la
puissance des contrats aujourd'hui
plafonnés à 36 kVA la loi d'accélération
des énergies renouvelables doit aussi
s'inscrire dans une planification
écologique globale dont nous devons
pouvoir nous parlementaires évaluer
concrètement la cohérence et
l'efficacité de mise en œuvre enfin nous
sommes très inquiets de l'envoler des
prix de l'énergie sur la compétitivité
de nos filières industrielles on voit
bien que le Président de la République
peine à se faire entendre par les USA
sur la question du protectionnisme
commercial quels sont monsieur le
ministre vous proposiez position pour
restructurer le marché européen de
l'électricité dont nous voyons
aujourd'hui les limites je vous remercie
merci chers collègues et enfin je donne
la parole d'ailleurs et je donne la
parole à Denis Saint-Pé pour le groupe
Union centriste
monsieur le Président Madame et
messieurs les ministres Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs
ce mercredi Météo France annonçait que
2022 était l'année la plus chaude jamais
mesurée en France
autrement dit le changement climatique
n'est pas à venir mais il est déjà en
cours se rappelle me semble bienvenu
alors que nous devons examiner les
crédits de la mission écologique de ce
projet de loi de finance pour 2023
malheureusement le gouvernement en dépit
d'une détermination louable en la
matière se retrouve devant une équation
quasi-insoluble il doit mener la
transition écologique tambourbattant
sans compromettre des finances
fragilisées par un endettement record
tout en s'assurant de ne laisser
personne sur le bord de la route de fait
en caricaturant un peu ces crédits
retranscrivent d'une conciliation
acrobatique entre le besoin d'éviter la
fin du monde tout en permettant à nos
concitoyens de vivre ou pour les plus
précaires d'entre eux de survivre
jusqu'à la fin du mois il ne s'agit pas
ici de remettre en cause le bouclier
tarifaire ou l'amortisseur électricité
ces mesures sont nécessaires en ce
qu'elles permettent à nos ménages nos
entreprises nos collectivités de lutter
comme il le peuvent contre une inflation
effrénée des prix de l'énergie mais au
vu du coup vertigineux de ces
dispositifs il faut se féliciter que les
compensations habituellement versées par
l'État au producteurs d'énergie
renouvelable ce soit muet en recettes
exceptionnelles permettant ainsi d'en
financer la plus grande partie cela
illustre bien l'intérêt d'accélérer la
production des énergies renouvelables en
France et montre toute la pertinence du
projet de loi du gouvernement qui va
dans ce sens et récemment votée par le
je souhaite aussi dire un mot du chèque
énergie mesure essentielles pour
protéger les ménages les plus fragiles
il a nécessité l'ouverture de nouveaux
crédits en 2022 pour un coût total de
près de 2,9 milliards d'euros par
comparaison ce sont 795 millions qui
sont prévus en crédit du club de
paiement pour 2023 je crains que cela ne
suffise pas mais j'espère de tout cœur
que le futur me donnera tort quant au
dispositif de matrim Renov il a
visiblement trouvé son public en croire
les enquêtes de satisfaction toutefois
je m'interroge sur son efficacité en
effet d'après un rapport de la Cour des
comptes de mars 2022 seul 2100 logements
en 2021 sont sortis du statut de
passoire thermique sur un objectif de 80
000 il m’apparaît par conséquent
impératif d'augmenter le taux de
rénovation globale bien plus performante
d'un point de vue énergétique que les
rénovations monogestes pour que ma prime
rénove soit à la hauteur des ambitions
qui lui sont assignées enfin je tiens à
saluer vos efforts monsieur le ministre
pour stabiliser les effectifs de votre
ministère et des agences sous votre
autorité au vu des défis à relever il
était effectivement vital de mettre fin
aux réductions de personnels c'est
pourquoi comme l'a déjà annoncé le
président Longeot le groupe de l'Union
centriste votera en faveur des crédits
de cette mission je vous remercie
merci et maintenant la parole est à
notre collègue Jean-Claude Anglard pour
le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président madame messieurs
les ministres madame monsieur le
rapporteurs mes chers collègues
les 22 milliards d'euros de crédit de
paiement qui sont demandés au titre de
la mission écologie développement
immobilier durable en 2023 montre à quel
point l'écologie est devenue le
référentiel majeur des politiques
publiques des transports aériens
ferroviaires fluviaux et maritime à la
reprise de plusieurs dispositifs du plan
de relance en passant par la politique
de l'eau et de la biodiversité le champ
d'action de cette mission est d'ailleurs
si vaste que le rattachement à
l'écologie de certains secteurs
interpellent
toute politique publique a-t-elle
vocation à être renouvelable à être en
transition et enfin à être évalué sur sa
performance énergétique ces objectifs
peuvent-ils être simplement dupliqués
uniformément sur tous les territoires
rural
urbaine périurbaine dense ou très peu
dense les communes n'ont-elles pas des
spécificités qui expliquent que les
modes de vie et les préoccupations de
leurs habitants diffèrent
je me permets ces interrogations tant
qu'il me semble que ce budget révèle une
conception de l'écologie trop souvent
dogmatiques et statistes loin du
pragmatisme et du bon sens nécessaire
pour répondre aux difficultés des enjeux
les plus locaux et les plus éloignées
débuteront le budget de cette mission
comporte plusieurs lacunes que les
rapporteurs dont je salue le travail ont
déjà souligné
c'est le cas notamment
c'est notamment le cas pardon de
l'abondement du fond vert et je ne
reprendrai pas ce qui a été dit en tout
cas je souscris à l'idée qu'il doit
participer
prioritairement à la sobriété foncière
si on veut réussir cette politique et je
ne parle pas volontairement des ânes
les conséquences des choix du gouverne
du choix du gouvernement sur les
mobilités durable sont aussi négatives
lorsque l'écologie est l'industrie ne
sont pas conciliés les effets pervers de
la stratégie du gouvernement pour la
transition écologique du secteur
automobile continue à paraître et vous
me permettrez madame panier de citer
l'abandon du moteur thermique qui a déjà
produit les conséquences désastreuses
sur les bassins d'emploi de l'automobile
diesel avec par exemple la fermeture de
l'usine Bosch a emmener les photos en
Aveyron
mais cela continue aujourd'hui à grande
échelle avec les aides à l'acquisition
de véhicules d'iprops qui amène
concrètement en subvention les
constructeurs et très rangés cela a été
déjà souligné par mes prédécesseurs
sur ce point il est essentiel il est
essentiel que le gouvernement tient
compte des modifications à l'initiative
de notre collègue Christine Lavarde en
tant que rapporteur spécial
les conséquences du choix du
gouvernement sont aussi négatives
lorsque le traitement de la mobilité ne
tient pas suffisamment en compte de la
diversité des territoires
la population est de plus en plus mobile
avec des migrations pendulaires souvent
contraintes en particulier dans les
territoires ruraux l'attractivité des
territoires ne se décrète pas et le
désenclavement des territoires ruraux ne
peut pas se faire selon les mêmes
méthodes que celles des métropoles cela
ce budget n'en tient pas suffisamment
compte en ce sens l'insuffisance des
investissements en faveur du réseau
ferroviaire est préoccupante comme le
noter Philippe Tabarro ou Stéphane
sotarel
avec ce budget la dégradation du réseau
va continuer et les desserts fines du
territoire ne vont pas se développer
autant que nécessaire malgré la carte
que l'on vient de voir être produite sur
Twitter à l'instant par le gouvernement
alors que nous assistons à l'attrition
du réseau aérien français il est
indispensable de renforcer le
financement des aéroports de province
classés liaison d'aménagement du
territoire
au total je dirais que le grand soir
écologique sous lequel gouvernement va
apparaître ne trompe personne mais
plutôt qu'il inquiète par un dogmatisme
qui est peut-être aveugle à la
complexité des fractures territoriales
et si j'osais je dirais qu'il décide
est-ce la première ministre chargée de
la planification écologique ou bien
est-ce le haut-commissaire au plan qui
travaille sur la grande transition
écologique pourrait prendre les mots du
président de la République si l'écologie
est votre nouveau référentiel mesdames
et messieurs les ministres les solutions
même écologiques sont plus complexes que
des slogans de communication je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues et je passe
maintenant la parole à Monsieur
Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés je voudrais
d'abord remercier les sénateurs
c'est quand même un comble absolu pour
pour moi qui connaît cette maison pour y
avoir passé 6 ans que je fasse ce lapsus
je veux
en vous saluant toutes et tous
évidemment saluer tous ceux qui se sont
succédés à cette tribune depuis un peu
plus de
depuis près de deux heures maintenant
pour rapporter
les avis dont ils avaient la charge ou
exprimé la position des différents
groupes
vous comprendrez aisément qui ne me soit
pas possible en 15 minutes d'apporter
une réponse précise à la totalité des
arguments qui auront été évoqués qu'ils
soient positif réservé ou négatif sur
les différents sujets et je vais
nécessairement faire l'impasse dans la
présentation succincte de l'ensemble de
cette mission sur un certain nombre de
sujets je m'autoriserai quelques
incursions malgré tout en réponse à
quelques-uns des propos que j'ai pu
attendre et je nous renverrai ensuite
collectivement à l'examen des
amendements qui ont été déposés pour que
nous puissions parfois entrer dans le
détail de tel ou telle dispositif
tous ceux qui se sont succédés à cette
tribune ont souligné la crise écologique
et énergétique sans précédent que nous
connaissions à la fois d'où elle vient
la suite d'un réchauffement climatique
qui ne date pas de ces derniers mois sa
réalité son actualité et pas seulement
son caractère futur ou avenir et la
nécessité d'une transition vers une
économie neutre en carbone et sobre dans
l'usage de nos ressources naturelles qui
est plus que jamais une priorité même si
manifestement nous pouvons avoir
des variations sur la manière de
concevoir ou le sens de l'urgence ou la
nécessité d'accélération
je veux d'abord dire que notre pays fait
partie de la vingtaine de pays à
l'échelle mondiale qui a commencé la
baisse de ses émissions
que dans le contexte que nous
connaissons l'argument que nous ne
pèserions que 1% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre à l'échelle mondiale
n'est pas une excuse pour ne pas agir et
qu'il est assez rare de se retrouver
dans une situation où on explique qu'on
va quand même pas commencer à éteindre
l'incendie de son propre appartement
tant que le voisin qui en a un plus
grand n'a pas commencé à le faire fort
de ça nous avons un conduire cette
transition avec le double souci de
conduire une transition qui soit
solidaire et qui soit juste comme
certains ont pu le dire parce que si
nous oublions les plus fragiles au bord
du chemin c'est à fois c'est à la fois
injuste d'un point de vue climatique
parce que ce sont ceux qui émettent le
moins et c'est surtout profondément
contre-productif parce qu'une transition
qui ne s'accompagnerait pas d'un effort
de chacun ne serait pas une transition
qui pourrait être réussie
les budgets qui vous sont présentés qui
additionnent ceux du ministère de la
transition écologique de la cohésion des
territoires et de la transition
énergétique atteignent le niveau inédit
de 69 milliards d'euros pour l'année
ce niveau est en progression de 36%
alimenté par les dispositifs de soutien
et de boucliers tarifaire mais même
quand on les retraites la progression
des crédits est réel 41 milliards pour
la transition écologique 28 pour la
transition énergétique avec une méthode
transnation verte une déclinaison la
planification écologique qui fait
l'objet de 22 chantiers thématiques et
de 7 chantiers transversaux pour aboutir
avec les parties prenantes à des accords
à des visions qui ensuite seront
présentées à ce Parlement et feront
l'objet de vote par grand domaine mais
sans attendre un certain nombre de
priorités sont déclinés c'est le cas
avec l'accélération de la décarbonation
du mix énergétique et
je veux dire à une partie de ceux qui se
sont exprimés en soulignant la
contribution des énergies renouvelables
aux recettes de ce budget que les 39
milliards qui ont été évoqués notamment
par François Calvet mais par quelques
autres sont bien à la fois un dispositif
de prélèvement de ceux qui
s'apparenterait à des rentes n'avions
pas mis des prix de plafonnement et donc
un dispositif particulièrement efficace
pour notre pays quand on compare sur le
plan européen à une contribution des
énergéticiens mesure de soutien ensuite
aux acteurs privés ou public qui se
retrouvent à devoir financer ces mesures
au travers de toute la palette de
dispositifs boucliers amortisseurs
guichets qui sont imaginés
je veux souligner les 2 milliards et
demi d'euros qui sont mobilisés pour
financer ma prime rénov j'ai entendu les
pistes d'amélioration que vous pouviez
suggérer elle rejoignent une partie de
celle que nous pointons nous-mêmes en
particulier à la faiblesse des
copropriétés dans l'ensemble du
dispositif pour lesquels il n'est pas
certain que ce soit d'abord des
problèmes budgétaires qui bloquent quand
nous connaissons les règles de majorité
qui s'appliquent ensuite la nécessité de
regarder comment nous pouvons matifier
les gestes parfois aussi comment nous
pouvons les simplifier il n'empêche que
quel que soit le regard que nous
portions sur ce que pourrait être une
efficacité accrue je tiens malgré tout à
me réjouir du million et demi de
rénovation rendu possible et des
économies d'énergie et des missions
d'ores et déjà atteintes et qui
représente l'équivalent de la
consommation de la ville de Lyon
plusieurs ont évoqué la question du
bonus écologique et de la prime à la
conversion qui représente un virgule 3
milliards d'euros qui témoignent d'abord
que le gouvernement est parfaitement
réaliste sur le fait que nous ne pouvons
pas conduire une politique de transition
écologiste qui consisterait être contre
la voiture elle est indispensable et
nécessaire sur un certain nombre de
territoires nous devons juste faire en
sorte qu'elle soit décarbonée avec un
rythme de décarbonation qui doit tenir
compte de nos capacités de production et
je veux en particulier dire au sénateur
gilet que une des raisons pour
lesquelles le leasing n'entre pas en
vigueur au début de l'année 2023 c'est
que nous ne voulons pas que ça devienne
un outil de financement d'importation
massive de voiture qui seraient produite
au bout du monde ce qui nécessite que sa
mise en oeuvre ayavec les filières de
production de véhicules électriques sur
le sol européen
je veux
insister sur le fait que
la décarbonation de notre mix
énergétique et c'est la cohérence avec
le projet de loi présenté par Agnès
panière une haute assemblée avec sagesse
a su adopter
représente ou plus exactement ce traduit
par près de 70 millions d'euros pour
financer les études sur l'implantation
des parcs éoliens ce qui témoigne de la
cohérence entre les ambitions qui ont
été affichées les moyens financiers pour
être capable de les obtenir
je veux rappeler que la décarbonation du
mix énergétique c'est également le fond
chaleur avec des crédits qui sont
sanctuarisés à plus de 500 millions
d'euros et que l'industrie n'est pas
oubliée puisque dans un autre pan du
budget c'est bien 5 milliards d'euros
qui sont prévus dans le cadre du fond
des carbonations pour l'industrie 4 à
destinations des plus grandes zones et
maîtrise de ce pays et un pour les 26
000 PMI qui sont considérés
vous êtes revenu sur la protection des
Français face à la hausse des prix
brutales de l'énergie avec la mise en
oeuvre du bouclier tarifaire sur le gaz
l'électricité avec l'amortisseur qui
représente à la minute où nous nous
parlons 54 milliards d'euros et qui
consacre le fait que notre pays est
celui qui en Europe aura consacré sur
les années 2022 et 2023 les moyens les
plus importants à la protection de nos
concitoyens
je veux rappeler aussi le chèque énergie
qui financera en 2023 à la fois les
ménages modestes qui se chauffent au
fioul mais également au bois et le
chèque énergique exceptionnel envoyé au
40% des ménages les plus modestes en
cette fin d'année 2022
beaucoup a été dit sur les transports je
veux souligner tous les rapporteurs qui
se sont exprimés
d'abord pour vous rappeler que le
programme 203 est en hausse de près de
5% en dépassant les 4 milliards d'euros
qu'ensuite les moyens conséquents comme
le budget annexe de l'aviation civile et
je salue madame Perrot le budget de la
fuite et je salue le sénateur Tabaro ou
encore les moyens consacrés au
verdissement des véhicules pour obtenir
au total près de 12 milliards d'euros
sont bien consacrés à la politique des
transports ce qui représente une hausse
de près 13% par rapport à l'année 2022
avec une priorité assumée sur le système
ferroviaire et plus de 6,3 milliards qui
sont consacrés soit plus de la moitié
des dépenses globales en faveur des
transports avec un peu moins de 100
millions d'euros prévu pour continuer à
soutenir le frais de ferroviaire
presque tous dès lors que vous avez
parlé de transport vous avez tenu à
revenir sur les annonces du RER
métropolitain qui ont été faites par le
Président de la République il y a
quelques jours c'est d'abord pour moi
l'occasion de les saluer et de mesurer
qu'elles ne sont manifestement pas passé
inaperçu et de les inscrire dans un
contexte et dans un cadre qui est celui
de PLF
nous disons
depuis déjà plusieurs semaines ou
plusieurs mois avec Clément bun la
nécessité qu'il y a dès que le rapport
du Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures aura été rendue
de présenter un plan massif
d'investissement dans le ferroviaire
plusieurs dizaines de milliards d'euros
sont nécessaires pour la planification
écologique
sur la régénération sur le soutien au
fret ou les travaux du Sénat sur la
possibilité que nous aurions de revenir
dans la moyenne européenne en doublant
la part de fret
alimentent notre réflexion et sur les
RER métropolitains qui ont le mérite de
concerner les endroits dans lesquels
nous avons le plus de densité et donc
les impacts en termes de décarbonation
qui seront les plus importants nous ne
pouvons pas opposer ces projets d'abord
parce que dans un certain nombre de cas
il peut arriver que ce soit les
itinéraires des LGV qui concourent à la
réalisation de RER
je pense en particulier à Toulouse en ne
citant qu'un exemple et dans d'autres
nous avons d'ores et déjà des échanges
et des discussions extrêmement claires
avec ces territoires qui ont lancé des
programmes de RER métropolitain et pour
lequel l'État sera au rendez-vous dans
le cadre de cette planification
écologique en terme de financement je
précise que dans le socle le rTMS et les
CCR sont bien évidemment totalement
intégrés
je ne m'étendrai pas sur le secteur
routier sauf pour souligner que les
budgets sont bien au rendez-vous et même
un peu supérieur à la trajectoire prévue
par la l'homme que la question du
transport aérien qui n'est pas un sujet
tabou reste très important en termes
d'accessibilité pour les territoires je
veux souligner les dossiers importants
qu'on progressé grâce au travail
parlementaire un sonorisation des
aéroports chers Vincent kapokanellas
développement des lignes à grande
vitesse cher Claude rénale Philippe
Tabaro Henri Cabanel taxation des
carburateurs des jets privés grâce au
rapporteur général de l'Assemblée
nationale Jean-René Cazeneuve ou
Jean-Marc soules
plusieurs d'entre vous ont évoqué la
biodiversité y compris en la mettant en
ligne avec la COP15 qui commence le 7
décembre prochain pour saluer des
crédits portés à 3,6 milliards d'euros
sur la question de l'eau je rejoins le
sénateur chevrolier je qui je rappelle
les 2,2 milliards d'euros et 100
millions complémentaires qui ont été
prévus je veux dire que les écarts de
performance des réseaux
doivent parfois aussi être regardés avec
les prix qui sont payés par les usagers
parce que ce glorifier d'avoir un prix
très bas quand on a un réseau peu
performant peut nous interroger sur le
critère de bonne gestion de ses réseaux
quand on a été tout de suite de 20% en
moyenne mais que c'est au monde parfois
à 70% se réjouira à ce moment-là qu'on
paye peu cher son mètre cube ne doit pas
conduire à demander à l'État d'aller
compenser les efforts qui auraient dû
être faits pour assurer ou les
interconnexions de réseau ou la
sécurisation de ces différents
dispositifs fin janvier nous aurons
l'occasion de présenter la fin du
travail que nous avons initié fin
septembre avec Bérengère Couillard avec
plusieurs axes la lutte contre les
fuites la réutilisation des eaux usées
la question évidemment de la diminution
des moyens pour parachever ou prolonger
le varen de l'eau évoquait par certains
je ne m'étendrai pas sur
la question
posée par Pascal Martin de la prévention
des risques sauf pour lui dire que le
bon chiffre sur les ETPC s'il le cherche
encore c'est bien 25 supplémentaires
pour l'année qui arrive après les 50 des
années précédentes que bien entendu nous
savons les efforts qui nous avons encore
à faire je veux évidemment vous dire un
mot sur le fond vert puisque beaucoup
d'entre vous nous ont fait l'amitié d'en
parler de manière longue j'ai entendu
plein de choses donc beaucoup qui sont
exactes et certaines qui ne le sont pas
se font ne vaut que pour l'année 2023
point et si la totalité des
autorisations d'engagement sont
précisées sur cette année que nous ne
mettons que 500 millions d'euros de
crédit de paiement c'est que nous ne
pourrons pas verser les crédits sans
avoir le service fait par les
collectivités l'idée n'est pas de penser
qu'on va financer ça en 4 ans l'idée est
bien je l'ai dit dans les auditions à de
multiples reprises dans cet enceinte que
j'ai eu l'occasion d'avoir je l'ai dit
avec toutes les associations d'élus
depuis des mois c'est un fond pour la
seule année 203
le principe nous l'avons co-construit
avec les associations des lieux reçues à
partir du début du mois de juillet
en particulier avec l'AMF et quand
j'entends ici y compris le sénateur
anglar appelé de ses vœux qu'on puisse
tenir compte des petites communes la
fongibilité et la souplesse passe par ce
que certains déplorent comme étant une
absence de ligne parfaitement claire je
précise pour aller plus loin que ce fond
précisément
il a la souplesse qui va nous permettre
d'accompagner les collectivités sur une
seule année pour ensuite en imaginer le
prolongement et la pérennisation dans le
cadre de la planification écologique et
y compris contenu du retour d'expérience
que nous pourrions avoir je serai
évidemment attentif à ce que vous
suggérez prétendre que ce serait des
crédits recyclés si vous considérez que
le plan de relance avait vocation a duré
toute la vie ça relève de l'honnêteté
intellectuelle si vous considériez que
le plan de relance devait se terminer au
moment où il est essentiel se terminer
ça pose davantage de difficultés
puisque par définition les crédits
auraient dû être de 0 sur la totalité
des lignes qui sont issus du plan de
relance donc oui nous assumons le
prolongement au travers du fond vert en
particulier du Fonds friche mais plus
largement c'est bien 2 milliards qui
n'auraient pas été présent si nous
n'avions pas validé ce dispositif pour
le reste je répondrai plus tard mon
dernier mot sera pour les effectifs nous
ne mettons pas fin à 50 baisse ou à 10
ans de baisse comme je l'ai entendu mais
à 20 ans de baisse le pôle écologique
est celui qui depuis 20 ans pourcentage
a le plus contribué à la baisse des
effectifs à l'intérieur de l'État
cet arrêt était nécessaire les rapports
sur le fait qu'un certain nombre
d'opérateurs étaient à l'os on ne les
compte plus et cette stabilité elle est
pour 5 ans et elle masque des hausses
puisque la Société du Grand Paris est à
l'intérieur du dispositif et qu'elle
rendra des centaines de postes dans deux
ans c'est donc bien une progression des
effectifs à périmètre constant qui vous
est proposé et qui nous permettra de
disposer des moyens humains de conduire
cette bataille indispensable à
l'intérieur de laquelle nous allons
entrer merci de votre attention
merci monsieur le ministre nous allons
donc procéder à l'examen des amendements
portant sur les crédits de la mission
écologique développement et mobilité
durable figurant à l'état B
je donne tout de suite la parole à
Madame Christine Labarde
pour indiquer que pour tous les
amendements relatifs à l'ADEME ainsi que
pour ce qui a été fait dans le rapport
je me suis en position de départ et je
ne prendrais pas par au vote
bien merci donc nous entamons le débat
sur les amendements avec
deux amendements successifs qui sont
présentés par le gouvernement donc le
premier amendement le 11 39
madame panière une hachée merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président cette amendement
vise à augmenter de 6 milliards d'euros
la dotation du programme 345 pour tenir
compte des reprovision de charge de la
creux et du coup des boucliers pour les
logements collectifs donc je vais
détailler ces 6 milliards d'euros
il s'agit d'abord de 2 milliards d'euros
qui permettent de financer d'une part
l'extension du périmètre du bouclier
tarifaire gaz au titre de l'exercice
2022 afin de prendre en compte et
structures collectives d'habitat non
encore retenu par le décret du 9 avril
22 c'est un des sujets sur lequel cet
assemblée avait été particulièrement
vocale je pense aux EHPAD aux résidences
autonomies au casernes de gendarmerie au
logement diffus de structure collective
les crédits permettent aussi de financer
le prolongement de ce bouclier gaz sur
l'habitat collectif en 2023
d'autre part l'extension par un décret
en cours d'élaboration du bouclier
tarifaire cette fois-ci électricité à
l'ensemble de l'habitat collectif pour
le chauffage des parties communes les
crédits ouverts doivent couvrir le
second semestre 2022 ainsi que l'année
à hauteur de 3 milliards d'euros cette
amendement prend en compte les moindres
reversement attendus sur les contrats de
soutien aux installations de production
d'énergie à partir de sources
renouvelables du fait de rupture
anticipée de contrats l'initiative des
producteurs intervenus depuis l'été 2022
le gouvernement se fond ici sur les
dernières prévisions de la Commission de
régulation de l'énergie paru le 3
novembre dernier soit après le dépôt du
projet de loi de finances ces ruptures
de contrat rendront néanmoins ces
producteurs redevables de la
contribution sur les rentes
inframmarginales ça sera rattrapé pour
partir au travers de cette contribution
sur les rentes infra marginales sous
forme de recettes fiscales
enfin pour environ un milliard d'euros
plusieurs hautes hypothèses
sous-jacentes à l'évaluation suite à la
délibération de la commission de
régulation de l'énergie du 3 novembre
2022 notamment sur le niveau de prix du
combustible utilisé pour les centres
centrales gaz à co générale génération
je vous remercie merci avis de la
commission sur cet amendement
alors monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre bonjour alors sur cet
amendement bien évidemment c'est assez
difficile de s'opposer puisque vous avez
bien compris qu'il vient financer
l'extension des boucliers tarifaires en
gaz et en électricité alors notamment
madame la ministre peut-être parce que
votre exposé des motifs n'est pas très
précis sur le l'extension du bouclier
tarifaire électricité je suppose que par
les parties collectives vous entendez en
fait l'ensemble des résidus les parties
communes voilà l'ensemble de l'habitat
collectif
mais sinon sur la forme j'ai quand même
une certaine difficulté alors déjà le
fait que cet amendement soit arrivé il y
a en gros 24 heures au Sénat un
amendement assimilards alors je sais
qu'on adore les amendements assimila ou
le chiffrage de l'énergie autour de 6
milliards je peux pas croire en plus
vous allez citer la délibération de la
croûte du 3 novembre donc on est quand
même presque un mois plus tard le 2
décembre donc voilà il y avait
certainement matière à pouvoir nous
l'envoyer plus tôt ce qui aurait pu
permettre peut-être une étude encore
plus approfondie
alors pourquoi est-ce que il y a
certaines choses qui me chiffonnent un
peu notamment pour justifier l'ouverture
de 1 milliard de crédits supplémentaires
vous parlez à juste titre de la
cogénération vous vous appuyez sur la
délibération de l'accreux du 3 novembre
mais moi j'avais un amendement que j'ai
dû retirer face au vôtre qui lui
justement venait vraiment tenir compte
de la reprovision de la Crau et venez
diminuer les crédits affichés dans la
maquette budgétaire soit les actions 10
soutien biométhane et actions 12
soutient à la co génération puisque la
Crew est venue diminuer les charges de
service public imputable essaie de
filières par rapport à la délibération
du mois de juillet vous vous nous
justifiez ces mêmes filières pour venir
augmenter les crédits donc permettez-moi
de penser qu'il y a quelque chose de pas
très crédible ou quelque chose qui nous
échappe à tous ici qui peuvent qui
puissent vous permettre d'augmenter
alors je sais pas Madame la Ministre
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas venu nous dire
qu'il y avait besoin de crédit
supplémentaire sur l'action 17 cette
action vous avez créé de soutien aux
consommateurs face à la crise
énergétique là on aurait pas eu de
questions on peut le comprendre mais
voilà venir justifier ça par des
filières ENR qui et que ça ne soit pas
incohérence avec la délibération de la
Creuse c'est problématique et je
voudrais aussi revenir sur les 2
milliards enfin sur les 3 milliards que
vous
apporter pardon
enfin on parle de 6 milliards donc je et
on a eu 24 heures donc je voudrais juste
parce que nous avons délibéré de la
contribution sur Antin fromage le
gouvernement est venu représenter un
article liminaire et j'ai pas
l'impression que ce que vous nous avez
apporté comme recette supplémentaire
soit complètement cohérent avec 3
milliards que vous venez effacer sur les
charges de service public alors est-ce
que vous allez en fait revenir encore
avec un nouvel article auliminaire à la
fin de l'étude de la seconde partie
voilà les questions que j'avais à vous
poser
merci Madame la rapporteur madame la
ministre voulait ajouter quelque chose
je voulais préciser que sur la décision
de la Creuse on parle bien du
rehaussement non des prix l'énergie mais
du prix du combustible sur cogénération
qui est bien matérialisé par une
augmentation donc ça joue à la hausse et
je crois que tout le monde pourra
comprendre que s'agissant de la
cogénération gaz les prix du gaz ne sont
pas prévisibles et sont le résultat d'un
état de marché sur lequel comme vous le
savez nous sommes un portateur
massivement et donc c'est un ajustement
qui est automatique s'agissant du dépôt
de bilan je crois qu'il y a du dépôt de
d'amendement il a été fait effectivement
il y a 48 heures qui est la résultante
d'un certain nombre de travaux encore
une fois nous essayons et vous le et
vous le savez sur le bouclier
copropriété et sur les parties sur
l'habitat collectif c'est des
discussions que nous avons eu ces
derniers jours et encore la semaine
dernière avec l'ensemble de la filière
donc si nous voulons ce temps de
concertation pour pouvoir fiabiliser
ensuite les chiffres effectivement je
comprends et j'entends le fait que 48
heures c'est court mais croyez bien que
la veille nous étions encore en train de
finaliser ces discussions je vous
remercie
merci Madame la rapporteur donc si j'ai
bien compris vous ne vous opposez pas à
l'amendement voilà avec toutes les
questions que vous avez posées et bien
on va
oui madame la ministre je viens
d'entendre votre réponse
on peut tout entendre sur les
difficultés
[Musique]
d'appréhender une situation avec
les comment dirais les difficultés liées
aux contraintes multiples Europe
fournisseurs d'énergie et essayer de
trouver des solutions mais vous êtes ici
dans une des deux
enceintes du Parlement
et la manière
dont les informations ne sont parvenues
il a fallu faire plusieurs demandes
insistantes sous l'autorité du président
de la commission des finances ne sont
pas convenables je dirais même qu'elles
ne sont pas acceptables on vous a alerté
vous répondez tardivement et vous ne le
voyez
Christine lavard vient de le dire
nous finalement nous sommes condamnés à
vous faire confiance
sachant que le gouvernement de toute
façon la main puisque beaucoup va
relever du pouvoir réglementaire mais
pour vous comme pour nous on est on va
être en situation d'alerte et de
difficulté
des entreprises s'inquiète
s'inquiète sur les futurs de stage les
coupures de courant et quelque part le
bouclier énergétique l'amortisseur le
mode de calcul nous avons fait des
propositions sur le filet de sécurité je
pense qu'on a collectivement intérêt à
avoir des dispositifs qui soient
travailler le plus en amont possible
mais on ne peut pas être
informé aussi tardivement et dans les
conditions dans lesquelles les
informations sont délivrées je le dis
j'ai entendu Christine Lavarde mais moi
j'ai assez peu goûté la semaine passée
la manière et on le dira au ministre
concerné dont
[Musique]
a été remise en cause une enfin où a été
évaluée plutôt un sous amendement
effectivement trois petits points à 6
milliards d'euros
alors que vous serez le gouvernement va
être incapable de nous donner de
véritables éléments d'évaluation donc on
débute
c'est cette séance sur un sujet qui est
très important qui va être dans les mois
suivants
merci Monsieur Dantec oui merci monsieur
le Président Madame la Ministre de deux
choses d'abord je pense que d'un point
de vue pédagogique on a parlé tout à
l'heure des 39 milliards qui sont la
bonne nouvelle puisque aujourd'hui la
production d'électricité la moins chère
c'est clairement les énergies
renouvelables donc on a quand même une
recette de 39 milliards je crois qu'il
serait bon que le gouvernement nous
montre comment sont utilisés les 39
milliards parce qu'on a des bruits ici 6
milliards aujourd'hui
des différents dispositifs ça je crois
que ça serait bien pour la société
française de voir comment s'être en 9
milliards servent finalement à
l'ensemble du bouclier aujourd'hui je
crois que en termes de transparence ça
serait intéressant premier point
deuxième point vous l'avez dit c'est un
point je pense
d'inquiétude on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
du fait de des recettes très importantes
on a un certain nombre de producteur
d'énergie renouvelables qui sont en fait
en train de racheter
leur contrat c'est à dire que une
recette dont on parle des 39 milliards
elle va pas durer et je pense que c'est
un élément d'alerte pour la creux pour
les prochains contrats je pense qu'il ne
faut plus permettre qui est ce rachat
anticipé des des contrats parce qu'on
sait que les prix de l'énergie vont
continuer de fluctuer ça n'empêche pas
que la creux dans l'autre sens à
certainement intérêt à révaluer un petit
peu les prix de rachat qui sont
aujourd'hui trop faibles quand même dans
la crise où on mène d'avoir des contrats
sur lequel on ne trouve pas de
d'opérateurs sur les appels d'offres
c'est absolument aberrant donc je pense
que les contrats sont aujourd'hui trop
faits parce qu'il y a aussi des coûts
induits notamment sur sur le prix des
matières premières du métal enfin il y a
aussi des coûts induits pour les
producteurs qui doivent amener la croix
réévaluer mais de ne pas permettre
derrière ceux à quoi on est en train
d'assister c'était un des des rachats
anticipés qui vont nous priver de
recettes demain si jamais les prix
continuent de fluctuer donc de remarques
complémentaires
bien merci nous allons passer au vote
sur cet amendement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté deuxième
amendement présenté par le gouvernement
le 1138
sur Clément Beaune
si monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs c'est un
amendement technique mais important
d'ajustement de crédit sur le programme
217 qu'on lui était pilotage des
politiques de l'écologie de
développement et de la mobilité durable
qui vient ajuster les modalités de
compensation la collectivité européenne
d'Alsace au titre des routes et des
personnels puisque nous avons ajusté les
modalités de compensation avec un
ajustement d'un côté de recettes fiscal
affectées de TICE et donc la minoration
budgétaire miroir qui convient sur le
programme support 217
merci
avis de la commission
c'est un avis favorable et c'est un
amendement dont on reparlera en seconde
partie quand il y aura effectivement les
transferts d'effectifs et là on pourra
admirer la finesse de la précision du
chiffrage à l'Europe
bien donc à vif favorable sur cet
amendement du Gouvernement
qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté avant qu'on continue je vais
donner la parole au président de la
commission des finances
merci monsieur le Président alors ça
sera pas madame la ministre pour revenir
sur les propos du reporter général qui
propose que je partage par ailleurs je
voudrais simplement vous indiquer que
suite
à certaines
missions que nous avons passé qui
présentait
les avantages d'avoir en discussion
commune quelquefois jusqu'à 80
amendements et qui rendaient le travail
et la compréhension de ce que l'on
faisait la qualité de la discussion en
elle-même tout à fait délicate et par
rapport à une mission celle que nous
regardons maintenant l'écologie
développement immobilier durable qui
ramené à un sujet de même nature j'avais
demandé
à la séance de bien vouloir regarder
s'il y avait des possibilités de
regrouper par des thématiques pour des
débats allant jusqu'au vote etc par
débat et non plus selon les règles
traditionnelles qui sont finalement par
possibilité de gage
c'est ce qui a été fait et je voulais
d'abord je vous voulais vous le dire
remercier je crois en votre nom parce
que ça va améliorer les choses
considérablement les équipes de la
séance qui ont fait un travail
remarquable jusqu'à
il y a pas longtemps pour arriver à nous
faire faire des débats en discussion
commune relativement raisonnable je
dirais pas par leur montant quelquefois
je reste plus modéré sur ce point mais
par contre sur le fait que soit par
thématiser ça nous aider à tous y
compris d'ailleurs au ministre bon donc
je pense qu'on va améliorer nettement
les choses enfin en tout cas je le crois
deuxième point je reste quand même en
tant que président extrêmement attentif
à la façon dont le débat va se dérouler
et éventuellement vous mettre en garde
sur des amendements qui sont d'une
grande qualité quant à l'intérêt du
débat mais pour lesquelles comment dire
un vote pourrait
vider des lignes budgétaires de manière
très forte bon voilà je voulais vous les
découvrirez vous-même
cela étant dit si je n'interviens pas
avant ses amendements ça veut dire que
techniquement c'est réalisable et donc
on peut avoir un amendement très coûteux
mais sur une ligne budgétaire très
importante donc finalement ça peut ça
peut s'entendre par contre d'ores et
déjà et sans aller plus loin comme on va
y arriver assez vite un amendement 1071
de Monsieur laelec je
demanderai simplement c'est qu'à la
suite du débat il est si possible un
retrait parce que à lui seul il vit de
totalment
l'enveloppe ce qui veut dire le gage ce
qui veut dire que tout autre amendement
très peu coûteux qui auraient été voté
après tomberait enfin voilà donc je je
vous l'indique et quelquefois peut-être
dans le débat j'interviendrai pour dire
celui-là voilà restons-en au débat si
possible merci à tous
merci donc nous entamons le débat dans
ces conditions un peu un peu nouvelles
en tenant compte de l'expérience des
expériences précédentes j'en ai vécu
l'autre soir un petit peu compliqué
effectivement
donc
l'amendement 497 monsieur brouiller
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le mini chers
collègues cet amendement par d'un
constat partagé ici par tous et tous le
dispositif m'imprime rénov ne permet pas
d'atteindre les objectifs fixés en 2021
seul 2500 logements sur les 644000
dossiers financés ont changé
qualitativement la performance
énergétique et ma prime rénove reste
trop souvent une rénovation par geste au
détriment d'un projet global il ne faut
pas se contenter de ce constat c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle notre
groupe a proposé une commission
d'enquête pour examiner comment sortir
du statu quo et améliorer la réalité des
performances des objectifs nécessaires à
mettre en oeuvre mais cet amendement
vise à reprendre un amendement débattu à
l'Assemblée nationale qui proposait
d'accorder une augmentation de 6
milliards 850 millions ce chiffre ne
sortant d'ailleurs pas du chapeau d'une
tête écologiste mais étant celui évoqué
préconisé dans le rapport d'Olivier
Sichel de mars 2021 pour être capable
d'avoir une réelle engagement sur les
enjeux que France stratégie a encore
souligné si nous voulons atteindre
l'objectif que nous nous sommes fixés à
savoir baisser les émissions du secteur
de 50%
d'ici 2030 et de 100% d'ici à moitié du
siècle il faudra pousser beaucoup plus
loin les gains d'efficacité de
décarbonation c'est le but cet
amendement qui avait prospéré et
commencer à être débattue à l'Assemblée
nationale jusqu'à 49-3 ne lui donne ne
lui donne une nuit signale une fin de
vie pour nous cet amendement doit donner
un signal à l'ensemble de aux filières à
l'ensemble des partenaires concernés
collectivités professionnelles
locataires bailleurs copropriété pour
dire que le temps est venu de réellement
s'engager sur cette isolation thermique
indispensable pour la planète
indispensable pour le bien-être des
habitants et indispensables pour la
Solidarité sociale dans notre pays
merci alors il y a cinq amendements je
l'ai pas dit fait c'est le premier de 5
amendements qui sont en discussion
commune donc le suivant le 975 monsieur
Dantec oui en complément de l'amendement
précédent celui-ci est un peu moins
élevé puisqu'on en est plus qu'un
milliard 100 000 il s'agit de créer une
aide spécifique à la rénovation pour les
bâtiments
qui sont des classes F et G je crois
qu'il faut quand même avoir en tête qu'à
partir de 2023
les bâtiments les moins performants donc
là j'ai
puis classe F en 2028 et 2034 pour
classer tous ces bâtiments vont devoir
être rénovés donc il va falloir vraiment
mettre beaucoup d'argent sur la table
pour ces rénovations globales donc c'est
le sens de cet amendement mais qui
participe de la même discussion que
l'amendement précédent
merci le 895 je me suis Artano
merci monsieur le Président devient de
plus en plus raisonnable puisque cet
abonnement propose une augmentation de
600 millions pour porter le total des
crédits des aides publiques à la
rénovation énergétique générée par Lana
la proposition se fonde sur une étude en
fait publié par l'initiative rénovante
2020 qui estimait qu'un tel menton
d'Investissement serait nécessaire
chaque année jusqu'en 2040 pour
permettre au minimum la rénovation des
passoires énergétiques au niveau BBC ou
équivalent dans les années à venir
le
983 monsieur fernic oui c'est un
amendement de mon collègue Daniel salmon
que j'ai consigné bien sûr et qui est
identique à l'amendement qui vient
d'être proposé donc augmentation du
budget de la nappe pour le PLF de 600
millions d'euros pour porter les aides
publiques à la rénovation énergétique
géré par l'agence à 3 milliards 2 pour
2022 et enfin le 1076 madame baraillasse
qui viennent de le dire notre amendement
propose d'ouvrir un crédit de 600
millions aussi au titre des aides de la
nappe pour porter la rénovation
énergétique au montant de 3,8 milliards
voilà donc comme j'ai dit dans mon
intervention générale
le niveau des aides actuelles ne permet
pas de faire face au niveau de
performance énergétique dès 2007 que de
2500 logements alors que l'on visait il
faut le rappeler la rénovation de 80 000
face à thermique
merci avis de la commission sur ces cinq
amendements
tous ces amendements effectivement ils
vivent exactement la même chose et un
objectif sur lequel je me suis déjà
exprimé et vous savez que je le soutiens
à savoir accélérer la rénovation
thermique du parc de logement mais j'ai
envie d'aller au-delà du parc de
bâtiment qu'il soit public ou privé et
c'est une nécessité quand on sait que
notamment le logement représente plus de
40% de la consommation finale à usage
énergétique alors une fois qu'on a dit
ça il y a déjà toutes les nuances on va
de 600 millions à 6 milliards 8 donc
vous comprendrez dès que sur
l'amendement assimilé arbitre la vie est
nécessairement défavorable parce que ça
obérait une grande partie de la
discussion et sur les autres ça sera une
demande de retrait alors des moyens
supplémentaires à cette politique ont
déjà été ouverts dans le cadre du PLF
que nous avons adopté il y a quelques
jours et surtout j'ai envie de dire que
aujourd'hui déjà certes si on met des
moyens mais que derrière on n'a pas des
artisans qualifiés qu'on n'est pas en
capacité de monter les dossiers et
monter un dossier de rénovation globale
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que
d'aller cocher une case pour changer sa
chaudière et malheureusement et ça vous
l'avait dit justement aujourd'hui on
fait beaucoup trop de monogestes et ça
permet au présent de la République de se
gargariser de ce qui est fait sur ma
prime rénov mais quand on va dans le
détail regarder ce qui se passe pour la
rénovation globale on y est pas du tout
et le nombre de dossiers chute
drastiquement donc aujourd'hui il faut
que collectivement un effort soit fait
pour aller vers la rénovation globale
mais je craque malheureusement ne soit
pas prêt pour le faire à hauteur des
montants que vous nous demandez des 2023
et je pense que le gouvernement devrait
vraiment faire attention à ce sujet
parce que il y avait un article de prêt
je crois que c'est aujourd'hui ou hier
qui cité trois sujets qu'on a évoqué
aujourd'hui dans cette série comme
explosif c'est la rénovation des
passoires thermiques c'est la ZF et
c'est le zanne donc si on ne se saisit
pas de ces trois sujets je sais pas si
ça sera des gilets jaunes des bonnets
rouges ou quoi mais il y a en tout cas
une révolte qui pourrait gronder donc
vous l'avez compris demande de retrait
mais le sujet n'est pas clos pour autant
madame la ministre
merci beaucoup je crois qu'on est
effectivement très exactement dans ce
que monsieur le président de commission
mentionné c'est-à-dire un débat de fond
qui est important comment on finance la
rénovation thermique de bâtiments et en
particulier comment on accompagne des
ménages qui ont des diversités de
statuts dans des diversités de statuts
de bâtiment copropriété par rapport à
logement individuel diversité de statuts
des ménages c'est à la fois leur revenu
leur patrimoine mais c'est également
sont-ils locataires sont-ils
propriétaires bailleurs ou sont-ils
propriétaires occubants donc c'est pas
tout à fait les mêmes enjeux et la
volonté d'aller plus loin moi je partage
totalement cette volonté d'aller plus
loin je partage également totalement la
vie de Madame la rapporteur c'est que
c'est suffit pas de mettre une un
montant sur la table pour tout de suite
déclencher le halon plus loin cela
suppose de
probablement revoir ou rendre encore
plus performante et efficace
[Musique]
d'accord pour dire que ça ne va pas
assez loin et tout le monde est d'accord
pour dire qu'on va travailler à aller
plus loin et notamment à adresser à la
fois les sujets les plus compliqués
c'est-à-dire les copropriétés et ça ne
se fera pas juste en mettant de l'argent
sur la table ça se fera en revoyant le
processus d'accompagnement des messages
des ménages des copropriétés de la prise
de décision avec des vraies questions
sur comment on prend la décision dans
une copropriété à quel moment on prend
la décision d'aller sur la majorité
simple des présents copropriétés et
est-ce que c'est pas une façon aussi
poser des questions d'équilibre pour
ceux qui ne souhaitent pas forcément
faire ses travaux donc ça c'est une
vraie question je dirais quasiment en
tout cas très politique et certainement
principal la deuxième chose c'est
comment on peut connecter l'efficacité
énergétique à la performance énergétique
réelle sur les années d'après qui à mon
sens peut ouvrir un certain nombre de
champs et justement permettre d'avoir
des contrats de performance la troisième
la même chose c'est ce que porte
Christophe Béchu sur le tiers
financement qui fera l'objet d'une PPL
avec des députés qui sont mobilisés sur
ce sujet là dans la fin du mois de
janvier qui est un sujet dont on a dont
on parle depuis des années et sur lequel
nous voulons enfin faire atterrir des
propositions qui vont permettre d'avoir
un continuum de financement de permettre
de réduire la prise de risque des
financements privés et de faire venir
des financements privés sur cette
problématique donc vous le voyez il y a
des travaux qui sont engagés une je
dirais priorité qui est partagée la
volonté d'aller plus loin mais je ne
voudrais pas qu'on remette aussi ou
qu'on balaye de la main tout ce qui a
déjà été fait 700 000 ménages qui
aujourd'hui bénéficient de ces gestes de
rénovation thermique c'est pas rien et
je peux vous dire que ça se traduit sur
la fracture dès maintenant
bien avant qu'on passe sous votre
monsieur Dantec
oui merci monsieur le Président
j'entends bien ce que vient de dire
Madame Lemmy c'est notamment enfin on va
discuter tiers financement je crois que
il faut qu'on ait
la clarté de dire que le système tel
qu'il est ne peut pas permettre
d'atteindre les objectifs qui sont
devant nous qu'il faut totalement le
remettre à plat et qu'effectivement
Daniel Breuillet a parlé de la
commission d'enquête que nous allons
lancer cette commission d'enquête elle a
volonté d'aller vers des propositions
aussi consensuelles que que possible et
qui peuvent aussi vous inspirer donc
peut-être la première question pour pour
l'ensemble des ministres au ban c'est
dire est-ce que vous prévoyez un temps
de dialogue avec le Parlement pour
justement essayer d'avancer puisque
Christophe bécheux disait tout à l'heure
sur le fond vert que nous avons quelques
peu critiqué cette année c'est un peu la
suite du plan de relance mais on va voir
comment ça marche et on va le changer en
profondeur l'année suivante chiche donc
est-ce qu'on a des lieux de dialogue
pour approfondir parce que je crois que
dans le territoire on a une vraie
expérience pour arriver l'année
prochaine effectivement à quelque chose
qui soit totalement revu deux choses sur
ce qu'il faut revoir je pense qu'il y a
eu une vraie
erreur en ciblant uniquement sur les
ménages modestes je ne dis pas qu'il ne
faut pas aider les ménagement bien
évidemment est-ce que madame la ministre
a dit sur un certain nombre d'action qui
cochait des cases à un impact social
intéressant mais si on a même pas les
classes moyennes vers les rénovations
globales qui ont plus de moyens
d'investissement on ne peut pas y
arriver et là ça pose surtout des
questions d'endettement c'est-à-dire
qu'il faut aussi voir est-ce qu'on peut
sortir un certain nombre
d'investissement du taux d'endettement
des ménages c'est un peu la même chose
pour les collectivités territoriales
avec des retours d'investissement
possible mais à condition de leur
autoriser de nouveaux types de
d'endettement quitte à passer par le tir
investissement on a bien compris donc
c'est une vraie remise à plat dont on a
besoin et on a besoin d'entendre la
disponibilité du gouvernement pour en
discuter ensemble sans tabou et sans
posture
merci donc nous allons passer au vote
sur ces amendements avec des demandes de
retrait ou des avis défavorables
donc vous me le signalez s'ils sont
retirés avant que les soumettent au vote
donc le 487
donc je le remets au bois qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le
même vote non non pas alors qui est pour
qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient qui n'est pas adopté le
895 qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le
983 même vote
le 1076 même vote
nous passons ensuite à l'amendement 894
monsieur Artano
une étude d'impact datant de 2020
produite par l'association label vie
démontre qu'un bonus au service de
l'amélioration de la qualité d'accueil
du bien-être des résidents et de la
protection de l'environnement
permettrait au lieu de vie engager dans
une démarche de développement durable de
réduire de 25% la consommation d'eau en
moyenne et jusqu'à 70% la consommation
d'électricité le présent amendement a
pour objectif d'accompagner la
transformation de l'ensemble des lieux
de vie en créant un bonus au
développement durable permettant de
subventionner une partie des surcoûts
associés il propose de créer un fond
doté de 338 millions d'euros pour
soutenir 50% des lieux de vie de la
petite enfance et du Bien vieillir dans
cette démarche afin de verser un bonus
de 1000 euros par an pour les
assistantes maternelles de 5000 euros
par an pour les crèches et centres de
loisirs et de 10 000 à 20000 euros pour
les EHPAD
merci avis de la commission
c'est une demande de retrait alors
effectivement cet amendement est
intéressant mais quand on vient
sectoriser en fait les publicités
publiques on en aboutit parfois à des
incohérences et j'ai découvert très
récemment que par exemple pour installer
des dispositifs de capteurs de CO2 dans
les écoles on a une aide de l'État à
hauteur de 8 euros par enfant mais que
si jamais on veut mettre ces mêmes
capteurs dans des crèches et on pourrait
penser que les enfants en crèche sont
plus sensibles à la pollution de l'air
que les enfants dans les écoles il n'y a
rien donc j'ai un peu peur qu'en fait si
jamais on adopté cet amendement on en
arrive comme ça à avoir des politiques
publiques saucissonnées et qui à la fin
manque un peu de cohérence donc demande
de retrait
monsieur le ministre
je pourrais presque reprendre les propos
de la rapporteur parce que je pense
qu'effectivement ceci ce n'est pose une
difficulté je comprends l'intérêt et je
veux sans allonger les débats parce que
ce ne sera pas mon intention dans toutes
les interventions que je ferai à compter
maintenant j'en profite pour vous le
dire
faire en sorte d'indiquer que nous avons
près de 400 millions de mètres carrés de
bâtiments publics et que c'est pour ces
400 millions qui convient qu'on aille
présenter quelque chose ce sera l'objet
du dispositif du tiers financement qui
vous sera présenté avec l'obsession de
se demander comment ça impacte pas les
ratios d'endettement des collectivités
et donc en pensant les véhicules qui
nous permettront de nous appuyer sur des
dispositifs de ce type on aura
l'occasion d'évoquer ça au début de
l'année prochaine on est au cœur de la
planification mais si on fait ça que
pour un type de bâtiment on va se
retrouver avec des difficultés parce
qu'on aura d'autres qui pourraient le
mériter et qui ne sont pas retenues donc
demande de retrait merci donc une double
demande de retrait vous retirez monsieur
Artano retiré donc on passe ensuite à la
discussion sur cet amendement discussion
commune donc le 1029 monsieur Gillet
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre
cet amendement était déposé par mon
collègue Olivier Jacquin il remet en
perspective en fait le manque de clarté
aujourd'hui de la part du gouvernement
sur sa politique d'investissement au
niveau des infrastructures versières
avec les récentes déclarations en plus
du président de la République sur le RER
métropolitain où va-t-on exactement
c'est quelque part un peu le sens de cet
amendement puisque nous avons besoin
d'une vision à long terme pour le
ferroviaire et surtout avec la mise en
place d'un grand plan d'investissement
fondé sur une grande loi de
programmation plus réelle ferroviaire et
alors de quelle manière donc aujourd'hui
ces investissements qui sont prévus se
traduisent dans le projet de loi de
finance si vous avez des réponses très
factuelles et très concrètes je serai
ravi de pouvoir les entendre en tout cas
pour doubler la part du train en France
développer les RER métropolitain pour
relier les territoires doublés à part du
fret moderniser l'ensemble du réseau et
bien c'est amendement propose un soutien
massif au ferroviaire de l'ordre de 3
milliards d'euros
merci
Monsieur
Laennec pour le 1071
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Mesdames et Messieurs les
reporters
cet amendement s'inscrit dans le
prolongement des propos que nous avons
entendu à l'instant de la part de
Messieurs les rapporteurs de la
commission des finances du rapporteur de
la commission d'aménagement du
territoire et bien entendu j'ai attendu
j'ai entendu également
l'appel à une certaine prudence
de monsieur le rapporteur de la
commission des finances
monsieur le Président de la Commission
pardon
mais cette amendement que nous proposons
n'avait rien de très original en ce sens
qu'il avait il est réputé avoir déjà été
adopté à l'Assemblée nationale
et nous savons qu'elle sort il lui a été
réservé je ne reviens pas sur les propos
de mon collègue Ginet
depuis il y a quand même eu ces
déclarations de Monsieur le Président de
la République
je n'irai pas jusqu'à dire qu'il y a
soutenu cet amendement mais qui n'a pas
attendu le rapport de la Commission du
coi
par conséquent c'est un élément nouveau
et nous avons tenu compte de cet élément
nouveau
c'est amendement visait aussi l'objectif
présenté sûrement en tout cas l'avantage
[Musique]
d'éviter d'avoir à traiter d'un côté
le rail des villes et d'un autre côté le
rail des champs
et donc c'est tout l'objet de ce
de cet amendement et bien entendu j'ai
entendu cet appel à la prudence
et nous ne défendons pas nous le royaume
du tout ou rien pour une raison très
simple c'est qu'au Royaume du tout ou
rien c'est toujours le rien qui
l'emporte par conséquent nous sommes
preneurs de tout avancer qui serait
proposé et pour autant le débat n'est
pas clous sur ces 3 milliards qui
étaient proposés dans ce rapport je
propose donc que nous acceptions le
principe d'un retrait moyennant la
sagesse dont on nous parle par ailleurs
le 1030 présenté par Madame filleul
si monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
[Musique]
par rapport à l'amendement précédent
déposé par Monsieur Jacquin et vise à
investir un milliard 5 d'euros
supplémentaires dans le développement du
frais de ferroviaire j'allais dire
seulement un milliard 5 la France s'est
fixée en effet pour objectif de doubler
la part du frais de ferroviaire à
l'horizon 2030 or c'est bien dernières
années des centaines de gares de fret et
d'embranchement ont été fermés et le
nombre de cheminots travaillant à Fret
SNCF et passer de 12000 à 4000 afin
d'enrayer cette dynamique et se fixer un
objectif de 30% du transport de
marchandises par le fret ferroviaire
avant 2030 il convient d'investir
massivement dans la relance du frais de
ferroviaire notamment à travers la
régénération et le développement du
réseau d'infrastructures je vous
remercie
merci le 1119 monsieur ferrique
sur le ferroviaire c'était il y a plus
d'une heure Hervé Morin nous décrivait
clairement ce mur d'investissement
colossal pour reprendre ces termes qui
est devant nous ce mur on peut pas se
contenter de rester au pied même en
écoutant les incantations
présidentielles qui sonnent bien à mon
oreille de strasbourgeois parce que
notre réseau express métropolitain c'est
la semaine prochaine qu'il se commence à
se déployer donc ce mur il nous faut au
moins en commencer l'ascension et donc
cette proposition à un milliard 5 pour
compléter les deux milliards 8 prévus au
contrat de performance SNCF réseau cette
proposition c'est celle qui avait été
présentée sur les bancs de droite à
gauche de cette assemblée au PLF 2022
c'est ce qui est une réponse à cette
occasion manquée pour reprendre les
termes du président de la RT qui contrat
de performance SNCF réseau
c'est la trajectoire pour doubler la
part modale du train
comprenez
messieurs madame la ministre que que cet
amendement 10 fois plus important que ce
qu'expert au moins notre collègue Tabaro
par le sien il nous a dit tout à l'heure
qu'il était bien conscient qu'il en
faudrait plus c'est amendement et
clairement un appel à cette loi de
programmation ferroviaire à la hauteur
de nos ambitions partagées merci le 1031
madame filleul
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre nous estimons avec Monsieur
Jacquin nécessaire d'investir 700
millions d'euros supplémentaires dans la
régénération et le développement du
réseau petite ligne ferroviaire ces
lignes du quotidien si importantes sur
nos territoires notamment ruraux sont
depuis de nombreuses années délaissés
pourtant elle garantissent
l'attractivité économique et touristique
la mobilité des populations à
l'intérieur et entre les territoires et
constitue une alternative bas carbone à
la voiture individuelle forcé de
rappeler que souvent la voiture n'est
pas tant le mode de transport choisi
lorsque la distance est importante qu'un
mode de transport subit lié à l'absence
de solutions alternatives de transport
collectif ou à l'insuffisance de l'offre
lorsque cette alternative existe
seul le maintien des petites lignes
ferroviaires existantes le développement
d'une offre nouvelle et renforcée autour
des heures de pointe dans les zones
urbaines et une politique tarifaire
attractive sont susceptibles d'offrir
une alternative crédible et effective
pour nos concitoyens
merci et puis maintenant deux
amendements
identiques
le premier porté par Monsieur tabaron au
nom de la commission de l'aménagement du
territoire du développement durable
merci monsieur le Président Madame
Monsieur le Ministre j'avais pris date
cet été lors du PLF faire 2022 par un
amendement d'appel comme une forme de
signal pour créer le débat avec nombre
de collègues pour répondre enfin au
nouveau ferroviaire aujourd'hui je
défends cet amendement de commission qui
vise à louer 150 millions d'euros à la
régénération du réseau ferroviaire le
nouveau contrat de performance 113 SNCF
réseau et l'étape prévoit de maintenir à
un effort de régénération annuel du
réseau de l'ordre de 2,9 milliards
pourtant tous les acteurs du secteur et
nous l'avons répété les uns et les
autres s'accordent pour considérer ce
montant n'est pas à la hauteur des
enjeux dans ce contexte il est
indispensable d'augmenter les moyens
vous l'avez partiellement fait dans ce
PLF monsieur le ministre mais il est
indispensable de les augmenter encore un
petit peu plus c'est l'objet du présente
amendement qui compte tenu des
contraintes pesant sur les finances
publiques vise à louer 150 millions
d'euros supplémentaires à la
régénération du réseau ferroviaire alors
c'est loin de faire la maille mais cela
enclenche un cycle d'investissement plus
vertueux et plus ambitieux
et puis le même amendement présenté par
Monsieur Moret au nom de la commission
des finances
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
Monsieur le Ministre sur la présentation
de cet amendement je vais pas m'étendre
puisque c'est exactement le même que
celui de la Commission de l'amergement
du territoire du développement durable
ce dont je me réjouis parce que souvent
on a des oppositions entre entre
commissions et notamment entre la
commission des finances et les autres
commissions en du budget là on présente
le même le même amendement et donc je
n'ai pas le détailler ça a été très bien
fait par le rapporteur de la commission
américaine au territoire et
développement durable je vais donc être
d'accord tout de suite donner un avis
sur les 7 amendements cet avis vous vous
le pressez vous le devinez on a 7
amendements qui tousse propose de mettre
plus de moyens sur le ferroviaire avec
une spécificité pour le 1031 qui vise
plus spécifiquement les les petites
lignes je crois qu'on est tous d'accord
et vous savez très bien ce que nous
avons notamment à la commission des
finances avec ses Vans sotarelles
proposées au mois de février dans notre
rapport on est tous de la nécessité de
faire un effort colossal sur le
ferroviaire dont l'état je l'ai rappelé
dans mon intervention tout à l'heure et
plus que préoccupant pour autant les
amendements qui sont sur des montants de
3 milliards un milliard et demi nous
paraissent un petit peu élevé à ce stade
de la discussion budgétaire et qui plus
est je pense que si on les voté la SNCF
ne serait pas en mesure d'engager ces
crédits sur l'exercice 2023 donc quand
bien même pourrait-on les mettre sur la
table on constaterait à la fin
d'exercice 2023 qu'ils n'ont pas été
engagés comme on a pu le constater tout
à l'heure avec les dépenses de la fuite
donc j'invite tous mes collègues à part
bien sûr la commission la majeur de
territoire a retiré les amendements qui
ont été déposés au profit de ceux de la
Commission émergement du territoire et
de la commission des finances je vous
remercie merci monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs quelques mots si
vous me permettez de pas réagir sur
chaque point mais je crois que c'est ce
sont des amendements qui sont importants
pour reprendre les mots du sénateur
fermé qu'ils sont une appel à une
ambition ferroviaire que je crois nous
partageons très largement entre le
gouvernement et l'ensemble de ces bancs
ou en tout cas la quasi-totalité dans
les interventions que j'ai entendu il
n'y a pas de contradiction je crois
entre porter une ambition comme la
rappeler par exemple prendre la
République sur les RER métropolitain et
donner un cap politique et construire
notre budget de manière méthodique pour
rappeler quelques éléments nous avons
dans ce budget dans un certain nombre
d'efforts financiers qui sont connexes
ou complémentaires je pense au budget de
la fuite qui va être adopté dans
quelques jours je pense aux taxes
affectées à la Société du Grand Paris
nous avons un certain nombre au contrat
de performance parlant de la SNCF réseau
on attaque l'État que vous avez rappelé
nous avons un certain nombre d'outils
qui au total Christophe bechul rappelait
tout à l'heure permettent d'investir
plus de 6 milliards d'euros d'effort
là-dessus je veux préciser quelques
points puisque les différents
amendements je partirai par celui qui
envisageait la plus grande hausse de
crédit budgétaire les autres sont dans
le même esprit plus ou moins modérées
sur quelques points qui sont relevés à
cette occasion la question du réseau le
contrat de performance de virgule 9
milliards d'euros par an j'entends
beaucoup de critiques sur ce contrat de
performance je veux quand même le
défendre parce que il porte sur une sur
un horizon décennale et nous avons
besoin de visibilité nous avons besoin
d'engagement la durée pour notre réseau
ferroviaire il augmente les crédits par
rapport à ce qui existait les années
précédentes et je rappelle que nous
avons commencé la décennie 2010 il y a
moins de 10 ans d'ailleurs à moins de 2
milliards d'euros par an
d'investissement dans le trésor
ferroviaire on est aujourd'hui avant le
contrat de performance un peu au-delà de
2,5 milliards et on est à 2,9 par an sur
les 10 ans qui viennent dans ce contrat
de performance donc c'est un vrai
réengagement un vrai réinvestissement
sur notre réseau ferroviaire doit-on
aller plus loin je le crois profondément
j'ai l'occasion de le dire publiquement
devant les commissions du Sénat dans
l'hémicycle je crois aussi et c'est à
travers le rapport du coi notamment ou
c'est déjà qu'il faudra renforcer cette
ambition que nous aurons l'occasion de
débattre de cette trajectoire à quel
rythme comment nous renforcerons encore
notre effort dans l'investissement du
réseau j'en ai fait vous le savez une
priorité vous n'êtes pas obligé de me
croire sur parole donc vous me croirez
sans doute dans les chiffres et nous
aurons ces débats et ces combats menés
je crois de manière assez eucuménique si
vous me permettez l'expression dans les
mois qui viennent je l'indique aussi
puisque j'ai évoqué le budget de la fit
vous connaissez la subtilité des budgets
des transports ils sont un peu
éparpillés d'ores et déjà avec
Christophe Béchu nous avons souhaité
obtenu que comme un signal comme un
appel à se renforcer encore il y a 100
millions de plus sur la régénération du
réseau ferroviaire par rapport à ce qui
était prévu dans le contrat de
performance et dans la trajectoire
l'homme qui soit ajouté sur cette
régénération donc dans l'année 2023
c'est une préfiguration de l'orientation
que nous esquissons aujourd'hui ça
n'apparaît pas directement donc je
voulais aussi livrer les informations
puisque le budget de la fuite sera voté
soumis à vote en tout cas dans quelques
jours mais il faudra je le dis oui aller
plus loin et surtout tenir dans la durée
cet effort sur le réseau ferroviaire
ensuite sur la question du fret il y a
deux ans maintenant 18 mois un plan fret
national une stratégie fraise nationale
a été définie elle prévoit des moyens
importants c'est un plan total d'un
milliard d'euros il y a en ce moment les
aides de si on met bout à bout les aides
au wagon isolé d'autres types d'aides
qui atteignent 170 millions d'euros par
an qui sont prévus jusqu'à 2024 j'ai
indiqué devant la profession elle est
organisations du frais de ferroviaire il
y a quelques jours que nous
prolongerions ces aides jusqu'à 2027
parce que là aussi nous avons besoin
pour que le plan porte ses fruits et il
a des premiers résultats avec une
augmentation de la part modale du fret
de maintenir cet effort dans la durée
donc c'est important je tenais aussi à
le préciser sur la question des petites
lignes c'est un plan que le gouvernement
précédent sous l'autorité personnelle de
Jean Castex très attaché vous le savez à
se réengagement de l'État aussi
a permis d'amplifier il y a un objectif
de 9000 km de petites lignes à préserver
ou à mieux entretenir parfois à rouvrir
d'ailleurs ça s'apprend la forme de
protocole d'accord entre l'État et les
régions 8 protocoles est un région déjà
été signé j'ai envie j'encourage pardon
toutes les régions qui ne l'auraient pas
encore fait à rejoindre cette démarche
nous y sommes ouverts et nous mettrons
des financements avec toutes celles qui
s'engagent dans cette démarche dans le
cadre des prochains CPR et leur volet
mobilité d'ores et déjà sur l'ambition
de 9000 km c'est plus le 6000 km de
lignes qui font l'objet de ces
protocoles et en 2022 c'était 200
millions d'euros de l'État sans compter
les financements régionaux qui sont
déployés pour les petites lignes et cela
continuera dans les années qui viennent
conformément au protocole qui ont été
signés je crois là aussi que c'est une
ambition qui est importante je pourrais
détailler sur les trains de nuit sur
d'autres éléments sur les trains de nuit
en un mot nous aurons à prendre une
décision là aussi en 2023 sans doute en
fin d'année sur des commandes de
matériel roulants supplémentaires
calibrer les formes budgétaires et le
calendrier industriel nous aurons donc
l'occasion d'en reparler mais je veux
insister nous aurons renforcé nos
efforts sur ces grands objets d'avenir
que sont notamment le réseau les RER
métropolitains nous aurons à prévoir des
cofinancement entre l'État les régions
d'autres collectivités et l'Union
européenne nous aurons à débattre de
beaucoup de ces sujets notamment la
question du réseau sur la base en
particulier du rapport du coi nous
aurons le rendez-vous des contrats de
plan est à région au cours du premier
semestre 2023 comme je m'y suis engagé
sous l'autorité de la première ministre
donc je crois que nous avons d'autres
rendez-vous ce n'est pas pour minimiser
l'importance de ce budget 2023 je crois
qu'il porte déjà une ambition que cette
ambition nous devons la renforcer et
surtout j'insiste parce que c'est
souvent ce qui pêche disons le
franchement dans le secteur des
infrastructures les transports à le
consolider à le maintenir dans la durée
car réinvestir une année ou deux années
dans notre réseau c'est bien mais avoir
un effort de 5 ou 10 ans continue c'est
ce qu'il y a de plus important et c'est
ce sur quoi je veux m'engager avec vous
dans les prochains mois
donc monsieur le ministre le rejet des
amendements avec des feux de quoi le
gouvernement exprimera un avis
défavorable
donc sur donc le 1029 monsieur Gillet
merci monsieur le Président nous allons
retirer le 1029 et le 1030 nous allons
maintenir le 1031 mais par rapport à la
déclaration de ministre mais en fait
l'inscription budgétaire dans le périph
2023 vous affichez une somme mais on
voit pas du tout les fléchages et c'est
tout le problème à l'heure actuelle
c'est tout le problème vous ne vous
positionnez pas politiquement sur une
future loi de programmation qui nous
permettrait d'avoir clairement les
priorités qui sont affichées et de
savoir quels sont les objectifs annuels
qui seront poursuivis on ne les connaît
pas vous citez le COI aujourd'hui mais
ça nous renvoie à quoi c'est pas le PLF
2023 à une future loi de finances
rectificative donc c'est un rendez-vous
financier que vous nous donnez puisqu'on
n'a pas les éléments du coi à l'heure
actuelle donc on est dans un flou total
par rapport à ça il n'y a pas de
prospective qui soit réellement partagée
sur ces sujets là d'où les différentes
interventions des collègues pour pouvoir
afficher des montants à la hauteur de
l'ensemble de nos ambitions mais vous
courez plusieurs liens vers à la fois
toujours pas d'affichage de priorité et
vous nous laissez à penser qu'on pourra
tout faire tout financer c'est
exactement aussi quand on vous écoute
d'un peu plus près c'est ça que l'on
entend il y a pas de priorité qui sont
réellement dégagées c'est ça le fond du
problème monsieur le ministre
aujourd'hui qui justifie l'intervention
de l'ensemble des collègues
effectivement sur le sujet
nous allons proposer de voter nous
proposons de voter évidemment les
abondements tels qu'ils ont été
exprimées ici ce qui veut dire que le
retrait de l'amendement des 3 milliards
ne signifie pas un renoncement mais au
contraire une exigence démocratique et
un objectif qu'on entend bien se fixer
donc retrait pour voter
l'abondement qui a été prévu tel que
proposée par la Commission
sur le mini monsieur ferick on va
peut-être faire le tour et puis je
j'ai en mémoire une audition nous avions
fait en commission la maison du
territoire développement durable du
président des SNCF réseau je crois et
nous lui posons la question qu'elle
était le volume de travaux sur le réseau
que vous pouvez d'ores et déjà
être capable de réaliser sur une année
il nous disait de mémoire je crois pas
que je me trompe 300 millions d'euros
Philippe tabaron corrigera si je me
trompe 300 millions d'euros on y arrive
avec les 150 millions que vous rajoutez
et si on y rajoute l'amendement de la
commission développement durable sur
laquelle je me rabats car qui ne veut
pas arriver au plus peut au moins
espérer un petit peu moins
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président alors moi je
voudrais dire à Monsieur le Ministre que
vous ne pouvez pas démultiplier les
déclarations et les communications sur
la colonne vertébrale du ferroviaire
sans y ajouter les moyens nécessaires
vous avez fait voilà un exposé très
clair mais je ne comprends pas pourquoi
vous ne soutenez pas cette amendement et
le non soutien de cette amendement elle
est relève encore une fois
l'inadéquation entre annonces politiques
et action quand ce qui nous concerne
nous respectons notre engagement pour
donner de l'élan nécessaire au
ferroviaire et engager une planification
crédible et réaliste j'aimerais dire à
mes collègues de la droite ou de
l'extrême droite de l'hémicycle par
rapport à l'endroit où je me situe bien
sûr que je salue leur ambition mais je
crains qu'à cette hauteur elle
desservent la cause ferroviaire que nous
avons en partage et je pense notamment
la possibilité de consommer les crédits
que ce soit pour réseau que ce soit pour
la fit également au niveau administratif
enfin je note avec plaisir la vie
favorable
avec plaisir et bonheur la vie favorable
de la commission des finances du
rapporteur général le soutien sans
faille du rapporteur spécial ou de la
rapporteur spécial et de mes collègues
m'aurait SAREL qui ont emboîté le pas
pour être cohérent avec leur excellent
rapport de février j'appelle enfin de
mes vœux comme cela était dit à une
vraie loi de programmation ambitieuse
plus ryanuelle et novatrice pour le
transport
monsieur la Mini
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président Madame et
messieurs les ministres messieurs les
présidents de commissions financent
développement durable Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteur chers collègues
juste quelques mots je ferai pas
beaucoup d'interventions sur le
ferroviaire mais mais je tenais quand
même à la en faire au moins une
j'irai pour aller dans le sens j'ai lu
avec intérêt naturellement le rapport de
mes deux collègues de la commission des
finances Hervé Moret Stéphane sauterelle
sur un rapport très dense qui a demandé
aussi beaucoup beaucoup de travail et on
souhaite que suite soit donné aux
différentes recommandations qui figurent
qui figurent puis également le travail
des trois rapporteurs de la Commission
de développement durable Philippe Tabaro
un impéraud et Monsieur Gillet document
aussi particulièrement intéressant et je
crois que là
un jour et volontiers consigner les
amendements ou il y avait plus de de
montants financiers 3 milliards d'euros
par exemple et
est en fils de cheminots et puis étant
un passionné comme un certain nombre
d'ici dans cette hémicycle du
ferroviaire en particulier des petites
lignes je ne je défends pas forcément
que le TGV mais plus particulièrement le
fret capillaire et en particulier les
petites lignes qui font partie aussi de
la notion d'aménagement du territoire et
je crois que c'est réellement important
de et naturellement qui est des
investissements qui soient portés
investissement porté certes par l'État
mais aussi un partenariat avec
l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales les régions les
départements les intercommunalités
notamment pour
sauver des des lignes en termes
d'investissement en termes
d'infrastructures et on sait que il y a
encore beaucoup à faire mais né point je
soutiendrai les deux amendements des
deux commissions parce que je pense que
là sont plus modestes en financiers je
les soutiendrai
merci monsieur le Président et moi je
soutiendrai les amendements de la
commission présentée par Philippe Tabaro
et celui de la commission des finances
je suis pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est ça a été soulevé par le
président Mauret il y a une vraie
coordination entre la commission des
finances et celle de l'aménagement du
territoire je trouve que c'est important
elle faisait en vrai elle a dit quelque
chose de réel on peut mettre tous les
crédits on peut les multiplier par 10
par 20 par 30 par 40 mais si on n'a pas
les moyens derrière de réaliser les
travaux on se sera fait plaisir mais on
ira pas au bout et c'est amendement qui
a présenté Philippe Tabaro est un
amendement de bon sens avant de vendre
bon sens parce que 1 il montre que on
veut absolument travailler sur la
restauration à la rénovation des réseaux
mais avec des moyens qui restent
légitimes et j'ai bien entendu
qu'il aurait bien aimé mettre avoir des
crédits supplémentaires mais je crois
qu'il en est resté au crédit auquel on
peut effectivement répondre
favorablement et je crois que ce bon
sens c'est aussi ce respect de de
l'argent public et qui va permettre
d'améliorer et de remettre en route les
réseaux qui sont effectivement dégradés
et bien je pense que nous devons toutes
et tous voter ces deux amendements je
vous remercie
merci Madame Fillol à ce stade pour
préciser donc il reste en fait le 1031
et l'amendement commun des deux
commissions puisque si j'ai bien compris
celui de Monsieur de faire ni qui
retirait aussi vas-y c'est à ce propos
monsieur le Président que je voulais
intervenir pour retirer l'amendement
1031 en cohérence et pour voter bien sûr
l'amendement de ma commission celui de
Monsieur tabarou
bien donc monsieur le ministre avant
qu'on passe au vote sur l'amendement
merci monsieur le Président rapidement
pour essayer de
réconcilier de mettre autant que je le
puisse la cohérence qui je pense et
celle de ce budget entre les différents
éléments que vous avez rappelé on dit
juste titre il y a pas tout dans le PLF
2023 parce que d'abord il y a des
supports budgétaires on peut le
regretter mais assez différent dans
l'organisation de notre financement de
politique de transport les taxes
affectés à ceux du Grand Paris nous
avons un budget annexe en matière
d'évasion civile nous avons la structure
de Lafitte ça ne date pas de cette année
donc effectivement c'est pour ça que je
donnais ces précisions il est parfois
difficile d'appréhender l'ensemble de
l'effort construit mais on dit il y a
pas tout dans ce PLF on veut voir des
priorités et il nous faut du coup une
programmation aussi c'est exactement ce
que vous propose dans ce PLF et si on
rajoute les éléments à fit etc je crois
qu'on a des priorités qui sont très
claires je réponds monsieur le sénateur
à ce que vous disiez sur on ne voit pas
les axes prioritaires j'ai essayé de le
dire mais vous conviendrai avec moi que
d'avoir des priorités ne veut pas dire
que il y a pas une diversité de choses à
faire je prends un seul exemple les
priorités je les dis c'est le réseau et
c'est le ferroviaire notamment les
transports du quotidien mais ça veut pas
dire pour autant que le fret n'est pas
ou pour prendre un ensemble de trois
amendements je crois qui étaient
proposés voté je m'en réjouis par le
Sénat il y a quelques jours qu'on ne
finance plus par exemple des lignes à
grande vitesse mais les amendements qui
ont été portés et votés pour financer
par taxe affecté local GPSO lmpca et
lmppm c'est exactement ça on arrête de
divertir des ressources pour la grande
vitesse qui pèse sur nos priorités en
matière de frais de transport du
quotidien mais on n'arrête pas pour
autant en essayant de projet stratégique
on les finances plus intelligemment si
je peux dire différemment et de manière
concertée je pense que c'est une bonne
illustration donc avoir des priorités je
le répète c'est très clair c'est le
réseau le ferroviaire est transport du
quotidien en particulier ça veut pas
dire qu'il y a rien d'autre et vous
m'avez d'ailleurs vous-même interrogé et
présenter même dans vos amendements à
chaque fois plusieurs éléments et
plusieurs thèmes et à juste titre
d'ailleurs les amendements qu'ils soient
à 3 milliards d'euros ou un peu moins de
évoquent plusieurs éléments
d'intervention et de financement public
dans le domaine du ferroviaire fret
petite ligne notamment donc je pense que
il est très important d'avoir ce cadre
et de le rappeler et je crois que ça
transparaît dans le budget mais je suis
convaincu comme vous que nous avons
besoin en effet de visibilité plus
réelle nous avons déjà des outils je
vais pas tous les lister mais c'est
notamment le cas du contrat de
performance sur le réseau sur 10 ans on
peut pas dire que c'est pas de l'aimant
de visibilité même si on souhaite aller
plus loin et nous avons en effet un
rendez-vous je peux pas tout faire
porter sur ce rendez-vous mais il est
important vous y participez que celui du
Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures et sur cette base je le
redis nous aurons définir un Christophe
Béchu et sous l'autorité de la première
ministre la forme exacte mais nous
souhaitons bien qu'il y ait une
visibilité plus réelle un débat et une
programmation plus réelle voilà pour
être très clair sur ce sujet bien merci
Monsieur le Ministre donc à ce stade il
nous reste deux amendements les deux
amendements qui sont faites identiques
des deux commissions à voter avec un
avis défavorable du gouvernement donc
qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient ils sont adoptés donc
nous passons à l'amendement suivant le
1091 monsieur Gillet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre c'est amendement permet ce
ministre de revenir sur quelques
déclarations vous pouvez faire et
notamment celle du président de la
République sur les RER métropolitains
pour tout vous dire cette déclaration la
bousculé un peu certains présidents de
la métropole qui avait l'impression que
le Président de la République courait
derrière la victoire puisque c'était des
coups qui étaient déjà partis alors
qu'après il y ait des investissements et
un engagement de l'État plus important
que celui qui est aujourd'hui nous
verrons et ça sera effectivement une
bonne nouvelle dans ce cas de figure
mais c'est le cas sur Bordeaux métropole
aujourd'hui et le président alain
Anziani a réagi d'ailleurs dans ce
sens-là donc la question qui est posée
aujourd'hui par rapport à cet élan
nouveau qui a été proposé c'est de voir
de quand de quelle manière on peut
satisfaire l'ensemble de ces nouvelles
ambitions ferroviaires on l'a indiqué
précédemment sur un amendement qu'on
avait retiré mais après avoir supprimé
les milliards ajoutés à l'Assemblée
nationale nous sommes quand même
nécessaire notamment par rapport à ces
déclarations de RER métropolitain de
rajouter un milliard d'euros
supplémentaires sur des projets qui sera
estimés à 13 milliards ce qui donnera
pour le coup une clé de lecture très
évidente de l'engagement du gouvernement
et du président de la République pour
accompagner ses projets
merci monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le Président
je dirais que c'est un peu l'amendement
pied du mur pour le gouvernement ou
l'amendement chiche c'est vrai qu'on a
vous l'avez dit faire collègue tout
c'était très étonné de ces annonces du
président de la République auquel on
s'attendait d'autant moins que la parole
qui nous est donnée par les pouvoirs
publics c'est de dire attendons les
travaux du coi pour savoir un petit peu
ce que ce que l'on veut pour les pour
les années qui viennent donc par cet
amendement je vous proposais finalement
au gouvernement de s'engager résolument
sur ce qu'a proposé le président de la
République et donc compte tenu de cette
situation la commission des finances
s'en remet à la vie du gouvernement
le gouvernement
je vous remercie de cette confiance
là aussi un mot
faut procéder je reprends ce que disait
il y a un instant le président Longeau
avec méthode et avec pragmatisme sur la
consommation des crédits et sur la façon
dont on traduit une ambition politique
qui n'est pas nouvelle ça a été rappelé
d'ailleurs par Jacques ferrique il y a
des projets qui sont déjà bien avancés à
tel point que le RER métropolitain
Strasbourg verra le début de son
fonctionnement le 11 décembre prochain
qu'il y a des projets qui sont étudiés
qu'on fait l'objet d'un rapport que vous
connaissez public de SNCF réseau en
particulier en octobre 2020 et que
d'ailleurs je le crois si je veux faire
une remarque plus politique que le
prendre la République alors candidat
avait évoqué à nouveau l'ambition des
RER métropolitain dans la campagne
présidentielle avant d'en reparler je
m'en félicite nous en félicitons avec
Christophe Béchu il y a quelques jours
mais l'idée n'a pas été une idée surgit
je vous rassure et vous le savez de
aucun travaux ou de aucune réflexion
préalable il y a quelques jours on le
sait puisque des études ont été faites
des projets ont commencé à voir le jour
ce que nous disons c'est que là aussi
dans le cadre du rapport du coi en
travaillant dans les prochains mois il
faudra définir les priorités les tracés
les financements avec les collectivités
concernées peut-être en étant dans notre
boîte à outils pour traduire cette
ambition encore mieux encore plus vite
je pense par exemple à l'idée de société
de projet comme on le fait justement
pour des lignes grande vitesse ça peut
être un outil pour les collectivités qui
souhaiteraient sans saisir et s'ils
Parlement en est d'accord car il faudra
certainement une dispositions
législatives pour faciliter le
financement de certains projets locaux
de RER métropolitain donc on a encore du
travail on a une ambition politique et
là aussi je le dis toujours pour faire
écho à ce qui était dit notamment par le
prénom Anjo si on mettait un milliard
d'euros dans le budget immédiatement on
ne saurait pas consommer un milliard
d'euros même avec toute la bonne volonté
du monde pour faire avancer plus vite
les RER métropolitain donc je comprends
le message je comprends l'orientation je
vous le dis très franchement puisque à
la fin nous parlons d'euros sonore et
trébuchant et puis d'un gage par
ailleurs nous ne serions pas utilisés
immédiatement un milliard d'euros donc
procédons dans cette ordre là si vous en
êtes d'accord le rapport du coi nos
travaux la programmation par ces grandes
priorités assumées des RER
métropolitains et avec des outils de
financement qui seront un peu nouveau
qui ne seront pas que budgétaires parce
que je pense je pense pardon que pour
les collectivités comme pour l'État ce
ne serait sans doute pas tout à fait
soutenable
donc avis défavorable du gouvernement
[Musique]
qui ont des favorables également
je prends acte monsieur le ministre que
derrière les propos du président de la
République il y a pas de moyens
pas de moyens vous parlez d'un milliard
d'euros mais il y a aucune orientation
budgétaire qui donne de la crédibilité à
la parole du président de la République
ça pose question quand même le président
de la République d'ailleurs il aurait
fait cette déclaration d'une manière
peut-être plus collective avec les
collectivités territoriales qui étaient
concernées peut-être que les
interventions que nous avons faites sur
les bancs aurait été différente mais le
fait qu'il dirige avec cette parole sur
cette promesse gouvernementale sans en
donner une once de moyens sur les
perspectives 2023 ça pose réellement
question c'est pour ça que c'est un
moment nous maintiendrons bien donc
monsieur Béchu
au début du mois de janvier nous
recevrons les territoires concernés pour
que y compris dans le processus du coi
les choses prennent cette mesure mais ce
qui vient de vous êtes dit par le
ministre des Transports est totalement
exact faites un vote coût des classes si
vous le souhaitez dans la continuité la
discussion et les négociations parce
qu'on ne discute pas que dry mais de
gare d'infrastructures
nécessite qu'on est le temps
d'adaptation et encore une fois vous
blâmez finalement des annonces comme il
vous arrive parfois de blâmer le fait
qu'il n'y en ait pas ça fait finalement
une juste mesure nous prenons la nous
prêchons pour une méthode qui vient
d'être appelée par Clément Bonn un
rapport une orientation qui fait que
maintenant tout le monde sait que les
erreurs métropolitains seront dans le
socle des scénarios coi et derrière un
temps de rencontre avec les
collectivités et des moyens dédiés
bien nous allons donc passer au vote sur
l'amendement il est maintenu donc qui
est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement suivant le on sent 17
monsieur ferick oui je rebondis sur ce
que vient de dire le monsieur le
ministre
on a compris le message l'orientation et
partagée ça nécessite un temps
d'adaptation de travail avant de passer
à des moyens dédiés alors justement il y
a une question sur lesquelles toute une
partie de ce travail est déjà eu lieu et
ou en gros les moyens dédiés sont déjà
consommés c'est le travail pour répondre
aux problèmes du frais de ferroviaire
face au surcoût énergétique l'enjeu
c'est que notre plan frette auquel
allusion tout à l'heure le ministre
Clement beau ne capote pas comme ces
prédécesseurs avec les surcos
énergétiques donc dans le PLF qui est
derrière nous la concertation avec les
opérateurs du fait de ferroviaire et le
travail parlementaire a permis d'arriver
un amendement accepté par le
Gouvernement qui a mis en place un
dispositif de soutien pour prendre en
charge la moitié du le surcoût
énergétique sous forme d'une part de
prise en charge par l'État d'une part de
prise en charge des pH frais à hauteur
de 26 millions d'euros ce dispositif
fonctionne
il donne des résultats on voit la part
modale du frais de ferroviaire qui
continue sa progression c'est très bien
donc pour continuer cette trajectoire
qui nous amène vers le doublement il
faut à tout prix prolonger et amplifier
ce dispositif de soutien j'ai cru
comprendre à l'intervention de Clément
beau d'une des deux dernières je crois
que son intention c'était poursuivre cet
accompagnement pour la réussite du plan
fret c'est exactement ce que cet
amendement vous propose
monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le Président j'ai
encore demandé la vie du gouvernement
c'est pas c'est pas dans mes habitudes
et rassurez-vous ça ne va pas être notre
position tout au long de la séance mais
on va à nouveau demander la vie du
gouvernement parce que effectivement il
y a une vraie problématique et ça a été
très bien très bien souligné mais on
selon nos informations il y aurait des
discussions en cours entre la DGITM et
les professionnels qui pourraient
aboutir à ce que des mesures soient
proposées dans le courant de l'année
2023 et que ça se traduise dans le cadre
d'un PLFR comme ça s'est passé vous
l'avez rappelé en 2022 et c'est pour ça
sans que ça soit je vous le promets une
habitude de ma part pour cette séance je
m'en remets encore au gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
nous la responsabilité monsieur Ferney
qui vous avez raison de rappeler à la
fois l'importance du frais de
ferroviaire les résultats je n'y reviens
pas qui sont engrangés et c'est très
important on fait pas casser cette
dynamique et le travail qui a été fait
que vous avez notamment soutenu au
moment du PLF pour rajouter une part des
surcoûts de l'énergie à leur évalué qui
était de 26 millions d'euros je rappelle
que c'est un montant qui a été rendu
disponible pour 2022 qui est une aide
précieuse et qui est complétée par des
dispositifs de certificats d'économie
d'énergie qui renforce aussi le soutien
au secteur notamment pour faire face à
ces surcoobjectifs la réalité c'est que
nous ne savons pas exactement
aujourd'hui c'est vrai pour la SNCF
comme opérateur en général d'ailleurs et
c'est vrai pour le frais de ferroviaire
en particulier évaluer la précision des
surcos est-ce qu'il faut leur aller
au-delà pour aider le secteur de ce que
nous avons fait en projet de loi de
finance rectificatif pour 2022 c'est
possible il y a en effet nous l'avons
souhaité avec Christophe BECHU les
discussions en cours et j'ai reçu les
professionnels il y a quelques jours
entre les services du ministère des
Transports la DG ITM et les différentes
l'organisation professionnelle vous
feront un point au cours du premier
trimestre 2023 et je ne sais pas dire
aujourd'hui qui comment pardon et à
quelle hauteur il faudra soutenir le
secteur mais nous sommes attachés comme
vous à ne pas casser cette dynamique de
report modal très importantes nous
chiffons avec les professionnels des
coûts et vous conviendrez que 193
millions d'euros qui ont plus de vrais
notamment sur les questions d'énergie
c'est un somme importante pour une
évaluation qui est encore en cours je ne
suis pas vous dire à quel moment et si
nous aurons besoin de texte loi de
finance rectificatif en cours l'année
2023 je pense qu'on ne peut pas tout à
fait d'exclure et qu'en tout cas nous
adapterons nos dispositifs et que nous
aurons l'occasion de nous retrouver sur
cette question importante et partagée
donc je vous demanderai là aussi le
retrait au bénéfice de ces travaux en
cours et de l'évaluation à mener de cet
amendement faute de quoi nous en
demandions le rejet
vous maintenez l'amendement parce qu'il
y a une demande de retrait
il est retiré
donc trois amendements discussion
commune le 868
et la parole merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre le rapport c'est le
train d'équipe du territoire publie en
mai 2021 se prononce favorablement pour
l'investissement de 1 milliard 500
millions d'euros pour constituer ou
reconstituer un réseau de train de nuit
capable d'accueillir près de 5 millions
700 mille visiteurs voyageurs par an
donc 3 millions et demi pour les lignes
intérieures pour cela il faut une part
de 600 voitures de train de nuit pour
assurer le service or les territoire est
engagé que c'est la construction de 300
voitures de nuit pour 800 millions
d'euros l'âge du matériel dépasse les 40
ans et la construction prend 5 ans
environ et comme un don de financer la
commande sans rajouter encore
des investissements permettrait de
structurer en France une nouvelle fille
industrielle de construction de matériel
roulant le présentement qui partait
de créer un fond d'investissement visant
reconstituer le parc de matériel roulant
des trains de nuit dotée de 160 millions
d'euros pour sa première année toutes
les vidange si
si ensuite le suivant monsieur Gilles
madame Fillol
merci monsieur le Président tout à
l'heure monsieur le ministre vous avez
répondu d'une manière globale en
évoquant nombre de sujets dont les
trains de nuit et je trouve intéressant
que l'amendement de Monsieur Jacquin
vous permettent d'approfondir votre
réponse en effet Monsieur Jacquin
souhaite que 150 millions d'euros
supplémentaires soit investis pour
reconstituer un parc de matériel roulant
de nuit et pour déployer à l'horizon
2030 un vrai réseau de train de nuit en
France et en Europe en 1980 la France
bénéficiait d'un réseau complet avec pas
moins de 550 gares qui étaient
desservies par un train de nuit
alors de l'urgence climatique ce réseau
serait un atout formidable un pays comme
la France devrait pouvoir disposer de
ses alternatives à l'avion ou la voiture
au lieu d'accuser un lourdard par
rapport à ses partenaires européens
comme l’autriche qui a créé une
compagnie autrichienne de train de nuit
et ses lignes connaissent un franc
succès et permettent un maillage
territorial en Europe centrale et de
l'Est qui fait largement des fois à la
France
le 1125 monsieur Fernique oui c'est le
même amendement juste pour compléter
donc la constitution d'un réseau
consistance eurent à cette pénurie de
matériel roulant qui nous empêche
d'aller au-delà de des deux lignes
annoncées dans le cadre du plan de
relance il nous faudrait de l'ordre de
600 voitures et 60 locomotives ce qui
représenterait un milliard et demi ce
qui veut dire
150 millions d'euros d'investissement
chaque année pendant
10 ans voilà et c'est ce que propose ces
amendements merci monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
les ministres mes chers collègues c'est
trois amendements je vais faire une
réponse commune puisqu'ils sont proches
même si les modalités et les montants
varient légèrement de 150 millions de
quoi 160 millions mais ils vivent tous
effectivement à créer ou à donner des
moyens ou à renforcer des moyens pour
financer le matériel roulant des
nouvelles lignes de train de nuit donc
l'objet et l'intention de ces
amendements sont bien sûr légitimes et
appellent sans doute quelques
clarifications que monsieur le ministre
va apporter puisque des engagements
avaient été pris sur ce sujet par le
ministre de l'époque avec la création
effectivement d'un fonds de 800 millions
d'euros pour le matériel roulant sur les
nouvelles lignes de train de nuit qui
avait été annoncé par le gouvernement et
sur lesquels aujourd'hui ces questions
sont légitimes quant aux moyens et à la
capacité de répondre à cet enjeu donc
nous savons que plusieurs options
étaient encore dernièrement en
discussion à la fois sur de la
rénovation à la fois sur de
l'investissement nouveau et donc je
demande au ministre qu'il renouvelle
aujourd'hui cet engagement il nous
apporte effectivement plus de détails et
donc suivant mon collègue je vais me
ranger aussi sur cette question là la
vie du gouvernement parce que c'est un
sujet en fait sur le fond sur lequel on
partage sur lequel on a des attentes sur
lesquelles les territoires ont des
attentes sur lesquels il y a eu des
engagements et aujourd'hui la nécessité
de clarifier la position quand au
calendrier au moyen infecté merci
monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup il y a eu en effet corse
lorsque le gouvernement précédent est
notamment l'ancien Premier Jean Castex a
voulu redonner l'impulsion étrangui deux
séries d'engagements si j'essaye de
simplifier très rapidement
d'abord de rouvrir vite des lignes de
tramw pour montrer que le projet était
engagé sérieux c'est le cas des deux
lignes qui ont été ouvertes depuis la
fin de l'année 2021 et je crois que
c'était une nécessité pour engager la
dynamique et c'était aussi du
pragmatisme parce que c'était de ligne
sur lesquelles on pouvait engager de
nouveau du matériel roulant disponible à
brèves échéances l'autre engagement de
court terme dans cette série de premiers
engagements qui a été pris et tenue
c'est de mobiliser des crédits de
rénovation de matériel c'est 130
millions d'euros et c'est 130 millions
d'euros sont mobilisés qui ont été
affectés à cette première étape et puis
l'engagement qui avait été pris à
l'époque sous votre contrôle était
d'avoir plan de déploiement de ligne
supplémentaires jusqu'à 10 lignes au
total et de commander en effet le
matériel roulant nécessaire le
calendrier
assez clair il faudra que au cours
l'année 2023 et pour tout dire c'est
plutôt pour le deuxième semestre de
l'année 2023 on définit le calendrier de
déploiement de ces lignes le matériel
roulant nécessaire qui est indispensable
et qui est une commande industrielle
si on prend comme référence Dilling ça
correspond à peu près à 300
wagons de matériel roulants qui doivent
être commandés donc c'est une commande
industrielle importante plus réelle en
effet et c'est un rendez-vous qui sera
plutôt pour la fin de l'année 2023 pour
que l'on calibre ce calendrier de
mobilisation des crédits et de
financement de paiement effectif des
crédits de commande du matériel roulant
on a intérêt à mutualiser cette commande
une fois qu'on l'aura calibré puisque on
recrée aussi ce faisant une filière
industrielle un peu spécifique du train
de nuit donc tout ça pour dire que les
engagements qui ont été pris à court
terme ils sont tenus on peut le vérifier
les 130 millions d'euros et les deux
lignes ouvertes ça c'est fait et nous
avons cette discussion sur les lignes
d'ailleurs française et européennes avec
une commande qui a terminé un plutôt
dans la deuxième partie l'année 2023 et
selon la mécanique budgétaire les
autorisations d'engagement qui seront
alors demandés au Parlement sans doute
dans le PLF pour 2024 et les crédits de
paiement pour une première salve des
l'année 2024 très probablement aussi une
remarque madame la sénatrice sur les
exemples étrangers car rapidement après
mon ma prise de fonction dès le début de
mois de septembre j'ai eu un échange
avec mon homologue autrichienne et le
Président je peux dire le Jean-Pierre
farando autrichien qui dirige Ebb la
compagnie autrichienne qui avait un peu
relancé avec les night jet le train de
nuit c'est vrai qu'il y a un très bon
réseau faut être tout à fait transparent
ça ne disqualifie en rien à l'expérience
aucune ligne même si on dit que ça
marche bien à partir de l'Autriche ou en
Autriche aucune ligne n'est rentable il
y a toujours une subvention qui même
dans ce cas où il y a un bon taux
d'occupation et un bon taux
d'exploitation qui est nécessaire pour
que ce système fonctionne ça veut pas
dire qu'il faut pas le faire c'est pour
partager aussi avec vous le fait que il
n'y avait pas aujourd'hui de martingale
nulle part en Europe même dans les pays
les plus avancés qui ont relancé
rapidement le train de nuit pour trouver
un système qui d'un point de vue
commercial en tout cas fonctionne tout
seul donc c'est aussi à prendre en
compte dans les calibrages budgétaires
que nous ferons dans les années qui
viennent
bien merci donc je vais soumettre aux
voix les les amendements s'ils sont
maintenus monsieur Riquet il est
maintenu donc il est il est maintenu
alors donc je le soumets aux voix qui
est pour
qui contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le
1034 de Madame Fillol même votre
le 1125 de Monsieur Ferny même vote
donc qui ne sont pas adoptés je vous
signale juste au rythme actuel nous
allons avoir du mal à tenir dans la le
temps de la mission imparti je rappelle
que c'est 7h30 ça veut dire qu'il faut
examiner dans les quatre heures qui
restent sans aucun doute un monde
mais je veux brimer personne mais je
m'adresse d'ailleurs au ministre au
rapporteur ceux qui présentent les
amendements je ne fais que rappeler la
règle l'amendement 1074 monsieur laelec
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mais chers collègues il s'agit
d'un amendement de soutien au transport
combiné
le transport combiné ce sont des caisses
de camions que l'on met sur les trains
et vous ne permettrait de rappeler ici
que dans le cadre du débat sur la loi
qui m'a résilience
nous avions ici adopté un vote
permettant de donner un avantage
performantiel ou qu'est-ce que l'on met
sur les trains par conséquent il n'est
pas complètement anormal que nous
portions une attention particulière au
développement donc de ce transport
combiné nous avons besoin de le soutenir
des moyens existent pour cela et nous
trouvons que le signal d'adressé dans ce
projet de loi de finances n'est pas un
signal très encourageant pour développer
ce transport combiné
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
des ministres cet amendement vise à
augmenter de 130 millions d'euros l'aide
au transport combinés si nous partageons
la nécessité de promouvoir et de
développement et de développer ce
transport combiné pour assurer la
transition écologique comme la rappeler
notre collègue l'aide aux transports
combiné dite aident à la pince à d'ores
et déjà été réévaluée depuis 2021 de 27
à 47 millions d'euros le montant
unitaire par unité de transport
intermodal versé aux opérateurs
représente 31,50 euros soit une
augmentation d'environ 70% du coût moyen
du transbordement la stratégie nationale
pour le développement du frais de
ferroviaire prévoit de maintenir cette
aide renforcée au moins jusqu'en 2027 je
pense que monsieur le ministre prend
nous le confirmer et donc en conséquence
il est demandé un retrait faute de quoi
un avis défavorable sur le ministre
même position pour les arguments qui a
rappelé monsieur le rapporteur nous
avons augmenté significativement avec la
stratégie nationale de fret les montants
dévoués dédiés par d'autres transports
combinés le 27 à 47 millions d'euros les
aides je le confirme puisque vous me le
demandez sont prolongés jusqu'à 2027
c'est-à-dire cette enveloppe le 160
millions d'euros par an aujourd'hui qui
inclus c'est 47 millions d'euros pour le
transport combiné je crois que c'est un
effort important il sera prolongé dans
la durée merci
donc double avis défavorable on soumet
au vote qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
ensuite quatre amendements discussions
communes le premier le 10896 madame
barrayas
aux problèmes de la précarité
énergétique qui concerne pas moins de 12
millions de personnes dans notre pays
soient 20% des ménages français
depuis 2021 bien sûr on connaît un
emballement historique du prix de
l'énergie et le gel des prix du tarif
réglementé de vente du gaz électricité
ne sera malheureusement pas la hauteur
de beaucoup de ménages qui ne pourront
pas assumer cette nouvelle hausse de
15%. donc le chèque énergie
exceptionnelle comprit entre 100 et 200
euros à la à le mérite d'exister certes
mais il est loin d'être satisfaisant
pour répondre aux besoins de millions
d'usagers en précarité énergétique et
une compensera pas plus les hausses
continu du prix de l'énergie donc une
facture de chauffage il faut quand même
le savoir elle est en moyenne de 1600
euros pour un ménage normal elle est
dans le même temps à 1925 euros pour un
ménage en précarité
l'Observatoire national de la précarité
énergétique préconisée en 2018 une
revalorisation du chèque énergie à 710
euros afin que le taux d'effort
énergétique des familles ne dépasse pas
8%. le présentement demande porte le
montant donc du chèque énergie à 710
euros en moyenne et il prend en compte
l'augmentation des prix de l'énergie
bien évidemment 2023 merci le 1024
monsieur Montauger merci monsieur le
Président mais Monsieur le Ministre
chers collègues donc c'est abandonné
dans le même esprit et le montant un peu
moins d'eau un milliard 130000 130
millions
prévoit d'une part d'augmenter la valeur
faciale du chèque énergie de 20% pour
faire entre autres face effectivement à
l'augmentation de 15% des tarifs
réglementés en 2023 et d'autre part
d'élargir le seuil d'éligibilité
des attributaires afin d'en doubler le
nombre de bénéficiaires je rappelle que
le seuil est fixé à 10800 euros de
revenus que c'est vraiment un seuil très
bas parce qu'il laisse déjà en
difficulté ne pas pouvoir bénéficier de
ce dispositif d'aide
merci Monsieur Grémillet pour la
commission des affaires économiques oui
merci monsieur le Président ce ministre
n'aura pas peur cher collègue cet
amendement a pour but tout simplement de
conforter effectivement le chèque
énergie de 120 millions pour aider
pratiquement 4 millions 5 de famille qui
sont très exposées par rapport notamment
la situation
du chauffage fuel et bois qui est très
peu en prise en compte dans le cadre du
bouclier et c'est surtout suite aux
auditions que nous avons réalisées du
Médiateur de l'énergie qui nous a alerté
sur cette situation très précaire de 4,5
millions de familles dans nos
territoires
donc c'est de conforter de 30 euros le
chèque énergie pour ces familles
merci et puis le 1023 Monsieur montoget
Merci monsieur le Président amendement
identique donc de replis par rapport au
précédent que j'ai présenté il y a
quelques instants 120 millions d'euros
donc sans changement des critères
d'éligibilité voilà pour notamment faire
face au 15 % d'augmentation et
éventuellement au paiement de mode de
chauffage différent que de l'électricité
comme le bois par exemple dans le rural
c'est très souvent et peut-être trop
souvent le cas
merci Madame lavard pour la commission
alors surtout ces amendements ce sera
une demande de retrait alors
effectivement on entend tous la
préoccupation légitime que vous avez
développé qui est celle de soutenir les
plus fragiles face à la hausse de
l'énergie mais il faut peut-être quand
même rappeler l'argent qui a été mis sur
le chèque énergie ces deux dernières
années puisque en 2021 comme en 2022 600
millions d'euros puis ensuite 1,8
milliard d'euros ont été adoptés pour
verser notamment des chèques énergie
supplémentaires par ailleurs au cours
des deux PLF de l'année 2022 on a voté
des aides exceptionnelles à chaque fois
230 millions d'euros une première pour
les ménages chauffés au fioul et ensuite
une seconde pour les ménages chauffés au
bois il convient d'ajouter que ces
mesures elles viennent en complément des
mesures de bouclier tarifaires que nous
allons évoquer plus tard dans la journée
qui vont aussi venir limiter la hausse
de l'énergie pour l'ensemble des ménages
alors à ce stade étant donné qu'il
existe déjà dans le projet de PL le
chèque énergie socle celui qui est
destiné aux 5,8 millions de
bénéficiaires entre guillemets courants
qui convient peut-être d'attendre de
voir ce qui va se passer sur
l'efficacité des différents dispositifs
qui ont été mis en place face à la
flambée des prix avant de venir abonder
d'office l'enveloppe et on l'a vu au
cours des deux derniers exercices
budgétaires quand il y a eu besoin dans
les PLFR des crédits supplémentaires ont
été ouverts pour faire face aux besoins
réels nous me demande de retrait et je
pense qu'on aura l'occasion de réévoquer
ces sujets au cours de l'année
sur le ministre
même position pour toutes les raisons
qui viennent d'être indiquées 1,28
milliards effectivement un dispositif de
soutien avec un chèque énergie
exceptionnel qui va concerner 40% des
ménages et qui ne se qui est tout
énergie confondu et le fait qu'ensuite
on aura une année 2023 qui n'ont pas
douté permettra de prolonger une partie
des discussions mais en l'état venir
compléter des dispositifs qui sont déjà
à des niveaux qui sont particulièrement
élevés et qui quand on les compare
montre le l'attachement que nous avons
collectivement à lutter contre la
précarité énergétique ça nous semble
passe pas de nécessaire
bien merci donc demande de retrait ou
avis défavorable
[Musique]
chez
oui merci monsieur le Président j'ai
bien entendu la position de notre
rapporteur et du ministre
Michel ministre j'ai
oui il y a des accompagnements qui sont
faits l'alerte la commission des
affaires économiques du Sénas c'est de
dire il y a 4 millions 5 de famille
plutôt fioul et bois qui sont dans
l'accompagnement est plutôt plus faible
et sont dans une situation de précarité
c'est pas uniquement la commission qui
l'a fait en regardant mais en
travaillant sur la situation et
notamment avec tous les retours précieux
du médiateur moi je j'entends la réponse
de notre rapporteur qui dit
ok il y a un souci
peut-être pas fléchés tout de suite les
moyens supplémentaires
mais l'engagement de notre rapporteur
qui dit on reverra
et notamment ces catégories qui sont
exposées et qui ne sont pas accompagnés
qui sont dans une fragilité méritent une
attention particulière
je fais confiance à notre rapporteur je
vais retirer cette cette amendement mais
sur cet engagement qui est pris
c'est-à-dire effectivement on observe
mais on va pas attendre c'est pour ça
que je dis à Monsieur le Ministre
non il y a deux catégories qui
aujourd'hui sont en situation de
précarité je réinsiste et le nombre de
familles qui sont souvent avec des
revenus très faibles d'où cette
précarité fuel et bois donc je le retire
avec l'engagement qui a été pris par
notre rapporteur
les trois amendements qui restent donc
le premier le 1096 qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le
1024 qui est pour
le bottes et le 1023 même vote un qui ne
sont pas adoptés nous passons à
l'amendement 3 présenté par Monsieur
Artano les ménages résidents dans les
zones rurales subissent de plein fouet
la flambée des coûts d'énergie y compris
hors crises énergétique que ce soit pour
le chauffage ou les transports le pdfr
2022 a été abandonné de 230 millions
d'euros afin de faire face à
l'augmentation des factures énergétiques
des ménages j'utilisant du fioul ce qui
exclut de fait les ménages ayant recours
aux autres énergies hors tarifs
réglementées or les ménages résidents
dans les zones rurales en
majoritairement recours à ces énergies
ne sont pas protégées par les
différentes aides instaurées par le
gouvernement le présente à maman propose
de majorer 250 millions d'euros le
montant des crédits alloués au chèque
énergie afin d'accroître sa valeur
faciale en fonction de la grille
communale de densité établie par l'INSEE
un coefficient multiplicateur serait
appliqué selon les modalités fixées par
voie réglementaires au bénéficiaire de
chaque énergie résidant dans les
territoires durant 6 vers la bêta
dispersée et 7
merci avis de la commission
là aussi ce sera une demande de retrait
puisque là vous venez rajouter un
paramètre dans la détermination du
chèque énergie en ajoutant un critère de
localisation aux critères de revenus et
de composition familiale qui détermine
déjà le montant et après il y a les
mêmes raisons qui exposées précédemment
c'est à dire que pour ces sujets
particuliers que vous évoquez le fuel le
bois qui effectivement ne sont pas
couvert par des dispositifs de boucliers
tarifaires il y a des aides ponctuels
qui ont été apportées en 2022 donc qui
permettent de couvrir la chauffe de
l'hiver 22 23 donc finalement la
question elle se posera l'hiver prochain
si on est toujours dans les mêmes
conditions de tension géopolitique et
peut-être autre
sur le ministre
demande de retraite
tout le monde de retrait donc
l'amendement est maintenu je le soumets
aux voix qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le
suivant le 1026
qu'il présente
gilet Monsieur Personne ne le présente
monsieur Gillet le 1026
merci monsieur le président
cet amendement visa créer une aide
exceptionnelle en faveur des ménages
résidents dans un immeuble équipé d'un
chauffage collectif pour faire face à
l'augmentation du prix de l'énergie il
s'agit donc de permettre aux résidents
qui dispose de chauffage collectif de
bénéficier des mêmes aides prévues par
le chèque énergie il y a donc
l'assemblée des prix bien évidemment par
rapport à ça et le fait de mettre en
place un traitement équitable un grand
nombre de résidents notamment des
logements HLM ne peuvent bénéficier de
ce chèque dès lors qu'ils sont chauffés
vient un chauffage collectif il y a donc
là une situation préoccupante ainsi pour
permettre à tous les résidents qui se
éligibles à ce chèque dit prétendre de
pouvoir l'utiliser et les proposer
d'augmenter de 100 millions d'euros les
crédits du nouveau programme intitulé
aide exceptionnel en faveur des ménages
résidents dans un immeuble équipé d'un
chauffage collectif pour faire face à
l'augmentation du prix de l'énergie
merci Madame la rapporteur
alors cet amendement en fait il pose une
question intéressante qui est celle de
l'usage qui peut être fait du chèque
énergie par l'ensemble des bénéficiaires
aujourd'hui on constate et même s'il y a
eu une amélioration du taux
d'utilisation du chèque depuis son envoi
automatique alors qu'il y a encore
quelques années il fallait faire des
démarches pour l'obtenir ça progresse
doucement mais on a encore un taux
d'usage qui est autour de 85%. donc il
reste encore 15% de personnes qui ont ce
chèque mais qui ne peuvent pas
l'utiliser alors malheureusement on
manque de statistiques mais peut-être
qu'une des raisons vient justement pour
les populations que vous ciblez par cet
amendement à savoir celle qui n'ont
jamais de factures de d'énergie en face
de leurs dépenses puisque tout est tout
est couvert par les charges communes et
donc effectivement pour ces catégories
de personnes mais c'est-à-dire qu'elles
auraient même pas un contrat
d'électricité alors non enfin elles ne
peuvent pas utiliser le bénéfice de ce
chèque énergie donc c'est pas tant
d'abonder les crédits de la ligne
puisque chaque année on voit qu'on a une
sous-consommation des crédits du chèque
énergie plutôt de voir comment est-ce
qu'on peut solutionner ce cas
particulier et une ouverture avait été
faite je crois il y a un ou deux ans
quand on était venu étendre le bénéfice
du chèque énergie aux résidences
sociales
ce qui avait permis à ces personnes en
résidence sociale qui bien évidemment
n'ont pas de facture d'électricité
puisqu'elles sont dans une chambre où
elles payent un droit de séjour mais
elles ont pas une facture de pouvoir en
fait avoir aussi ce bénéfice pour venir
réduire leur coût de pension donc c'est
une demande de retrait même si le
problème est intéressant
monsieur le ministre
il y a effectivement deux sujets sur le
fond cet amendement est satisfait
puisque ceux qui sont dans des immeubles
qui sont chauffés de manière collective
ont le droit à la fois des tarifs qui
sont plafonnés de la même manière que
ceux qui sont les logements individuels
et à des montants de chèques qui
permettent de couvrir le sujet
effectivement du non recours ou de la
capacité à pouvoir affecter à des
charges de copro une partie de ce chèque
ça c'est un sujet sur lequel on pourra
avoir intérêt à travailler mais qui
n'est pas sur le montant budgétaire qui
est sur le fait d'avoir ensuite un juste
recours aux sommes qui sont en jeu mais
il est satisfait d'un point de vue
financier pour les familles concernées
donc demande de retrait
bien donc je maintiens vous maintenez
l'amendement monsieur gilet
on va le retirer mais sur le fond au
niveau des réponses moi je suis pas
satisfaire parce que en fait c'est
chaque ne sont pas mobilisés pour ces
problématiques de logement collectif ils
ne sont pas il peut y avoir une aide par
ailleurs mais sur ces intervention là
ils ne le sont pas donc il faudrait
trouver un dispositif qui permet de les
mettre en jeu de manière collective donc
il me semble pas que votre réponse
permet de satisfaire ces temps en temps
je le retire non
il est retiré donc ensuite nous passons
à deux amendements discussions communes
le premier est présenté par Madame
Fillol
amendement de Madame Rossignol vise à
créer une aide exceptionnelle pour les
ménages se chauffant avec des pellets de
bois sous la forme d'un chèque du même
type que celui adopté en loi de finance
rectificative cet été pour le fioul le
prix de vente des granulés de bois aux
particuliers en effet très fortement
augmenté passons de 300 euros la tonne à
environ 600 euros en moins d'un an
raison pour laquelle nous proposons de
créer une mesure exceptionnelle de
soutien à l'achat de pellets de bûches
de bois la dernière loi rectificative
d'ailleurs permis d'apporter une aide
aux ménage touché par cette augmentation
à hauteur de 230 millions d'euros en se
basant sur le cours actuel des pellets
de bois nous proposons une aide à
hauteur de 768 millions d'euros celle-ci
pourra diminuer en fonction de
l'évolution de l'inflation qui montre
aujourd'hui des signes de ralentissement
merci Madame baraillasse mon amendement
va ressemble en tout point à celui qui
vient d'être évoqué certaines ces aides
des aides avaient été apportées dans le
cas du projet de loi de finance
rectificative mais elles ne seront pas
suffisantes effectivement à l'envoler
des prix des granulés de bois qui
effectivement en octobre était de
l'ordre de 660 euros c'est un matériau
qui est très utilisé dans mon
département un couvert à 85 à 45% par la
forêt donc évidemment
nous vous proposons nous par contre nous
sommes un petit peu plus modestes
puisque nous nous proposons une
inscription de 400 millions d'euros afin
d'alléger la facture des ménages qui se
chauffe au poil ou à la chaudière à
granulés
merci Madame la rapporteur
on vient déjà de voter des crédits il y
a quelques jours pour
cet intrant et par ailleurs l'occasion
de ces débats il avait notamment été
fait mention de l'envoler très brutal
des pellets de bois et donc il me semble
d'ailleurs qu'un rapport a été voté une
demande du gouvernement pour venir
regarder ce qui s'est passé pourquoi
l'envoler est aussi brutale et s'il y
aurait pas eu des rétentions de stock ou
autre donc peut-être que les prix vont
aussi retomber à un niveau plus
raisonnable quand on va voir ça un peu
la police sur ce marché donc demande de
retrait
demande de retrait également je vous
rappelle que c'est 70% des ménages
puisque c'est sur les 7 premiers des
cils que l'actuel dispositif bois et
conçu
il n'y a pas de raison qu'on est des
prix pour l'hiver prochain qui soit
structurellement plus élevé que celui-ci
on n'est pas exactement sur les mêmes
mécanismes de formation des prix que sur
d'autres types d'énergie et on est quand
même curieux de comprendre pour qu'on a
eu un tel multiplicateur en si peu de
temps sur un matériau de ce type et donc
on pense pas qu'il faille aller mettre
des mesures qui donneraient le sentiment
que ça peut permettre de compenser des
hausses à court terme il y a le
dispositif précisé il y a quelques jours
à moyen terme ce rapport est l'évolution
des prix nous permettra d'y voir clair
donc demande de retrait
bien je soumets vous vous maintenez
l'amendement moi je ne retire pas parce
que aujourd'hui en France il y a 3
millions de de 3 millions de Français
de l'amendement de Monsieur gay de ma
collègue madame varayas donc je soumets
aux voiles amendement
1097 avec deux avis défavorables qui est
pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
ensuite l'amendement 8004 monsieur
Gillet ou eu le 8004
ce sera très rapide monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre c'est un
amendement d'appel qui revient sur une
revendication concernant la gratuité des
10 premiers mètres cubes d'eau il faut
considérer aujourd'hui la solidarité
nationale sur toutes les ressources le
bouclier tarifaire s'applique bien sûr
sur l'énergie aujourd'hui mais cette
question est toujours fondamentale et
elle génère souvent un grand nombre de
dossiers sociaux qui sont traités de
perte de temps et d'énergie en
l'occurrence et le fait d'instaurer la
gratuité sur les 10 premiers mètres
cubes permettrait en même temps une
gestion vertueuse de la consommation
c'est pourquoi nous revenons
régulièrement sur ce sujet un moment
d'appel donc il sera bien sûr retiré
madame la rapporteur
oui je suis étonnée huégard à la qualité
des cossignateurs de voir un dispositif
qui n'est pas ciblé parce que
accessoirement vous allez donner la
gratuité de l'eau à des gens je pense
qu'ils n'ont absolument aucune
difficulté pour se la payer et comme nos
finances publiques ne sont pas
impuissant fond pour cette seule raison
ce serait une demande de retrait
monsieur le ministre
j'ajoute en complément de ce qui a été
dit que depuis 2019 les collectivités
territoriales ont la possibilité de
déterminer leurs règles alors échelles
et qu'il faut faire confiance aux élus
locaux et à la capacité ensuite de
mettre en place des dispositifs de ce
type s'il le souhaite l'eau les sujets
que nous avons devant nous
ça va sans doute être des sur
investissements de réseau dans un pays
où c'est l'eau qui paye l'eau il faudra
qu'on détermine quelle accompagnement de
l'État mais je pense que ça n'est pas un
bon signal de le faire de manière
nationale ça n'est pas juste d'un point
de vue social et ça vient altérer le
principe de liberté des collectivités
territoriales donc demande de retraite
le soumet on voit
il est retiré il est retiré donc ensuite
le
323 si je ne me trompe il n'y a personne
enfin aucun des signatures n'est présent
pour le défendre donc il tombe le 893
monsieur Artano les 600 000 ménages
chauffés au GPL ne dispose pas tout
comme les ménages chauffés au fioul d'un
accès au réseau de gaz naturel une
déficit pas du bouclier tarifaire
applicable au gaz naturel par équité et
par cohérence avec les dispositions
votées
2022 pour les ménages qui se chauffent
au fioul et ce se chaufferont au bois et
le présente amendement propose de
répliquer le mécanisme d'aide pour les
ménages se chauffant au GPL me proposant
d'abonder de 46 millions d'euros les
crédits du programme 174
oui alors effectivement je comprends cet
amendement parce que comme on a eu une
multiplication de dispositifs dispositif
d'aide pardon à peu près pour chaque
catégorie qui utilise tel type de
combustible ceux qui n'utilisent pas à
un des combustibles et des se sentent
lésés mais il faut juste quand même
mettre une vérité des prix en face le
prix du propane a augmenté de 6 % quand
demain le prix du gaz et l'électricité
augmentera de 15% donc c'est pas un
problème de prix après l'argument aussi
qui est mis en avant c'est que on est
dans pas le propane on a désormais un
prix du propane qui approche le prix du
fioul et donc les ménages qu'il utilise
le sentiment qui alors qu'ils sont plus
vertueux d'un point de vue
environnemental parce que le propane est
moins émetteur de substances nocives que
pour l'environnement que le fioul il
devrait être aidé mais là aujourd'hui on
n'est pas dans des dispositifs
d'incitation écologiques on a dans des
dispositifs de pouvoir d'achat et il y a
pas un problème de pouvoir d'achat sur
le propane donc c'est une demande de
retrait
demande de retrait nous demande de
retrait vous le maintenez il est retiré
il est retiré donc ensuite deux
amendements en discussion commune le 146
je crois qui seul monsieur blanc est
présent parmi les signataires je crois
non
défendu défendu alors le ensuite le 11
03 madame barillas oui comme cela a été
rappelé dans le rapport sur la mission
économie le réseau consulaire et lui
aussi frappé par la hausse de ses coups
il y a eu la revalorisation pour eux
aussi du point d'indice qui est chiffré
à 17 millions d'euros mais aussi la
facture énergétique qui augmenterait de
15 millions d'euros en 2023 or depuis
des années loi après loi le réseau
consulaire s'essayait et CMA est
fragilisé par une privatisation rampante
via le recrutement de personnels de
droits privés mais aussi par l'extension
de ces missions avec des moyens toujours
plus contraints à titre d'illustration
le projet de loi de finances pour 2023
prévoyait de diminuer de 15 millions
d'euros les ressources discales pour le
réseau des Chambres de métiers
d'artisanat et inscrivez cette baisse
dans une trajectoire baissière de 60
millions d'ici à 2027 alors même que la
situation de crise que nous connaissons
depuis maintenant plusieurs ainsi que le
climat anxiogène qui touche nos
entrepreneurs et artisans nous invitent
au contraire à protéger les missions de
service public de proximité des CMA
c'est pourquoi dans la suite des
amendements qui ont été adoptés en
première partie nous souhaitons que le
réseau consulaire puisse bénéficier
explicitement de l'amortisseur
d'électricité prévue l'amortisseur
électricité pardon prévue dans ce projet
de loi
alors les chambres consulaires sont des
établissements publics donc pour moi
elles sont incluses dans le dispositif
d'amortisseur mais le gouvernement nous
le confirmera très certainement et en
fait je pense que vous avez déposé cet
amendement parce qu'il y a une véritable
dissymétrie d'informations entre nous
parlementaire et le gouvernement
du fait que les amendements sont déposés
de manière très tardive et que tout est
renvoyé par voie réglementaire donc je
pense qu'on aura un certain nombre de
questions tout à l'heure quand on va
discuter de l'article 42 TER et après
j'avoue que j'en suis en plus vous avez
réussi à chiffrer le besoin à 30
millions sur un dispositif que beaucoup
ont un peu de mal à anticiper donc je
sais même pas dire si le montant serait
suffisant ou pas suffisant pour répondre
à la demande que vous exposez donc
j'entends qu'en fait que vous aimeriez
déjà savoir c'est l'éligibilité des
chambres consulaires donc sur ça le
gouvernement va nous répondre monsieur
le ministre
alors
cet amendement a une base légitime liée
à certaines interprétations en termes de
droit européen sur la concurrence qui
pourrait conduire à ce que dans
certaines acceptions le réseau
consulaire ne soit pas considéré comme
étant éligible au droit européen ce qui
nous pose une difficulté parce que il
doit pas y avoir de trous dans la
raquette donc même si ce n'est pas
exactement mon champ j'assume le fait de
suggérer à la Haute Assemblée
une forme de sagesse qui pourrait
consister à voter le dispositif même
s'il y a un petit risque que ça
corresponde à un point sur lequel
ensuite nous aurons quelques bras de fer
européens à conduire mais l'idée telle
que ça vient d'être exprimé par la
rapporteur c'est que nous ne voulons pas
de trous dans la raquette et il y a pas
de raison qu'on assume un trou notamment
pour les CFA qui se retrouveraient à ce
moment-là avec des difficultés alors
qu'on prétend les défendre donc
je comprendrais que la Haute Assemblée
vote ses amendements
ou bien donc je l'ai soumets tous les
deux en même temps au vote puisque en
fait celui qui n'a pas été présenté
était identique c'est donc
qui est pour ces amendements
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
ils ne sont pas entendus ils ne sont ils
sont adoptés pardon
ils sont adoptés c'est la fatigue
excusez-moi
l'amendement 3503 monsieur grimier oui
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur chers
collègue cet amendement est droit de
ligne des travaux parlementaires à la
fois de l'assemblée du Sénat sur le
texte énergique climat puisque à
l'époque le gouvernement avait décidé de
mettre fin à l'exploitation des
productions énergétiques bases fossiles
et de la fermeture de la centrale
nucléaire de Fessenheim que nous
regrettons bien et il avait été décidé
dans le cadre de la commission mixte
d'accompagner la revitalisation de ces
territoires qui à l'époque ne demandait
rien pour les accompagner dans le
reconversion donc c'est amendement
permet effectivement de respecter les
engagements pris par les assemblées sur
l'accompagnement de ces territoires au
titre des fermetures des activités de
production
énergétique
fossile ou nucléaire de Fessenheim
une demande d'avis du gouvernement
la possibilité de savoir s'il y a besoin
effectivement de venir abonder au-delà
de la programmation plurianuelle qui à
hauteur de 47 millions d'euros de crédit
etant donné par ailleurs que deux de ces
centrales qui devaient fermer ont été
prolongées par un décret très récent je
pense à Saint-Avold et à corps de mai
donc a-t-il ce qu'on a vraiment besoin
d'argent là tout de suite en 2023 ou
après la question se pose mais je ne
sais pas y répondre
je suis le ministre
défavorable parce que nous avons
suffisamment de crédits les
autorisations d'engagement qui ont été
faites permettent jusqu'en 2025 d'aller
financer les mesures d'accompagnement et
donc à ce titre rajouter des crédits qui
viendraient dépasser les engagements
sociaux qui ont été pris par rapport aux
personnels nous ne sommes pas
souhaitables je veux dire que vous avez
une garantie dans la garantie c'est que
de toute façon ces fonds sont censés
être versés sur plusieurs années donc si
vous vous aperceviez qu'il y a des trous
il y aurait d'autres années où vous
pourriez éventuellement corriger le
dispositif mais là en l'état vraiment ça
n'est pas utile compte tenu des sommes
qui sont d'ores et déjà inscrites
j'espère avoir eu raison de faire
confiance parce que c'est pas les
amendements de Daniel grimier sénateur
mais bien de la commission des affaires
économiques
dans les travaux que nous avons rédigés
les auditions nous sommes alertés
notamment sur la fermeture des
Fessenheim qui est quand même une
réalité monsieur le ministre qui est pas
quelque chose encore une fois que nous
regrettons énormément et effectivement
sur ces territoires en particulier il y
a un besoin réel puisqu'on est passé
dans la face où l'activité a disparu
total totalement puisque les deux
réacteurs sont fermés et sur ces
territoires on nous dit que
effectivement ils sont pas accompagnés
que les engagements pris ne sont pas
respectés
madame la Présidente prima
je vais essayer d'être économe de ma
parole monsieur le Président simplement
moi je soutiendrai cette amendement tout
à l'heure on a fait confiance là on a
besoin d'être rassuré par rapport à des
engagements en particulier de la loi
énergique climat vous savez qu'on a eu
quelques déceptions sur la loi énergie
climat ou certains décrets faisaient
l'inverse de la qualité de notre CMP des
conclusions de la CMP donc là je ne
doute pas que vous vouliez accompagner
ces
collectivités dans lesquelles on ferme
des centrales maintenant je pense que le
signal que nous voulons envoyer là c'est
le signal que la loi doit être respectée
qu'elle le sera et qui aura bien des
engagements sur ces territoires de
revitalisation voilà c'est un signal que
le Sénat souhaite adresser à ces
territoires
j'entends le signal nous avons 40
millions d'euros de crédit ouvert vous
ajoutez des crédits à des crédits
ouverts alors même qu'on aura les moyens
de payer je serai tenté de dire au
sénateur grimier que tout à l'heure j'ai
bien compris qu'il avait pas fait
confiance au ministre mais elle a
rapporteur franchement sur cet
amendement vous pourriez faire confiance
aux rapports au ministre parce que vous
n'avez aucune raison j'ai aucune raison
de vous présenter un truc vu le montant
dont on parle qui consisterait juste à
ne pas vous faire voter si je pensais
que c'était pas inutile
bien l'amendement et maintenu donc nous
allons passer au vote sur cet amendement
qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté ensuite
l'amendement 863 alors il y a pas
beaucoup de Monsieur delegue non il est
défendu madame la rapporteur
mais pour
savoir si on vient d'évoquer à introduit
dans le code de l'énergie indispositif
de soutien sous la forme de contradict
expérimentation en faveur des projets de
production de biogaz à partir de
technologie innovantes un décret du
premier octobre 2021 à préciser les
modalités de la procédure des appels à
projets prévus dans le cadre de ce
mécanisme mais en fait maintenant on se
demande ce qu'il en est réellement et
notamment sur les perspectives de mise
en oeuvre d'installation bénéficiant de
ce mécanisme de soutien donc peut-être
le que le gouvernement peut nous
éclairer
sur le ministre
alors sur ce sujet
nous avons effectivement des contrats
d'expérimentation pour le biogaz qui
font partie de qui entraîne des
discussions pour élaborer le cahier des
charges avec la filière notre sujet à la
mine où on se parle n'est pas budgétaire
c'est pas le montant c'est le cahier des
charges pour lequel nous pensons que
nous serons capables de les écrire
l'année prochaine de manière à pouvoir
lancer l'appel à projet en 2023 c'est
seulement à ce moment-là qu'on aura une
idée des sommes qu'il faut être capable
de couvrir par rapport au niveau de ces
expérimentations donc en l'état c'est un
avis défavorable non pas sur le principe
mais sur la temporalité puisque les
cahiers des charges avec la filière
c'est pour les mecs qui arrivent
bien donc je vais soumettre l'amendement
voie qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
ensuite l'amendement 1028
madame allez-y oui monsieur le Président
le présente amendement visa augmenté les
crédits du programme 174 énergies climat
et après mines de la mission écologique
afin de permettre le versement des
indemnités garanties par les articles 22
et 23 du décret 46 100 1433 du 14 juin
1946 relatif au statut du personnel des
exploitations minières et assimilées et
due aux anciens mineurs et à leurs ayant
droit ayant souscrit un contrat de
capitalisation il s'agit de remédier à
une situation particulièrement
pénalisante pour les anciens mineurs qui
ont opté pour le rachat des indemnités
de logement et ou de chauffage dans le
cadre d'un contrat de capitalisation au
terme de l'amortissement du capital réel
perçu par ses anciens mineurs dans le
cadre du contrat de capitalisation le
versement des indemnités
prévu aux articles 22 et 23 du décret
précité aurait dû reprendre ce qui n'a
pas été le cas cet amendement vise donc
à permettre le versement des prestations
de logement et de chauffage du et le cas
échéant le rattrapage des montants non
perçus pour les anciens mineurs et leurs
ayant droit qui auraient dû en
bénéficier la dotation d'un peu plus de
12,5 millions d'euros correspond au
nombre total de bénéficiaires qui ont
atteint l'âge de capitalisation d'après
la haine GDM et à la date de novembre
2022 cette dotation supplémentaire
abondera le budget de l'Agence nationale
pour la garantie des droits des mineurs
qui assurera le versement de ses
prestations aux mineurs et à leurs ayant
droit bénéficiaires je vous remercie
merci Madame la rapporteur
[Musique]
alors sur ce ta maman qui nous fait
voyager dans le temps je n'ai absolument
aucune expertise donc c'est le
gouvernement qui va nous répondre mais
en forme de boutade j'y vois en fait une
justification à l'après mine dans
l'intitulé du programme parce que
malheureusement il fait plus beaucoup de
choses heureusement pour les mineurs vu
le nombre de que nous avons encore
monsieur le ministre
alors sujet effectivement très technique
qui n'est pas exactement au cœur du
ministère de la transition écologique et
donc puisque j'ai la chance l'honneur et
l'avantage de remplacer Agnès renachi
qui vous en parlerait certainement sans
papiers moi je vais pas me quitter mes
notes pour vous indiquer les éléments
vous évoquez effectivement les contrats
de capitalisation avec les versements
des indemnités qui sont un dispositif
spécifique prévu à deux articles 22 et
23 du décret qui aurait dû reprendre
sauf que des mineurs qui ont opté en
connaissance de cause pour la
capitalisation des indemnités on renoncé
pour l'avenir à la perception future de
ses avantages en nature sous quelque
forme que ce soit sur ce point précis la
ngdm
nous confirme l'absence de besoins de
ligne budgétaires spécifiques puisqu'il
s'agit d'un contentieux et donc ça n'est
pas en augmentant les crédits de l'ANGDM
qu'on préjugera de la décision de
justice qui pourrait être rendue suite
au contentieux intenté par certains
mineurs qui considèrent que la
capitalisation n'aurait pas dû avoir
comme effet de les priver de ses
avantages en nature donc en l'espèce je
comprends le sujet c'est au moins
d'amendement d'appel qui permet de
braquer les projecteurs mais ce que nous
attendons désormais ce sont les
décisions de justice et la ngdm nous dit
qu'elle a fait des provisions dans le
cadre de ces décisions de justice si le
contentieux ne lui était pas favorable
mais notre problème n'est pas budgétaire
il est à ce stade juridique
bien merci Madame vanègue
oui je voudrais répondre à madame le
rapporteur il n'y a plus de mines mais
il y a encore des anciens mineurs et ça
ne serait que justice parce qu'il s'agit
d'un engagement qui n'a pas été tenu
bien donc nous allons maintenant donc
nous allons soumettre aux voiles
amendement qui est pour cet amendement
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement suivant n'a pas de
signataire présent donc il n'est pas
défendu
le 352 monsieur Grémillet oui merci
monsieur le Président ce ministre un
remporteur chers collègues je veux juste
préciser monsieur le ministre c'est pas
un problème de confiance c'est que pour
2023 il y a aucun crédit qui ne sont
autorisés en paiement et le alors que
nous avons des projets donc le sujet il
est réel par rapport et je remercie mes
collègues d'avoir fait confiance à la
commission des affaires économiques sur
l'amendement là est dans la droite ligne
de ce qui est en train de se passer sur
les accompagnements sur notamment le
bouclier
sur l'accompagnement de en matière
énergétique et de donner les moyens à la
creux là aussi de pouvoir mettre en
oeuvre donc c'est un accompagnement
auteur de 800.000 euros sur à la fois
cette mise en œuvre du bouclier
d'accompagnement
à la fois des collectivités à la fois
des particuliers qui est un vaste projet
qui nécessite des moyens supplémentaires
madame la rapporteur
alors ce sera une demande de retrait ou
un avis défavorable l'année dernière la
CO a bénéficie d'une augmentation
substantielle de ces moyens s'useppe
pour venir instruire la révision des
contrats photovoltaïques je me suis
objectivement posé la question et je
l'ai posé à la présidente de la Crau
pour savoir ce qu'avait fait ces agents
l'année dernière vu que le problème n'a
absolument pas évolué et je crois bien
que à part créer un contentieux
important des sujets de notification
auprès de la Commission européenne c'est
tout ce qu'on a récolté donc ça sera pas
faute d'ailleurs au Sénat d'avoir alerté
sur le risque juridique de vouloir
revenir réviser à posteriori des
contrats signés par l'État je ferme
cette parenthèse mais tout ça pour dire
qu'il y a eu 6 ETP l'année dernière et
que par ailleurs les dispositifs pour
lequel vous demandiez des ETP ont été
considérablement simplifiées par
l'amendement alors je suis d'accord vous
avez peut-être pas eu le temps de
l'étudier parce qu'il a été déposé je le
rappelle le 30 novembre à 20h sur le
dispositif de le article 42 TER et que
désormais en fait la comp ne sera plus
exposée sur la part exposée au marché
déduction faite enfin on aura le prix
vendu il y aura plus besoin de venir
faire des soustractions avec la part à
Rennes ou pas dans les différents
contrats fournitures donc rien que ça
déjà rend la le contrôle à opérer par la
Creuse sur le comportement des
fournisseurs d'énergie beaucoup plus
simple donc il me semble que la creux a
des moyens suffisants pour accomplir ses
missions monsieur le ministre
alors ma position est intermédiaire
entre la rapporteur et l'auteur de
l'amendement en fait la creux ne demande
pas 800000 mais demande 400 000 euros
je le précise et le gouvernement va
déposer un amendement autorisant la
création de 5 et TP avec cette hauteur
dans le cadre des crédits non rattachés
pour tenir compte d'une partie des
remarques que vous faites donc je peux
pas totalement abonder dans le sens de
leur rapporteur qui explique qu'on n'a
pas besoin de qu'il n'y aurait pas
besoin complémentaire à la creux mais je
vous demande de retirer cette amendement
parce que vous en demandez deux fois
plus que ce que la creux elle-même
suggère et calibre
monsieur Grémy oui monsieur le Président
merci merci monsieur le ministre
mais je peux pas m'entendre dire qu'on
demande le double de ce que demande la
creux
et je remercie de notre rapporteur parce
qu'effectivement la commission
économique a examiné
ces positions ses amendements la vie de
la commission avant même que nous
n'ayons connaissance de l'amendement du
Gouvernement des conditions dans
lesquelles c'est et je remercie
effectivement donc c'est une avancée
quand nous avons auditionné la creux ce
ministre
le besoin était celui que je suis en
train d'évoquer alors depuis vous avez
évolué sur les conditions de mise en
oeuvre qui nécessitent et ce qui a
expliqué notre rapporteur donc moi ce
que je vous propose tout simplement
c'est de faire un sous amendement
rectifié cet amendement à la hauteur de
ce que vous considérez comme nécessaire
au niveau de la
donc l'amendement est rectifié pour un
montant de 400.000 euros
madame Goulet
non non c'est bon
donc je soumets aux voix en amendement
rectifié à la demande de Monsieur
grémière ou à la moitié du montant
actuellement indiqué
avis de Madame la rapporteur
bien évidemment c'est que mon avis pas
la vie de la commission puisqu'elle
s'est pas réunie ça vous a pas échappé
mais juste une petite question pour le
ministre si vous déposez un
amendement dans les non rattachés ça
veut dire que c'est une ouverture de une
autorisation d'où augmenter le plafond
d'emploi mais ce n'est pas assorti de
crédit supplémentaire pour les financer
donc ça veut dire que c'est nouveaux
emplois sont financés sur le budget de
la creux tel qu'il est voté ce soir dans
la maquette actuelle alors que
l'amendement de Monsieur Grémy enfin si
on vote là sous amendement de Monsieur
grimillier il fait coïncider des emplois
et des crédits pour les financer
du coup savoir s'il considère que sur le
budget de la Croix on a de quoi financer
c'est que TP supplémentaires
monsieur le ministre
je suggère effectivement le retrait pour
que ce soit bien via cette amendement
puisque les les ouvertures de crédit sur
5 postes complémentaires permettront
d'être couvert par les crédits de la
croix
je vais le retirer je vais le retirer
mais Monsieur le Ministre ça veut dire
que vous ne faites ni plus ni moins que
ce qu'a dit notre rapporteur on demande
à la creux de gérer sur ces fonds
propres aujourd'hui et sur la sa masse
budgétaire sur cette nouvelle mission
c'est pas 5 possibilités
bien il est retiré mais je vous ai
redonné la parole puisqu'il était
rectifié donc on pouvait considérer que
c'était un autre amendement le 865 donc
amendement suivant le 865
[Musique]
monsieur
il y avait monsieur Grémillet parmi les
signataires je vois pas d'autres ah non
pardon excusez-moi
donc le présentement la présidente et
d'ailleurs consigné par par tous les
ventes cette hémicycle vise à financer
la mesure consistante à intégrer les
exploitations agricoles à vocation
pédagogique géré par des établissements
publics ou privés sous contrat de
formation agricole au régime de soutien
spécifique à l'agrovoltaïsme instauré
par l'article 11 des sièges du projet de
loi de rectificatif à l'accélération de
la production des énergies renouvelables
actuellement en cours de discussion au
Parlement ils prévoit ainsi un soutien
de 100000 euros pour 2023 ce menton est
évidemment symbolique puisque les
énergies renouvelables génère
actuellement des recettes plutôt que des
dépenses ces établissements exercent en
effet des missions essentielles de
formation en réalité de l'exercice du
métier d'agriculteur et de ses
évolutions la mise en place
d'installations Agri voltaïque sur leur
exploitation agricole peut pleinement
participer à ces missions
alors effectivement il y a beaucoup de
cossignataires puisque la PPL que vous
évoquez a été votée à l'unanimité du
Sénat et donc en fait ce que vous
demandez alors je crois comprendre que
c'est un amendement d'appel c'est
d'essayer de permettre aux exploitations
agricoles à vocation pédagogiques de
bénéficier des dispositifs mais il va
falloir que le ministre nous répondent
sur l'intention du gouvernement
d'inclure ces mécanismes à travers les
dispositions du projet de loi enr
sur le ministre
alors sur la grivevoltéisme une
définition est en effet en cours
d'élaboration dans le cadre du projet de
loi d'accélération sur les énergies
renouvelables nous soutenons évidemment
les dispositifs dans la continuité de ce
qui a pu se dire dans le cadre de cette
loi néanmoins nous avons d'ores et déjà
des appels pour le soleil pour les
installations sur les terrains agricoles
qui existent avec des montants qui sont
prévus pour l'année 2023 et les
éventuels projets qui seraient lauréats
vous avez de toute façon un délai de 12
mois qui fait que indépendamment de la
somme modique que vous demandez et de
l'intérêt en termes de d'appel ne
nécessite pas ses crédits nous
partageons l'objectif mais nous n'avons
pas besoin de crédit spécifique pour
l'année 2023 en revanche vous serez
pleinement satisfait compte tenu jusqu'à
déjà été voté par la Chambre haute à
partir de l'année qui arrive
je suis Artano retirer
bien nous continuons avec deux
amendements discussions communes le
premier monsieur Dominati Michel
ministre au mois de septembre le chef de
l'État dans une allocution solennelle a
expliqué aux Français que l'on devait
faire des économies d'énergie on devait
éteindre la Tour Eiffel
baisser la climatisation fermer les
portes des magasins bref
la pénurie en partie quelques instants
après il y avait la publicité sur la
même chaîne et l'État offrait 7000 euros
si on a acheté une voiture en
l'occurrence japonaise et on ne comprend
pas je suis comme beaucoup de Français
je n'arrive pas à comprendre comment il
gagne telle distorsion dans l'action de
l'État en aidant et en dopant une
filière particulière
7000 euros c'est plus que le revenu
moyen de l'impôt sur le revenu des
français puisque 40% des foyers payent
seulement l'impôt sur le revenu
la moyenne est de l'ordre de 6500 alors
ma question est simple pourquoi
gaspiller autant d'argent je comprends
bien qu'il faille peut-être réduire le
train je voudrais savoir si en achetant
une calèche tirée par un âne ou un
cheval j'aurais droit à 7000 euros pour
me déplacer peut-être que vous me direz
que c'est pas un véhicule propre mais
normalement mettez fin à cette gabgie
c'est 900 millions d'euros je dirais
dans le budget mais sur le plan
technique je crois que la commission des
finances dans quelques instants va
développer ses arguments
donc un autre amendement en discussion
commune déposée par la commission
défendue par Madame Lavarde oui
effectivement
le président donc pourquoi est-ce que
nous avons voulu déposer cet amendement
parce qu'aujourd'hui nous observons
comme la justement dit Monsieur Dominati
une sorte de distorsion l'argent des
Français vient financer l'industrie
automobile chinoise alors c'est un
industrie automobile elle est en pointe
elle représente une part très
significative de la chaîne de valeur du
véhicule électrique 50% et 75% de la
chaîne de valeur des batteries donc
autant dire que sur ce secteur nous
avons abandonné notre souveraineté ce ne
sera peut-être pas sans poser de
questions dans quelques années en
fonction des évolutions géopolitiques
d'autres pays ne se font pas autant de
nœuds au cerveau et sont beaucoup plus
radicaux je pense ici à nos voisins
américains que le Président de la
République est en train de visiter et
d'ailleurs il me semble qu'il a eu des
discussions sur cette réduction
inflation actes pour dire que ça allait
peut-être poser des problèmes pour les
investissements directs étrangers
notamment des entreprises américaines
sur le sol français mais alors pourquoi
que nous nous continuons à fermer les
yeux et à faire ceci ceux d'autant plus
c'est que j'avais déjà eu l'occasion de
le dire les années antérieures et c'est
ce que rappelait monsieur Dominati
aujourd'hui les dispositifs de soutien
que ce soit le bonus et la prime à la
conversion quand bien même ils sont
cumulés à leur montant maximum ce qui
doit être autour de 12000 euros c'est
pour un ménage avec un revenu fiscal de
référence par part autour de 13000 euros
donc dites moi si vous trouvez sur le
marché un véhicule électrique 25000
euros ça veut dire quand même la
mobilisation d'une année entière de
revenus fiscal de référence en
complément des aides publiques pour
venir acheter son véhicule 25000 euros
il y en a pas beaucoup et s'il y en a
c'est des voitures boîtes de conserve
donc déjà si vous avez une famille vous
oubliez la mobilité électrique
aujourd'hui par ailleurs ces voitures de
petite taille elles sont quasiment
exclusivement fabriquées par des
constructeurs étrangers parce que notre
industrie automobile qui a souvent été
une industrie plutôt de haute gamme à
investi sur les véhicules électriques à
forte valeur ajoutée et entrain
aujourd'hui de transformer ces chaînes
de production
transformer une chaîne de production
automobile ça se fait pas en claquement
de doigts il faut en gros 18 mois notre
industrie automobile et je les ai
auditionnés nous indiquait être prête
fin 2023 début 2024 donc l'objet c'est
amendement n'est pas tant d'effacer les
crédits pour soutenir la transition du
parc mais c'est plutôt de les décaler
dans le temps pour que ils viennent en
soutien de notre filière automobile
quand elle sera prête
[Applaudissements]
d'abord je dirais que finalement la
rapporteur a répondu à philippe Dominati
puisque lui propose de supprimer le
bonus écologique quand la rapporteur
propose au contraire de l'encadrer et de
faire en sorte de le diminuer pour
dénoncer la part trop importante des
importations étrangères donc je ne
dirais pas à philippe Dominati autre
chose en cru que ce que la rapporteur
lui a dit et il comprendra la vie
défavorable que je ne peux que mettre
malgré la section que je lui porte
madame la rapporteur on a eu tout à
l'heure
à cette tribune des gens qui se sont
succédés en disant il y a une urgence
climatique le pays n'est pas au
rendez-vous de ce qui doit être capable
de faire on peut avoir des débats
infinis sur un certain nombre de choses
mais sans doute pas au moins sur deux
points le premier sur le fait que se
réchauffement est une réalité et le
second c'est que les moteurs thermiques
les énergies fossiles sont la partie
contribue le plus c'est notamment vrai
en France compte tenu des 30% des
missions qui sont liées au transport et
à l'intérieur de ce transport le
ferroviaire dont nous avons beaucoup
parlé ne représente que 0,3% de nos
émissions d'où l'intérêt qu'il y a à
massifier les efforts tels que ça peut
être dit plus tôt et la part qui est
liée aux voitures individuelles et
majoritaire dans ses émissions
nous avons pris la décision
de reporter le leasing pour nous coller
au calendrier que vous indiquez pour
précisément faire en sorte que ce
dispositif de soutien massif en termes
de montant aille avec les
relocalisations industrielles un mot
quand même pour vous dire que pour
l'année en cours qui n'est pas terminé
le véhicule qui a le plus bénéficié du
bonus c'est la Zoé qui sera quand on
fera les comptes de la totalité de
l'année celui qui aura été le plus
choisi pas par le gouvernement par les
gens mais que nous avons c'est le
véhicule le plus bonus et sur l'année
et ce que je peux vous indiquer dans la
continuité de ça c'est que vous avez
précisément cité le inflation réduction
actes et les propos du président de la
République il y a quelques heures à
Washington à plante ses vœux une forme
de bail européen acte ou en tout cas de
fin de l'année de notre Union européenne
sur ces sujets pour faire en sorte qu'on
puisse réserver ses crédits je me
permets de vous indiquer que ça c'est
pas une décision qui date d'il y a trois
semaines six mois ou 5 ans que c'est la
continuité d'engagement européen qui ont
été pris par des gouvernements et des
présidents de la République successifs
de considérer que en matière de commerce
internationale nous avions parfois
tendance à accepter des produits sans
nécessairement appliquer des
réciprocités je suis pleinement
convaincu que nous avons à fléchés les
crédits de l'argent des Français vers
des véhicules qui sont produits en
Europe simplement accepter votre
amendement ce serait considéré qu'on
peut faire une pause dans
l'électrification du parc et ma
conviction la plus profonde c'est qu'il
est souhaitable d'aller vers ce que vous
décrivez mais que comme vous le dites
très justement en baissant les crédits
tel que vous le présentez on diminuerait
le rythme de renouvellement du parc
septembre c'est 22% d'immatriculation de
véhicules électriques nous avons besoin
de continuer à soutenir cet effort parce
qu'il est le plus efficace d'un point de
vue climatique tout en ouvrant les yeux
sur la nécessité de recentrer les
crédits monsieur gilet
c'est Monsieur président monsieur le
ministre très rapidement le sujet est un
sujet de fond
mais il met en perspective un vrai
paradoxe le paradoxe c'est de dire les
constructeurs français ont dérivé leur
gamme vers des véhicules de plus en plus
luxueux de plus en plus lourds qui
coûtent de plus en plus cher et sur
lesquels ils font de plus en plus de
plus-values voilà la situation des
constructeurs français pourquoi ils
l'ont fait parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
tenir la concurrence vis-à-vis des pays
étrangers sur des véhicules d'entrée de
gamme et voire même de moyenne gamme
donc ça c'est le fond du sujet donc il
faudrait presque aider aujourd'hui des
constructeurs français pour qu'ils
puissent produire ces véhicules parce
que votre position aujourd'hui
consisterait à empêcher déménage
modestes de pouvoir acquérir des
véhicules électriques et de concentrer
les aides sur des véhicules plus luxueux
qui entraînent plus de plus-value au
niveau des constructeurs français donc
ça pose une véritable problème
d'accessibilité sociale par rapport à un
problème économique de marché qui est
posé aujourd'hui et une dérive je pèse
mes mots des constructeurs français vers
des véhicules qui dégagent de plus en
plus de plus voilà le fond du sujet donc
on ne peut pas vous suivre à l'heure
actuelle sur ces amendements
madame l'avarne
oui alors monsieur le ministre a raison
quand il parle de la zone mais quand on
regarde l'ensemble des véhicules
aujourd'hui alors sauf si la tendance
est inversée sur les derniers mois de
l'année mais au cours des 9 premiers
mois de l'année 2022 les bonus
écologiques alloués pour l'achat de
véhicule produit en France ne
représentait que moins d'un cinquième du
total donc la Zoé est peut-être
l'exception qui fait mais le reste c'est
les chiffres parlent d'eux-mêmes moins
d'un cinquième du total ensuite quand je
vous entends j'ai l'impression que c'est
comme le nuage de Tchernobyl à savoir
que la pollution de l'air elle s'arrête
à nos frontières quand on pollue en
Chine pour fabriquer des véhicules avec
des unités de production au charbon ça
pose pas de problème aujourd'hui les
véhicules électriques qui sont utilisés
par des Français pour se déplacer ou
ainsi un bilan carbone sur l'ensemble de
leur cycle de vie qui est plus mauvais
qu'un véhicule thermique donc est-ce que
ça c'est faire de la transition non
donc je vous le dis nous je suis enfin
je pense que aux personnes d'ici pour
Annie et que je suis pas du tout enfin
très favorable à toutes les mesures de
transition mais il faut utiliser
l'argent public à bonallois ce qu'on
vous dit juste c'est attendez quelques
mois que notre industrie elle sera elle
soit prête et je vous ai entendu j'ai
entendu le ministrehal à cette tribune
au terme de la discussion générale dire
que cette mesure elle était soutenue par
le gouvernement il semble que vous ayez
tenu des propos analogues au Conseil
national de la transition
énergétique pas plus tard que mercredi
de cette semaine donc pourquoi est-ce
que vous mettez pas vos paroles en
conformité avec des actes c'est ce que
fait cet amendement
monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
je maintiens chacun des propos que j'ai
tenus notamment devant le rapporteur
Jean-François Husson pour dire qu'il
nous devions fléchés ces crédit vers des
productions européennes la Zoé je
l'utilise pour répondre que nous avons
qu'il n'y a pas de fatalité à ce que des
modèles d'entrée de gamme ne puisse pas
être produit en France c'était la raison
pour laquelle j'évoquais cela et nos
chiffres sont ensemble vrais deux défis
modèles les plus bonus et sont fabriqués
en Europe pas en France mais en Europe
en revanche la part d'évasion hors
Europe elle est beaucoup trop élevée et
j'ai effectivement dit que si c'était
pour avoir des véhicules qui étaient
produits avec du charbon ça posait une
difficulté mais en amont quand vous
réfléchissez sur le cycle de vie un des
éléments déterminants va pas entrer dans
le débat c'est le poids du véhicule et
c'est le niveau de matière ensuite c'est
la durée d'utilisation de ces véhicules
et donc dans les dispositifs à améliorer
il y a aussi le temps minimum avant
revente quand on a une part de soutien
public si je vais plus loin dans les
différents domaines sur lesquels nous
pourrions réfléchir mon message c'est
quoi vous ne dites pas il faut plus
aider les véhicules qui sont pas
fabriquer en Europe vous dites on va
diminuer les crédits parce que une part
correspond à de l'évasion les pays qui
se sont essayés à minorer une part des
dispositifs de soutien ça s'est traduit
par un effondrement des véhicules
électriques on sait bien qu'on n'aura
pas le renouvellement du parc complet en
2023 mais il faut que la tendance
d'augmentation de la part
d'immatriculation des véhicules
électriques se poursuivent parce que
c'est une nécessité pour être cohérent
avec nos objectifs climatiques à terme
et je le dis les yeux ouverts et en
reprenant les propos que j'ai tenus tout
à l'heure nous devons dans notre pays
faire en sorte de continuer à accélérer
indépendamment de ce qui se joue à une
échelle internationale avec d'autres
pays qu'il faut ou qu'on aide à
accélérer ou qu'on contraigne avec des
dispositifs de ce type merci Monsieur
Kuypers
oui monsieur le ministre je vais vous
demander quelques secondes de lucidité
est-ce que nous avons les l'énergie
nécessaire aujourd'hui pour faire
fonctionner ces voitures électriques ces
véhicules électriques
dans les médias dans tous les médias
on nous dit attention on va avoir des
ruptures d'alimentation électrique il
faut fermer vos lumières il faut etc etc
comme la dimension Dominati
je crois que vous nous conduisez dans le
mur
en mettant le tout électrique
aujourd'hui
nous savons très bien et lisez ce que ce
qu'on produit monsieur
PDG de PSA la semaine dernière
nous allons dans le mur nous le savons
tout le monde le dit et vous continuez
vous persistez au fait que nous
puissions aujourd'hui avoir que des
voitures électriques en 2030 ou en 2035
ce n'est pas le moment je crois qu'il y
a autre chose à faire il y a autre chose
à développer au terme d'énergie
renouvelable notamment mais le tout
électrique pour moi c'est une erreur
monumentale et historique
oui monsieur le monsieur le ministre
pour rebondir à la fois sur votre propos
et sur l'intervention de notre
rapporteur on a me semble-t-il un
problème de
coïncidence entre les annonces et
finalement une absence de coordination
de notre de nos stratégies
les gouvernements successifs et celui
auquel vous appartenez n'a pas échappé
finalement à des effets d'annonce quand
l'outil industriel n'est pas
complètement adaptée vous prenez
l'exemple de la Zoé sauf faire de ma
part elle est promise à la fin de
production en 2024 je suis dans un
département par exemple où sur les
véhicules utilitaires à bâti et fabriqué
pour l'Europe le Renault Master
électrique qui a du mal à trouver sa
place parce qu'il y a plusieurs sujets
il y a le coup ça a été évoqué mais
puisque vous
évoqué la lutte ou l'avantage par
rapport au climat je rappelle aussi que
ces véhicules sont effectivement plus
lourds et que se posent
concomitamment la problème du
réchauffement climatique le problème de
la pollution
et avec les véhicules électriques la
pollution de l'air n'obtient pas que des
bons des bons résultats c'est moins
d'émissions de gaz échappement mais
c'est plus d'émissions sur notamment les
plaquettes de frein et l'abrasion
puisque c'est plus lourd donc il faut je
pense qu'il faut être très attentif à
ces sujets en ayant en coordonnant les
travaux et en essayant de concilier avec
une progressivité
la perspective économique est l'enjeu
écologique et climatique mais à vouloir
courir trois lièvres à la fois
malheureusement vous finalement vous
trébuchez sur des annonces non suivies
des faits en tous les cas avec beaucoup
moins d'effets et des réalisations que
ceux que vous annoncez publiquement
monsieur grémillais je vous ai vu
monsieur le ministre monsieur grimier
oui merci monsieur le président
c'est le Ministre cher rapporteur chers
collègues moi je me réjouis du débat
actuel parce que on est vraiment dans le
cœur
de ce que doit faire le Parlement
de trouver une cohérence globale
et effectivement on aura tout à l'heure
des débats sur l'énergie
et aujourd'hui je vous rappelle monsieur
le ministre que c'est au Sénat la
première assemblée qui a parlé de bilan
carbone au départ c'était sur leur
doublable en disant faut peut-être avant
de dire il faut du renouvelable et si
c'est pour importer du renouvelable qui
vient d'Asie quand on fait le bilan
carbone c'est pas terrible
et je voudrais prolonger le propos de
notre rapporteur sur cette son
amendement
c'est le ministre
il y a le bilan carbone du produit qui
est la voiture
et effectivement nous importons
indirectement nous faisons ailleurs
l'émission de gaz à effet de serre on se
donnant en bonne conscience mais lorsque
le véhicule est rentré
et je reprends le propos de notre
collègue Pierre Cuers
on sait tous qu'on est une somme en
fragilité électrique encore un minima
sur deux ans
vous le savez monsieur le ministre le
bouclage de la France
est essentiellement c'est l'Allemagne
qui nous dépanne en électricité et nous
les dépanons en gaz
mais chaque fois que j'ai un porte pour
faire tourner ces véhicules électriques
de l'électricité le bilan carbone c'est
pas du nucléaire c'est pas du propre
c'est essentiellement à partir de
charbon et de gaz donc on l'amplifie
donc il y a un vrai sujet c'est pour ça
que je dis je me réjouis parce que on
plante on prend vraiment son sujet dans
son ensemble et ça milite pour
effectivement
accompagner les industriels français et
européen pour être à conquête de ce
marché on n'est pas contre et ça milite
aussi pour avoir une production
énergétique bien plus propre et des
carbonées comme nous l'avons toujours eu
en France et nous en voter pionniers
là-dessus par rapport à d'autres pays
Union européenne
merci Monsieur le Ministre ensuite on
passera au vote je pense monsieur ferick
excusez-moi monsieur le ministre je fais
Annick j'avais pas vu
juste quelques mots
nos constructeurs automobiles ont déjà
perdu dans la décennie qu'on allait à
nous 100000 emplois la question c'est
est-ce qu'on veut encore en perdre
100000 autres et de ce point de vue là
il est clair
l'attachement un peu nostalgique à la
voiture thermique c'est des emplois
qu'on détruit il est important que nous
soyons compétitifs que nous soyons
performants sur la voiture électrique
alors bien sûr si tous ceux qui
circulent aujourd'hui en voiture
thermique bascule sur des voitures
électriques il y a toute une série de
problèmes qu'on aura encore d'où
l'intérêt de tout ce que nous disions il
y a quelques heures sur le transfert
modal sur le ferroviaire sur les
transports publics du quotidien mais je
pense vraiment que ce serait une erreur
pour pour quelques mois nous dit-on de
façon à ce que notre outil industriel
soit prêt de décaler une marge vers
l'électrification qui est nécessaire
monsieur le ministre
ça mériterait des débats tellement longs
que je vais moi-même faire mon deuil
d'un certain nombre d'éléments mais il y
a des choses que je peux blesser dire un
le rapporteur Russian a raison il y a
d'autres formes de pollution mais ça
c'est l'enjeu de la norme Euro 7 et donc
j'entends avec satisfaction que le Sénat
va réclamer qu'on aille amplifier les
mesures nouvelles que la Commission est
en train d'examiner pour limiter
l'abrasion liée aux plaquettes de frein
c'est un sujet dont la commission saisie
qui vaut pour tous les types de
véhicules le vrai sujet c'est la
question du poids là aussi s'il y a de
la cohérence sur tous ces bancs
modifions les barèmes
d'indemnités fiscales pour faire en
sorte d'arrêter de rembourser plus cher
les kilomètres des grosses berlines que
des petits véhicules puisque le même
principe s'applique plus un véhicule est
important plus la brasure qu'il génère
est élevé et donc plus ça contribution à
la pollution est élevée et là on pourra
s'entendre et on sera pas seulement dans
des postures
sur le caractère thermique
2035 c'est pas la fin pour rouler avec
des véhicules thermiques c'est
l'interdiction de la vente de nouveaux
véhicules thermiques et je ne vois pas
comment nous pourrions défendre un
modèle qui nous rend dépendant d'un
produit que nous ne produisons pas qui
est fait dans des pays qui ne partagent
pas nos valeurs je parle du pétrole
faire en sorte de majorer la part de
l'électricité que nous produisons avec
l'énergie renouvelable et le nucléaire
c'est à la fois bon pour notre économie
bon pour notre climat et bon pour notre
souveraineté les arguments qui
consistent à penser qu'on aurait intérêt
à tergiverser à attendre parce qu'on
irait trop vite sur l'électrique je vous
le dis il me semble être vraiment en
décalage avec les propos qui ont été
tenus il y a quelques minutes à cette
tribune par ceux qui appelaient à ce
contiennent compte de d'urgence
climatique et même par rapport à nos
constructeurs et c'est là-dessus que je
termine
si vous pensez qu'en tenant ces
positions c'est le gouvernement que vous
visez vous vous trompez c'est un sujet
sur lequel l'unanimité européenne s'est
exprimée et le débat c'est celui de
notre compétitivité à venir c'est la
question de savoir si on regarde notre
filière tombée comme c'est le cas par
rapport à des décisions qui n'ont pas
été prises à 10 ans ou si aujourd'hui on
assume une position à l'échelle d'un
marché d'un demi milliard d'habitants
qui nous permettra de retrouver notre
souveraineté sur les usages que nous
avons et qui nous permettra
effectivement de remonter une filière
qui sera compétitive à l'extérieur bien
madame alors madame la Présidente prima
pardon monsieur le Président mais je
peux pas laisser caricaturer nos propos
comme ça monsieur le ministre je suis
désolé les moteurs thermiques
aujourd'hui à base d'énergie fossile il
est clair qu'on veut s'en débarrasser et
qu'on veut enlever cette dépendance que
nous avons par rapport à ces énergies à
ces énergies fossiles mais les moteurs
thermiques demain et vous n'êtes pas
sans l'ignorer car vous avez beaucoup
aucune information il y a aujourd'hui
des projets hydrogène pour remplacer les
énergies fossiles dans des moteurs qui
sont des moteurs thermiques il y a des
projets hydrogène il y a du biocarburant
qu'on fournit et qu'on produit sur notre
territoire et donc le point de la
rapporteur aujourd'hui n'est pas de dire
on ne veut pas d'électricité elle est de
dire aujourd'hui on veut des véhicules
électriques qui soient principalement
issus de nos productions européennes et
qu'on vienne pas subventionner des
véhicules qui sont produits dans des
pays hors Europe avec un bilan carbone
qui est beaucoup plus désastreux que ce
qu'on sait faire aujourd'hui donc ne
caricaturez pas nous propos nous sommes
évidemment tous sur la même le même
objectif qui est de ne plus être
dépendant des énergies fossiles mais
nous avons des divergences de vues sur
la façon d'y arriver
alors je vous propose de passer au vote
monsieur Dominati vous maintenez votre
amendement
ce président trois choses je vais
retirer l'amendement parce que j'étais
convaincu par les arguments de Madame
lavage je l'avais présenté rapidement je
pensais pas que ça ferait un tel débat
je voudrais dire simplement que la prime
la première embauche d'un apprenti c'est
moins cher il n'y a aucun produit en
France et c'est pas un produit de
première nécessité qui est de paix à
l'ordre de 20-25% comme vous le faites
et troisièmement les erreurs
industrielles qui ont été faites il y a
10 ans l'État était actionnaire des deux
principales
des deux principaux constructeurs
automobiles français donc c'est pas
véritablement des erreurs stratégiques
je suis comme d'autres favorable au
développement de l'électrique mais doper
être à contre-chasse à ce point-là c'est
rare donc je serai moins radical pour ce
budget je suivrai bien évidemment
l'amendement de la commission et de
madame lavard qui a très bien exposé le
problème je retire mon abonnement
bien donc nous allons passer au vote sur
l'amendement de Madame Labarde avec un
avis défavorable du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient qu'il est adopté nous
nous continuons je redis encore une fois
que au rythme actuel
ça va durer un certain temps comme
dirait l'autre
903 monsieur Artano il y a donc là
maintenant deux amendements de
discussion commune monsieur Artano
présente le premier 1903 merci monsieur
le Président le prêt à taux zéro
mobilité dans l'expérimentation doit
être lancée en 2023 accompagne le
déploiement des zones à faible mission
mobilité on accompagnant l'acquisition
d'un véhicule peu polluant le présent
amendement propose de financer la
garantie de l'État sur le prêt à taux
zéro mobilité pour un montant de 150
millions d'euros sous calcul est fondé
sur une hypothèse de 50000 ptzm
distribué lors de la première année pour
un moment pour un montant moyen de 4000
euros le coût d'une garantie de l'État à
hauteur de 75% ont été évalués à 150
millions d'euros au regard du faible
taux de sinistralité observé sur le
microcrédit mobilité environ 10% un tel
dispositif aurait un faible coût final
pour les finances publiques 15 millions
d'euros pour ces 50000 PTZ il s'agit
donc pour l'état d'une immobilisation de
trésorerie plutôt que d'une véritable
dépense
et le 622 monsieur Hitman
merci monsieur le Président le l'objet
de l'amendement de Madame Gruny donc ce
qui explique que si la loi climat est
résilience du 22 août 2021 prévoit
l'expérimentation à partir du 1er
janvier 2023 et pour une durée de deux
ans d'un prêt à taux zéro pour
l'accusation d'un véhicule électrique se
dit ce dispositif paraissent sous
calibré le présentement propose donc de
mettre en place un véritable prêt à taux
zéro pour permettre à nos concitoyens
particuliers comme professionnels
d'acquérir mais également de transformer
leur véhicule en finançant la garantie
de l'État un tel dispositif permettrait
d'alléger le coup de l'achat d'un
véhicule propre ou de la transformation
d'un véhicule thermique de simplifier
les démarches avec une avance des aides
existante
merci Madame la rapporteur sur ces deux
amendements
j'ai forcément un peu de faiblesse pour
ces amendements puisque j'étais la
première à porter un amendement visant à
instaurer justement ce prêt à taux zéro
mobilité alors il y avait été une
première fois rejetée par le
gouvernement ça devait être la loi de
finance pour 2020 on avait réussi enfin
à l'instaurer dans la loi climat et
résilience sous la forme d'un dispositif
expérimental donc bien évidemment je
suis j'y suis favorable après j'ai un
problème un peu technique avec votre
amendement à savoir que une garantie
d'État c'est pas portée par la Mission
écologie mais c'est porté par la Mission
engagement financier de l'État dont nous
avons déjà débattu donc il est trop tard
en fait pour le faire
donc c'est une demande de retrait
le ministre
demandeur retrait mais pour vous dire
que nous travaillons un dispositif de ce
type qui puisse s'appliquer des années
prochainement
on continue l'amendement 603 madame
Fillol oui
merci
à sécuriser le financement de contrat de
relance et de transition écologique en
mobilisant un front propre avec des
crédits dédiés on est chez les
collectivités territoriales se voient
confier de plus en plus de missions
concernant la transition écologique la
résilience sanitaire et la rénovation du
patrimoine elles sont un acteur clé de
la mise en oeuvre de la loi climat et
résilience et de la relance à travers
les contrats de relance et de transition
écologique sans moyens suffisants
tentent en termes d'investissement que
de fonctionnement ces plans ne pourront
être mis en oeuvre cette situation
difficile est action tuée par la crise
sanitaire et économique qui engendre des
pertes de recettes significatives pour
les collectivités or aucun mécanisme à
ce jour ne permet de savoir si les
moyens de fonctionnement et
d'investissement sont suffisants et
effici pour mettre les en oeuvre les
politiques publiques c'est pourquoi il
est proposé une enveloppe de 500
millions d'euros pour sécuriser le
financement de ces contrats
oui alors le financement des contrats de
transition écologique aujourd'hui il est
financé par d'autres lignes de crédit et
notamment des lignes de la mission
relation avec les collectivités je pense
notamment à la DS
à la DETR donc en tant que tel la
mission écologique n'est pas forcément
le bon support et si j'ai bien tout
compris du fonctionnement du fond vert
il est prévu que les dispositifs qui
seront financés par le fond vert devront
forcément basculer dans les contrats
dans les CRPE signé par les
collectivités donc on n'a pas besoin
d'être dans un cercle pour bénéficier du
fond vert par contre quand on a
bénéficié du fond vert on est obligé de
basculer dans un CRPE
si j'ai compris enfin donc on a mal
compris donc vous voyez les informations
sont pas plus claires donc en tout cas
sur votre amendement c'est une demande
de retrait et comme ça ça va permettre
au ministre de continuer à expliquer le
fonctionnement du fond vert
monsieur le ministre je vais être très
bref sur le sujet
je suis
défavorable et nous faisons
effectivement une demande de retrait en
considérant que
d'autres crédits existent dans le cadre
du financement du CRPE nous ne lions pas
le fond vert au CRPE notre question pour
l'année qui suit parce qu'on veut qu'il
soit efficace souple fongible ce que
j'ai dit devant la commission quand j'ai
été auditionné c'est qu'à compter de
l'année 2024 on a d'un côté des CRT qui
ne font pas l'objet de financement
fléchés et de l'autre des financements
écologiques qui pourraient nécessiter un
examen approfondi pour savoir ce qui est
ligible on a 40000 projets dans les CRPE
qui sont dormants qui peuvent attendre
potentiellement du coût financement une
des questions qui pourra se poser mais
ça ce sera une vraie co-construction
législative c'est est-ce que demain la
décile la DETR on peut vocation plutôt à
être mis en face des projets des CRPE
puisqu'on a déjà une base de projets
communaux et intercommunaux et à ce
moment-là est-ce que le fond vert pourra
pas en être une composante mais ça n'est
pas le sujet pour l'année 2023 ou la
réponse de la rapporteur est parfaite
pour ce qui concerne les d'autres types
de financement du CRPE et le fond vert
il est en plus de manière à ce qu'on
voit ce que ça donne
donc double avis défavorable
il est maintenu donc je le soumets aux
voix qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté deux
amendements discussion commune
donc le
897 Monsieur artanon Merci monsieur le
Président l'usage du vélo a largement
progressé dans notre pays la hausse des
trajets étant de 28% entre 2019 et 2021
en 4 ans 22000 km d'aménagement cyclable
ont été créés soit 40% d'augmentation
après un premier plan vélo du
gouvernement lancé en 2018 puis abondait
en 2021 par le plan de relance pour un
total de 500 millions d'euros la
consommation des crédits semble indiquer
que les crédits du deuxième plomb vélo
seront insuffisants pour couvrir le
développement des usages dotés de 250
millions d'euros il ne permettra pas
d'atteindre l'objectif de 9% de part
modale en 2024 et de 12% en 2030 le
présente amendement de mon collègue
agricole te propose donc d'abonder le
fond de vélo de 500 millions d'euros
supplémentaires
et Monsieur Fernique pour le suivant
de tout à fait dans le même esprit la
petite différence c'est que le nôtre
c'est 250 millions supplémentaires donc
avec les avec les 250 millions annoncés
on arrive au 500 millions d'euros par an
qui va dans le sens de la proposition du
plan Marshall du vélo porté par la fugue
et Valérie Masson Delmotte
madame la rapporteur à monsieur le
rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président nous avons
donc effectivement deux amendements qui
ont le même objet c'est-à-dire de
consacrer des crédits supplémentaires
aux pistes cyclables l'un à 250 millions
l'autre à 500 millions je voudrais bien
sûr dire tout notre attachement au
développement des mobilités douces
néanmoins en l'espèce pour ces deux
amendements en formulera une une demande
de retrait puisque nous avons quand même
déjà 250 millions d'euros qui sont
inscrits pour 2023 ce qui correspond à
une somme cinq fois supérieure au
montant annuel qui était consacré au
vélo dans le cadre du précédent plan de
la période de
[Musique]
c'est terminé en 2022 voilà 2017-2022
pardon donc pour cette raison nous vous
demandons le retrait peut-être que le
ministre pourrait nous indiquer le
volume qui est envisagé de son a pas le
montant pour cette année mais on n'a pas
le montant pour le plan sur la période
de 2022-2027 donc si on pouvait profiter
de sa retraitement pour avoir cette
information je pense que ça éclairerait
utilement notre assemblée merci monsieur
le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
rapporteur le montant qui a été alloué
et décidé par la première ministre à la
fin du mois de septembre c'est 250
millions d'euros je rappelle quand même
que c'est une somme très fortement
augmentée par rapport à ce qui était
mobilisé ces dernières années c'était
nécessaire parce que le premier plan
vélo a connu un grand succès que les
besoins sont en effet important pour
l'ordre de grandeur je rappelle que on
était sur 350 millions d'euros sur 5 ans
et on passe à 250 millions d'euros sur
une seule année 2023 on va engager avec
Christophe Béchu et les ministres
concernés un appel à projet dès les
premières semaines de 2023 qui lanceront
la consommation de ces 250 millions
d'euros et c'est à l'occasion du premier
comité interministériel sur le vélo que
la première ministre présidera en début
d'année qu'on déterminera une
trajectoire mais avec les 250 millions
d'euros on a de quoi largement je crois
investir pour 2023 tant dans les
infrastructures cyclables que dans des
points de stationnement sécurisé il
faudra en effet au-delà de ces
engagements et crédits de paiement
définir une trajectoire ce sera fait en
début d'année lors du prochain comité
interministériel
cette trajectoire elle doit
effectivement permettre de renforcer
fortement les infrastructures car on
sait que c'est le point déterminant pour
réussir nos objectifs en termes de part
modal la dame a établi des scénarios de
développement de par modèle du vélo qui
montre que si on reste sur les niveaux
actuels on restera scotché sous les 5%
de par modal notre objectif c'était
d'arriver à 9% pour 2024 ça je pense
qu'on y arrivera pas mais c'est de viser
de l'ordre de 12 à 15% pour 2030 merci
donc les amendements sont maintenus je
les soumets au bois
il est retiré monsieur ferdinig vous
maintenez le vôtre
oui alors qui est pour l'amendement
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il ne sont pas adoptés
avant de suspendre la séance je vais
passer la parole à au président rénal
bien c'est le Ministre messieurs les
ministres excusez-moi c'est les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs on a
eu un bon débat
de qualité on a beaucoup précisé les
choses et merci Monsieur les ministres
de vous y être prêté et au rapporteur
d'avoir pointé les difficultés on a donc
eu un bon débat
ce soir mais ce petit problème c'est
qu'on a fait du vin à l'heure du vin
amendement donc avec ce rythme
voilà vous pourrez prendre le train si
vous en avez un directement sans
repasser par le lit vous voyez ce que je
veux dire
à ce rythme c'est du 5 heures du matin
bon alors
tout à l'heure on va reprendre les
débats et ce que je vous proposerai
c'est d'avoir un débat moins intéressant
forcément parce que plus resserré je
suis obligé de vous le dire comme ça et
je crois que c'est pour le bien de tous
il y a Euro 2 phases dans la nuit
jusqu'à 2h du matin bonhomme allant ça
passe après 2h du matin nos débats chute
en qualité je vais vous le dire comme ça
donc autant s'y préparer et dès 9h30
être dans un rythme beaucoup plus
soutenu ça veut dire des présentations
demandement extrêmement rapide
extrêmement rapide avoir une réponse des
rapporteurs plus courts des ministres
extrêmement synthétiques et de passer à
un vote voilà donc je vous y encourage
je vous y encourage d'autant plus que à
la fin
ça se trouve comme ça vous avez un super
article qui s'appelle l'article 42 TER
qui parle juste du bouclier tarifaire de
l'amortisseur pour les ménages petite
entreprise et collectivités locales
c'est à dire qu'à la fin vous avez
quelque chose un petit sujet voilà et un
montant et comment dire un sujet
technique bon donc je vous propose de
garder du temps pour se débat qui
devrait pas être abordé après une heure
du matin si on veut faire ça il faut
aider vraiment le président de séance à
avoir un rythme qui permette d'y être
c'est à dire à plus de 30 amendements à
l'heure voilà donc qu'on essaie de
régler comme ça les choses sinon ça va
partir
voilà je vous laisse le dernier
vocabulaire bonne soirée
bien je vais suspendre la séance elle
sera reprise à 21h35 pour la suite de la
l'examen de la mission écologique
développement et mobilité durable la
séance est suspendue